GOOD AFTERNOON.
THIS WILL BEGIN TODAY'S SUB ONE
HEARING ON WEDNESDAY APRIL
FOURTH.
AND IF I MAY HAVE A CHAIR PER
ARGUED IF WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
ISSUE EIGHT FIRST.
IT'S A RARITY THAT WE HAVE THE
CHAIR OF APPROPRIATIONS HEREIN
WOULD LIKE HER TO.
BITER OF UP FRONT FIRST.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AND THINK PARALLELING THE TO
PERCENT EARLY I NEED TO CATCH A
FLIGHT.
.
AS YOU KNOW DIAPER NEED IT'S A
WELL DOCUMENTED URGENT PROBLEM
THAT WE MUST CONTINUE TO ADDRESS
IF WE WANT TO BREAK THE CYCLE OF
POVERTY FOR SO MANY SINGLE
PARENTS AND FAMILIES ACROSS THE
STATE. COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
WORKING TO ADDRESS DIAPER NEED
PROVIDED CRITICAL SAFETY NET FOR
LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
AND EVEN SOME MIDDLE INCOME
FAMILIES.
THERE'S MORE THAN TWENTY TO
DIAPER BANKS IN CALIFORNIA
CERTIFIED BY THE NATIONAL DIAPER
BANK NETWORK AND IT DISTRIBUTES
NEARLY TEN MILLION DIAPERS A
YEAR. AND ALTHOUGH LAST YEAR WE
DID BECOME THE FIRST IN THE
NATION TO RUN A DIAPER PROGRAM
AND HAVE I'M A POLICY WHEREBY
CAO WORKS RECIPIENTS CAN GET BAD
GET REIMBURSEMENTS FOR DIAPERS.
THEY'RE STILL A HUGE UNMET NEED
THAT ON MANY OF OUR DIAPER BANKS
HELP TO MEET.
OUR PROPOSAL REQUESTS A ONE TIME
ALLOCATION OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICE TO ESTABLISH A
DIAPER BANG GRANT FUND.
THESE GRANTS WOULD BE ISSUED FOR
THE PURPOSE OF INVESTING AND AND
BUILDING CAPACITY FOR EXISTING
CERVI DIAPER BANKS AND
NONPROFITS. THAT HAVE SOME
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE TO
COLLECT AND DISTRIBUTE DIAPERS
TO PARENTS IN NEED. THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD REVIEW
PROPOSALS FROM ELIGIBLE DIAPER
BANKS IN NON PROFITS TO ALLOW
GRANTS TO PRIMARILY FUND THE
COLLECTION AND DISTRIBUTION
DIAPERS STORAGE COSTS IN THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF NEW DIAPER
BANKS.
AGAIN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD EXTEND
DIAPER ACCESS TO POPULATIONS ARE
CURRENTLY ARE NOT SERVE THEIR
WELFARE TO WORK ADVANCE A
GROWING MOVEMENT CALIFORNIA
TOWARDS ESTABLISHING COMMUNITY
BASED SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS THIS
URGENT NEED FOR LOW INCOME AND
MIDDLE INCOME FAMILIES.
MY OFFICE EXPORTS WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE IN DEPARTMENT ON
THIS REQUEST PARTICULAR
PARTICULARLY TO CLARIFY
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
BRAINS THANK YOU FOR THIS
CONSIDERATION AND I RESPECTFULLY
URGE.
YOU'RE AT SOME POINT SUPPORT OF
THIS ITEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND NEXT WE HAVE JUST THE BIRTH
OF THANK YOU JUSTIN BARTHA WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEMBERS WE CLASS.
I'M ALSO ON THE BOARD OF THE
NATIONAL DEBT BURBANK NETWORK.
WE HAVE RECENTLY HAD CONDUCTED A
STUDY OF A DEBORAH BANKS TO SEE
WHAT THEIR ECONOMIC IMPACT IS.
I'M AND AND THE CITY WAS
PROFOUND WE FOUND WAS THAT MORE
THAN HALF OF PEOPLE WHO RECEIVE
DIAPERS FROM DEBORAH BANKS ARE
WORKING. THAT THEY OFTEN REPORT
HAVING TO MISS WORK BECAUSE.
OF NOT HAVING ENOUGH DIAPERS
FOR THE CHILDCARE PROVIDER.
.
WE FOUND THAT WHEN THEY HAVE THE
ASSISTANCE OF A DIAPER BANK THE
CHILDREN HAVE LESS DIAPER
RASHES-AND LESS URINARY TRACT
INFECTIONS.
AT A RECENT STUDY THAT WE ALSO
WORKED ON WITH A YALE UNIVERSITY
PROFESSOR IN CHILD DEVELOPMENT
FOUND THAT.
OF THE MOST.
SIGNIFICANT.
BECAUSE.
OF MATERNAL DEPRESSION THAT THE
INDICATOR THAT CAN INDICATE
WHETHER OR NOT A PARENT WILL
EXPERIENCE MATERNAL DEPRESSION A
PATERNAL DEPRESSION.
IS ACTUALLY LACK OF DIAPER.
HELPED LACK OF DIAPERS FOR
THEIR INFANT.
THIS WAS PROFOUND TO ME
ESPECIALLY HAVING SPENT TWENTY
YEARS IN THE ANTI HUNGER.
COMMUNITY I WOULD HAVE ASSUMED
THAT LACK OF FOOD.
BUT THAT CAME IN SECOND.
SECOND TO NOT HAVING ENOUGH
DIAPERS AND WE KNOW WHAT THAT
THE IMPACT ON CHILD DEVELOPMENT
IS FOR A CHILD ON THAT THAT HAS
A PARENT WHO IS DEPRESSED THEY
ARE LESS LIKELY TO BE ENGAGED AS
AN INFANT. LESS LIKELY TO BE
HAPPY THEY HAVE STRESS
INDICATORS THAT ARE HIGHER THAN
OTHER INFANTS.
AT THE BEGINNING EXPERIENCING
DEPRESSION AT THE AGE OF OF FOUR
MONTHS FIVE MONTHS AS AN INFANT.
AND THESE.
THESE IMPACTS WILL I CARRY
FORWARD THROUGHOUT THEIR YEARS
OF EDUCATION DEVELOPMENT.
AND INTO ADULTHOOD.
SO FOR FOR THIS AND SO MANY
REASONS WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
THAT ARE DISCONNECTED TO THE
WELFARE TO WORK PROGRAM.
AND NOT ABLE TO RECEIVE THE
ASSISTANCE ALREADY I PUT IN
PLACE TO THE BUDGET A LAST YEAR
DO HAVE CONNECTIVITY TO.
TO DEBORAH BANKS AND OTHER
ASSISTANCE FOR DIAPERS
CALIFORNIA ONLY HAS A FEW DIAPER
BANKS AND THIS ASSISTANCE WE
THINK WILL REALLY HELP DEVELOP A
FOOD BANKS AND OTHER AT
ASSISTING AGENCIES TO.
TO BUILD THE CAPACITY TO
DISTRIBUTE DIAPERS TO LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND FOR THIS REASON WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU COME WE HAVE LISTED ON
THE PANEL. DIRECTOR LIGHT BORN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ARE L. L.
IF YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS THAT
YOU WANTED TO ADD TO THIS
PROPOSAL.
YOU TOOK THE KNIFE.
SO THAT'S JUST. A COVER FINANCE
HER WORDS I THINK WE JUST NOTE
THAT WE WOULD STILL NEED TIME TO
LOOK INTO THIS PROPOSAL.
NOT WITHSTAND THE POLICY MERIT
AND WOULD HAVE TO LOOK INTO
WHETHER OR NOT A STATE RESOURCES
ARE NEEDED TO IMPLEMENT.
GREAT. GOT NEXT WE WILL TAKE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE IT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ENTER SHANE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF FOOD BANKS IN SUPPORT WERE
VERY PROUD THAT THE SAN DIEGO
FOOD BANK. IN THE.
MEMBERS DISTRICT HAS A DATA
BANK ON BUT NOT ALL DOING WITH
CITY SPENT THINK.
THANK YOU.
KEVIN AS THEM CHORUS A
CALIFORNIA WILL FOR ITS
ORGANIZATION.
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SING NO MORE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE EIGHT WILL BRING IT UP TO
THE DYESS FOR ANY COMMENTS
PEOPLE MAY HAVE.
I'LL ADD MY OWN TWO CENTS IF I
CAN.
I'M.
PROUD AS A PARENT THAT WE ARE
NOW THROUGH THE DIAPER STAGE.
THAT WAS NOT TRUE LAST YEAR AND
YET I RECOGNIZE HOW MUCH OF A
STRESS THIS IS ON YOUNG FAMILY.
AND REALLY APPRECIATE THIS I
REQUEST FROM.
WITH THAT WE WILL.
I AM I I HAVE TWO CHILDREN AND I
CALLED THE MEXICAN TWINS BECAUSE
THEY'RE FOURTEEN MONTHS APART
AND SO I WAS DOING THAT DUAL
DIAPERS THE WHOLE ENTIRE TIME
AND IT'S IT REALLY IS STRESSFUL
AND. COSCO'S.
IT IS GREAT BUT IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
AND WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO GET DIAPERS IT'S
REALLY REALLY DIFFICULT.
NOT ONLY FOR BABY SITTING YEAH
PURPOSES BITE YOU KNOW JUST TO
RUN YOUR OWN LIFE SO THANK YOU
FOR THE BILL.
YOU ARE THE PROPOSAL.
AND THEM HOLD LEAVE IT.
I THIS ITEM OPEN BUT HE WANTED
TO SAY YOU'VE HELD THE BAR UP
HIGH FOR MANY OF US TO.
IMPLEMENTED AND INSTITUTE FOOD
ARE DIAPER BANKS WITHIN OUR
FEEDBACKS AND SO. MANY OF US
HAVE OUR JOBS TO DO BOTH HERE IN
THE CAPITAL BUT ALSO LOCALLY.
THANK YOU FOR THIS PROPOSAL AND
WE WILL HOLD THAT I DON'T. THINK
YOU.
QUILTED.
SINCE WE HAVE A QUORUM I'D LIKE
TO ESTABLISH THAT FIRST AND
MAKE.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA HERE HARPER.
MATHIS RUBIO.
WOULD.
QUORUM.
GREAT WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ISSUE
ONE
.
PLEASE PLEASE BUT WHEN YOU'RE
RIGHT.
ALL.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I'M WILL LIKE BORN DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES.
.
WE ARE SORT OF HERE TO DO THE
BROAD CAL WORKS REVIEW AND I'M
GOING TO TURN IT OVER. TO KIM
JOHNSON WHO RUNS THE CAL WORKS
AND CHILDCARE BRANCH
FOR OUR DEPARTMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON I CHAIR MEMBERS
AND STAFF CAN JOHNSON CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
I'D YOUR GENDER DOES A GREAT JOB
IN LAYING OUT THE OVERVIEW OF
WHERE THE COW WORKS PROGRAM AT
IS TODAY AGAIN. CAL WORKS IS
CALIFORNIA'S VERSION OF THE
TEMPORARY AID TO NEEDY FAMILIES
PROGRAM PROVIDING CASH
ASSISTANCE EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
AND SUPPORTIVE SERVICES TO THE
FAMILIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA. WE
ARE SEEING.
A HISTORIC LOW IN TERMS OF
CASELOAD AS SINCE PRE RECESSION
LEVELS OF AROUND FOUR HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND AS
SERVING A LITTLE OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDREN ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
.
I WANTED TO KNOW THE COUPLE OF
THINGS RELATED TO THE CALL OUT
ESSENTIALLY OF POVERTY AT
REALLY.
.
ACCESS OF OUR PROGRAM. OUT IN IN
MEETING FAMILIES WITH OUR.
.
OUR PROGRAM DESIGNED OF
SUPPORTING CHILDREN WHO.
ARTS OFF OF.
ART ART
IF THEIR PARENTS ARE AND OFF
AID.
AND WE ARE SERVING CLOSER TO
FIFTY THREE PERCENT OF AT
CHILDREN IN POVERTY ACROSS
CALIFORNIA VERSUS THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE OF AROUND TWENTY PERCENT
FOR OTHER STATES THAT WE ARE.
DOING THAT AS A GOOD A GOOD WAY
BY OUR PROGRAM. IN TERMS OF WORK
PARTICIPATION RATES.
WE ARE SUCCESSFULLY MEETING THE
ALL OVERALL AT CAL WORKS WORK
PARTICIPATION RATE AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AT THE FIFTY
PERCENT THRESHOLD. WE ARE HAVE
BEEN OVER SIXTY PERCENT OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS.
AS WELL AS.
BAD THEN REDUCING OUR PENALTIES
SO LOOKING.
AT ORIGINALLY WHAT WE HAD AT
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION EXPOSURE
IN TERMS OF PENALTIES FOR NOT
MEETING QUIRK DISSIPATION RATE
WE'RE STILL WORKING ON THE TWO
PARENT RATE WHICH IS A SMALLER
PORTION OF OUR CASELOAD. WE'VE
REDUCE THAT DOWN TO FORTY POINT
TWO MILLION I'M IN TERMS OF
POTENTIAL EXPOSURE. I'M RELATED
TO THE AT WORK PARTICIPATION
RATE. ALSO JUST WANTED TO NOTE
THAT THE WORK PARTICIPATION RATE
IS ONE MEASURE I'M WITHIN THE
CAL WORKS PROGRAM AND YOUR
GENDER LAYS OUT A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE CAL WORKS AT OUTCOMES
IN ACCOUNTABILITY REVIEW. AND
INITIATIVE THAT HAS.
THAT WE ARE UNDERTAKING AND
THIS IS REALLY.
BEEN A VERY ROBUST STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS AT THAT INCLUDES MANY AT
DIFFERENT AS STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
PROCESS INCLUDING CURRENT FORMER
AT CALYX.
PARTICIPANTS AS WELL AND WHAT
THIS WHAT WE ARE ESTABLISHING
OUR NEW WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN
DEMONSTRATE THE SUCCESS OF THE
COW WORKS PROGRAM AT BOTH IN
PROCESS AND OUTCOME MEASURES BUT
LOOKING AT. NOT ONLY EMPLOYMENT
RATES IN IN THE THRESHOLD OF
EMPLOYMENT HOURS THE COW WORKS
PROGRAM REQUIRES BUT ALSO
LOOKING AT EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT PROGRAM ENTRY AND
EXITS AND ALSO HAS OPPORTUNITIES
FOR LOOKING AT CHILD AND FAMILY
WELL BEING OUTCOMES SO. WE ARE
HOPING THAT TOWARDS THE END.
OF THIS YEAR THAT THE LATE FALL
WE WILL ACTUALLY HAVE A GOOD
SOLID SENSE OF WHAT THOSE
MEASURES WILL LOOK LIKE.
I IN AND ALLOW AT COUNTY
SOMETIMES A PLANNED AND AUTOMATE
SYSTEMS TO BE ABLE TO CAPTURE
SOME OF THOSE MEASURES AB IN A
ENACT CLEAR WAY. SO THAT WE ARE
FULLY LOOKING AT IMPLEMENTING
THE NEW CAL OR PROCESS BY JULY
ONE OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN.
AGAIN IT IT WILL BE A THREE
YEAR CYCLE.
SO COUNTIES WILL SENSUALLY BE
LOOKING AT DOING A SELF
ASSESSMENT TO IDENTIFY HOW THEY
ARE DOING ON THOSE MEASURES THAT
WE IDENTIFIED AGREE UPON.
I THEY WOULD USE A STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS LOCALLY TO LOOK AT THE
CONTEXT OF WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
THE ECONOMY OF THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND SO FORTH. AND THE CREATES
BASICALLY.
AB PLAN I'M ON A PRE
IMPROVEMENT ON WHERE THEY'D LIKE
SAID TO LOOK AT SOME MEASURES OF
SUCCESS SO. AND THAT BEGINS A
THREE YEAR CYCLE IN THAT'S AT
MODELED AFTER OFF OF THE CHILD
WELFARE EXAMPLE IN AB SIX THREE
SIX OUT SOMETIME AGO.
AGAIN I WAS UP THERE SOME CPAS
OTHER SPECIFIC OUR. PORTS IT
PUSH PORTIONS OF THE GENDER THAT
I'M HAPPY TO COVER IN MORE DEPTH
BUT WE'LL LEAVE IT THERE FOR
QUESTIONS OR OR ANYTHING OF
SCRIPT FOCUSED.
THANK YOU FOR THE OVERVIEW
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HELLO ANY
COMMENTS.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ON PLEASE
EXCUSE ME TED ALMOST LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AND IT ISN'T THE MATERIAL IN
THE IN THE AGENDA WHICH IS
RATHER THOROUGH ON THE ONLY
THING OUR OFFICE WOULD NOT AT
THIS POINT IS THAT. SEVERAL
MONTHS OF CASELOAD HAVE COMMANDS
INTO MINISTRATION LAST PUT
TOGETHER A FORECAST THAT IT'S
BUDGET PUT OF PROPOSALS BUILT
ON.
OUR OFFICE LOOKED AT THOSE SIX
MONTHS OF NEW DATA AND DIDN'T
FIND ANY REASON TO THINK THAT
THE DATATREND WOULD.
INDICATE THAT THE MAY REVISION
CASELOAD ESTIMATES WOULD DIFFER
SUBSTANTIALLY FROM THE JANUARY
PROPOSAL STORE FOLLOWING THOSE
MONTH TO MONTH BUT THINGS LOOK
ON TRACK.
GREAT THANK YOU.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE ONE
AT THIS TIME.
SEEN NONO BRING IT TO THE
DIVESTMENT QUESTIONS WE MAY
HAVE.
WITH THAT WILL HOLD THIS ITEM
OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE TO.
THIS.
WE'RE GONNA START WITH CHRISTIAN
SCHUMACHER IF WE CAN AND THEN
FRANK MECCA.
HELLO MY NAME IS KRISTEN
SCHUMACHER AND I'M A SENIOR
POLICY ANALYST AT THE CALIFORNIA
BUDGET POLICY CENTER THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY SPEAKER
TODAY.
AMIR MERCK THE PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF CALVERT'S GRANTS
ANOTHER MYSTERY HOW COVER
SCREENS HAVE LOST VALUE OVER
TIME.
WELL ALSO COMPARE KELBERG'S
GRANT LEVELS TO A COUPLE
DIFFERENT PARTY THRESHOLDS AS
WELL AS THE BASIC FAMILY BUDGET
IN A COUPLE DIFFERENT COUNTIES
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE HELLO I PROVIDED. INCLUDES A
NUMBER OF CHARTS A DEMONSTRATE
MY KEY POINTS TODAY IF YOU LIKE
TO FOLLOW ALONG AND I LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT IN CASE THEY
OTHERWISE NO. WHEN I SPEAK OF
CAL WORKS GRANT LEVELS I'M
REFERRING TO THE MAXIMUM MONTHLY
GRANT FOR A FAMILY OF THREE AND
A HIGH COST COUNTY.
THE FIRST HURT ON PAGE TWO SHOWS
OF THE CUPBOARDS GRANTS HAVE
LOST MORE THAN ONE THIRD OF ITS
VALUE SINCE THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF CAL WORKS IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT.
DURING THIS PERIOD STATE
POLICYMAKERS FRICKLEY SUSPENDED
AND THAT ULTIMATELY ELIMINATED
THE COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT OR
THE COLA.
THIS ENSURED THE COOLER ENSURES
THAT THE VALUE THE GRANTS KEEP
PACE WITH INFLATION.
IN ADDITION POLICYMAKERS ALSO
REDUCE THE GRANT LEVELS DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION WHICH ALSO
ERODED THE VALUE OF COVER
EXPERIENCE TODAY.
THE POLICY MAKERS HAD INCREASE
GRANT LEVELS ANNUALLY TO ACCOUNT
FOR INFLATION THE MAXIM CAO
GROUP WITH CAL WORKS GRANT. BE
ONE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX DOLLARS PER MONTH IN
THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN STATE
FISCAL YEAR. THIS IS FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO DOLLARS
HIGHER THAN THE PROPOSED
PROPOSED VALUE OF JUST SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN DOLLARS.
FEELING THE MUSCLE INCREASE
GRANTS FOR INFLATION EACH YEAR.
SEVERELY PRODUCES THE RESOURCES
THAT PARENTS COULD USE TO
PROVIDE FOOD FOR THE FAMILY OR
PAY THEIR RENT.
IT'S LIKE A VEST AND CAL WORKS
GRANTS IS EXPRESSLY TROUBLING
WHEN COMPARED TO THE COST OF
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA. THE CHART
ON PAGE THREE SHOWS THAT THE
MEDIAN RENT AND HIGH COST
COUNTIES HAS FAR OUTPACED CAO
WORKS GRANTS IN RECENT YEARS.
CURRENTLY THE CAL WORKS GRANT
FALLS NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY
FOUR DOLLARS SHORT OF THE COST
OF COVERING A TWO BEDROOM RENTAL
AND HIGH COST COUNTY.
EVEN A LOW COST COUNTY SUCH AS
FRESNO FOR SACRAMENTO MEDIAN
RENTS ARE MUCH HIGHER THAN THE
CAL WORKS GRANT FOR A FAMILY OF
THREE.
THE CALYX GRANDPA'S THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR DOLLARS
SHORT OF THE MEDIAN RENT FOR TWO
BEDROOM HOME IN THOSE COUNTIES.
BECAUSE COVERS GRANTS HAVE LOST
VALUE MAXIMUM CAO WORKS GRANT IN
HIGH COST COUNTY FILL SO THE
FAMILIES OUT OF THE POVERTY. THE
POVERTY IS DEFINED AS FIFTY
PERCENT OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LINE. AND THAT MEANS FOR A
FAMILY OF THREE. MAKING ENDS
MEET ON LESS THAN ELEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR.
IN FACT THE CHART ON PAGE FOUR
SHOWS THE ABSENT A GREAT
INCREASE IN THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR
THE CAL WORKS GRANT WILL REMAIN
BELOW THE POVERTY LINE FOR THE
ELEVENTH STRAIGHT YEAR.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE ANALYZE
MAXIMUM TOWER CAO WORKS GREAT
WILL BE JUST FORTY ONE PERCENT
OF THE FEDERAL PARTY LINE.
AS DEMONSTRATED BY THE JOINT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING THIS PAST
MONDAY ON ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES WE KNOW THAT LIVING
IN DEEP POVERTY HAS PROFOUND
EFFECT ON CHILDREN AFFECTING THE
WELL BEING WELL INTO ADULTHOOD.
BUT EXPERTS CHART SHOW HOW THE
MAXIMUM COVERAGE GRANT STACKS UP
AGAINST POVERTY THRESHOLDS IN
THE BUDGET CENTERS MAKING ENDS
MEET BASIC FAMILY BUDGETS.
THE TURN PAGE BY PROVIDES DATA
FOR THE SANTA ROSA METRO REGION
AND SEE IT AND CINEMA COUNTY.
THE BLUE BAR ON THE LEFT IS THE
MONTHLY OFFICIAL FEDERAL PARTY
THRESHOLD FOR TWENTY SIXTEEN
WHICH IS ABOUT SIXTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER MONTH ACROSS THE
ENTIRE U. S. THIS. VALUE DOES
NOT VERY GEOGRAPHICALLY AND THAT
BAR WILL REMAIN THE SAME ACROSS
ALL THREE OF YOUR CHARTS.
AS YOU CAN SEE BY THE REDLINE
MACAU WORKS CURRENT IS ABOUT
HALF OF THIS PARTY THRESHOLD.
THE GREEN BAR IN THE MIDDLE
AFFECTS THE SUPPLEMENTAL POVERTY
SPECIAL FOR THE SANTA ROSA
REGION.
THAT'S CAN PROVIDE A MORE
ACCURATE PICTURE OF POVERTY FOR
MANY REASONS ONE OF WHICH IS
THAT IT DOES VERY GEOGRAPHICALLY
AND SANTA ROSA. THE MAXIMUM
GREAT IS ROUGHLY A THIRD OF THE
SUPPLEMENTAL PARTY THRESHOLD OF
ABOUT TWENTY TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER MONTH.
AND FINALLY THE ORANGE BROWN THE
RIGHT SHOWS THE BASIC FAMILY
BUDGET FOR ONE PARENT FAMILY
WITH TWO CHILDREN.
THIS VALUES FROM THE CALIFORNIA
BUDGET POLICY CENTERS MAKING
ENDS MEET REPORT WHICH WE
RELEASED THIS PAST DECEMBER THAT
SHOWS HOW MUCH INCOME FAMILIES
NEED TO AFFORD THE BAICS SUCH
AS HOW DO YOU HOUSING FOOD
HEALTH CARE JUST NAME A FEW.
FOR EXAMPLE WE ESTIMATE THAT A
SINGLE PARENT WITH TWO KIDS NEED
ABOUT FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
PER MONTH AND CINEMA COUNTY JUST
A FOR THE BASICS.
IT'S NOT A COUNTY THE CAL WORKS
GRANT IS THIRTEEN PERCENT OF THE
MAKING ENDS MEET BUDGET FOR THAT
COUNTY.
THE TERM PAGE SIX PROVIDE
SIMILAR DATA FOR THE LOS ANGELES
MATURE REGION THE STORY HERE IS
VERY SIMILAR TO SANTA ROSA AND
SONOMA COUNTY. AS ILLUSTRATED BY
THE BRIGHT RED LINE THE MAXIMUM
CALPERS GRANT FALLS FAR SHORT OF
THE SUPPLEMENTAL POVERTY
THRESHOLD AND THE MAKING AND
SPEAK FAMILY BUDGET. JUST THIRTY
ONE AND THIRTEEN PERCENT
RESPECTIVELY OF THOSE TWO
VALUES.
FINALLY THE CHART ON PAGE SEVEN
SHOWS DATA FOR THE FRESNO
METROPOLITAN AND FRESNO COUNTY.
FRESNO IS CONSIDERED A LOW COST
COUNTY IN THE COMICS PROGRAM SO
THE CELTICS GRANT LEVEL IS LOWER
TO REFLECT THIS GEOGRAPHIC
VARIATION. HERE THE MAXIMUM
GRANT FOR FAMILY THREE IS FORTY
TWO PERCENT OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY THRESHOLD THIRTY NINE
PERCENT OF THE S. P. M. AND
SIXTY PERCENT OF THE MAKING ENDS
MEET FAMILY BUDGETS.
IN CONCLUSION THERE IS ABUNDANCE
OF EVIDENCE THAT CAL WORKS
GRANTS FALL FAR SHORT OF
SUPPORTING CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
IN CALIFORNIA. FEELINGS OF LOSS
RESOURCES DUE TO THE SUSPENSION
AND THE EVENTUAL ELIMINATION OF
THE COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT
CALIFORNIA. DUE TO THIS THEM OUT
THAT MAXIMUM COVERAGE GRANT
FILLS OF THE FAMILIES OUT OF THE
POVERTY.
WE KNOW THAT POVERTY IMPOSES A
VERY STEEP COST ON CHILDREN OR
FAMILIES AND ON THE STATE'S AND
CAL WORKS PROGRAM IS OVERDUE FOR
A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT.
THE FINAL SLIDE IS OUR PROJECT
INFORMATION THE BUT IT CENTER
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS AT
THE END OF THE PANEL BUT ALSO
AFTER THE HEARING TODAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS SCHUMACHER
NEXT WEEK FREDRIKA THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FRANK MECCA
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
AND TODAY I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
A LARGE COALITION.
OF INTERESTED GROUPS IN THE
STATE WHO ARE HERE TO URGE NAM A
COWARD'S GRANT INCREASED AND
DEEP POVERTY.
FOR CHILDREN WHO LIVE IN THAT
PROGRAM AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE GRANT LEVELS KEEP UP WITH
INFLATION SO WE DON'T. CONTINUE
TO HAVE THE EROSION AND
SCHUMACHER TALKED ABOUT.
YESTERDAY HAD THE PLEASURE TO
PARTICIPATE IN YOUR IN THE SUB
TO US. HEARING ON ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES AND WE
LEARNED.
FROM EXPERTS IN THE STATE WHO
ARE DEALING WITH CHILDREN ABOUT.
THE REALLY DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS
OF ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
ON CHILDREN WE ALSO LEARNED THAT
LIVING IN POVERTY PARTICULARLY
DEEP POVERTY IS AMONG THE MOST
PERNICIOUS.
OF ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
AND.
KNOWING WHAT WE KNOW BASED ON
THAT HEARING ABOUT THE RESEARCH
HAS BEEN TELLING US FOR AWHILE.
IN KNOWING THAT WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST CHILD POVERTY RATE IN
THE NATION.
AND KNOWING THAT WE HAVE.
A DANGEROUSLY HIGH NUMBER OF
VERY POOR CHILDREN WHO ARE
LIVING IN A STATE OF NEAR
DESTITUTION AND THAT WE SHOULD
CALL IT WHAT IT IS.
I'M AND KNOWING THAT WE CAN DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT. AND NOT
DOING ANYTHING ABOUT IT IS JUST
SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE. AND THE
CURRENT CONDITION.
THAT CHILDREN THIS PROGRAM LIVE
IN IS A STAIN ON OUR STATE.
THE SCIENCE IS CLEAR OF TALKED
ABOUT THIS BEFORE.
LIVING IN DEEP POVERTY AS A
DEVASTATING EFFECT ON CHILDREN.
IT'S TOXIC STRESS THE DAMAGES
THEY'RE DEVELOPING BRAINS
CHILDREN LIVING IN POVERTY HAD
NOW AVERAGE OF SEVEN TO TEN
PERCENT LESS GRAY MATTER. IN THE
FRONTAL LOBE TEMPORAL LOBE IN
THE HIPPOCAMPUS
THE AREAS OF THE BRAIN TIED TO
LEARNING AND EDUCATIONAL
FUNCTIONING.
THEN CHILDREN WHO WHO ARE NOT
POOR.
GROWING UP POOR IS A LIFETIME OF
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES IT
DECREASES THE LIKELY HAD DICK
CHILDREN GRADUATE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL. IT LESSENS THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT THERE.
GAINFULLY I'M EMPLOYED AND A
PRODUCTIVE EARNING ADULTS.
ON THEY SUFFER FROM NEGATIVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES
NEGATIVE MENTAL HEALTH OUTCOMES
MORE LIKELY TO HAVE CONTACT WITH
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
DEEP POVERTY AND POVERTY FUELS
THE INTERGENERATIONAL CYCLE OF
POVERTY.
POOR CHILDREN ARE MORE LIKELY TO
BECOME POOR DOLLS.
NEARLY HALF OF ADULTS WHO ARE
PERSISTENTLY POOR DURING THEIR
CHILDHOOD.
LIVED IN POVERTY A THEMSELVES AT
THE AGE OF FIVE
COMPARE TO LESS THAN ONE PERCENT
OF ADULTS WHO NEVER EXPERIENCED
POVERTY AS CHILDREN.
IF WE WANT TO STOP THE CYCLE OF
POVERTY WE NEED TO STOP HAVING
KIDS GROWING UP.
SO DEEPLY IN IT.
I'M PARTY ALSO AFFECTS THE
PARENTS ABILITY TO MOVE FROM
WELFARE TO WORK.
WHEN YOU'RE FOCUSED DATA DAY IS
YOUR BASIC SURVIVAL
HOW I FEED MY CHILD WHERE WILL
WE LIVE TONIGHT.
IT'S DIFFICULT AN UNREASONABLE
TO THINK THAT A PERSON LIVING IN
THAT A SEVERE ECONOMIC
CIRCUMSTANCE. CAN FOCUS ON THE
EDUCATIONAL AND JOB READINESS
TYPES OF ACTIVITIES THAT THE CAL
WORKS PROGRAMS.
OFFERS SO WERE ALSO UNDERMINING
WANTED TO KEEP.
UP.
GOALS OF THE PROGRAM THAT IS
HELPING PEOPLE MOVE FROM WELFARE
TO WORK. ON IF WEEK.
CONTINUALLY REQUIRED THAT THEY
LIVE IN A DEEP STATE OF POVERTY
THE GOOD NEWS AS WE KNOW HOW TO
REVERSE THE DAMAGE.
INCREASING THE RESOURCES OF VERY
POOR FAMILIES WORKS THE RESEARCH
TELLS US.
THAT IF LOOK AT VERY LOW INCOME
FAMILIES IMPROVE THEIR FINANCIAL
WELL BEING IT VASTLY IMPROVES
THE WELL BEING OF THEIR
CHILDREN.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT EVEN MODEST
INCREASES IN DISPOSABLE INCOME
MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE IN
IMPROVING WHILE BEING.
MONEY MIGHT NOT BE AND IS NOT
THE MOST CRITICAL INGREDIENT IN
CHILD REARING.
BUT THE RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THE
ABILITY TO PROVIDE BASIC SUCH AS
FOOD SHELTER HEALTH CARE
EDUCATION MAKES A SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCE IN CHILDREN'S ABILITY
TO THRIVE AS ADULTS.
INCREASE HOUSEHOLD INCOME CAN
DECREASE MARITAL STRESS LOWER
REPORTED DRUG AND ALCOHOL USAGE
INCREASE PARENTAL SUPERVISION
AND INVOLVEMENT AND STIMULATES
HEALTHY BRAIN DEVELOPMENT OF
THEIR CHILDREN.
THERE'S THERE'S I'M A A NUMBER
OF EMERGING STUDIES.
WHERE THEY TESTED PROVIDING
RELATIVELY MODEST AMOUNTS OF
INCREASED INCOME TO VERY POOR
FAMILIES ONE STUDY OF VERY POOR
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES THAT
RECEIVED MONEY FROM INDIAN GET
MONEY FROM INDIAN GAMING?
I'M WHAT THEY FOUND THAT EVEN IN
VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
CHILDREN'S EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT WENT UP THERE
BEHAVIORAL PROBLEMS WENT DOWN
FAMILY FUNCTIONING IMPROVED.
.
WE KNOW HOW TO REVERSE AND
PREVENT THE EFFECTS OF THE TOXIC
STRATHEARN CHILDREN'S BRAINS.
LET ME LET ME BECAUSE IF I COULD
BY IMAGINING A SCENARIO WHERE WE
KNEW OF AN ENVIRONMENTAL FACTOR
PATHOGEN THAT WAS IN THE AIR IN
THE WATER.
AND WE KNEW THE DAMAGE IT DID TO
THE BRAINS OF DEVELOPING CHILD.
WE ALSO KNOW HOW TO A RACKET.
ARM WE WOULDN'T HESITATE.
WE WOULD WE WOULD NOT HESITATE
BECAUSE WE VALUE CHILDREN AND WE
WANT HEALTHY CHILDREN TO THRIVE
BECAUSE IT'S GOOD FOR THEM IT'S
MORALLY THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
AND IT'S THE RIGHT THING FOR
SOCIETY WE KNOW ALL THOSE
THINGS.
WE KNOW WHAT'S CAUSING THE
PROBLEM AND WE KNOW HOW TO.
TO FIX IT AND TO NOT DO SO WE
AYE I THINK IS UNACCEPTABLE WHY
IT'S SO DIFFICULT.
THINK ABOUT.
MORE CASH ASSISTANCE FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES I'M IN SPITE OF
WHAT WE HAVE KNOWN FOR YEARS
THIS ISN'T SOMETHING WE LEARNED
JUST YESTERDAY. I THINK REALLY
GETS TO OUR MANY OF THE ISMS
THAT UNDERLIE A LOT OF THAT.
WELFARE STEREOTYPES THAT HAVE
CHARACTERIZED THE NATIONAL
DEBATE OVER THE PROGRAM.
BUT KNOWING WHAT WE NOW NOT
DOING SOMETHING ABOUT IS AND.
AS I SAID BEFORE A FEW TIMES IS
UNACCEPTABLE. AND THAT'S WHY WE
WOULD URGE THE COMMITTEE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO WORK TOGETHER
WITH ADVOCATES.
TO MAKE SURE THAT AFTER THIS
BUDGET PASSES KNOW CHILD IN THE
CAL WORKS PROGRAM LIVES IN VERY
DEEP POVERTY.
THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT WE HAVE RUSHED ALONG THOSE.
HELLO MY NAME IS FOR TELLING
MENDOZA.
AND I LIVE IN THE CITY OF
ANTIOCH.
I'M A SINGLE DIVORCED MOTHER OF
TWO CHILDREN AGES TEN AND TO.
TODAY I AM JOINED WITH OTHER
PARENTS VOICES MEMBERS ACROSS
OUR STATE TO FIGHT BACK DEEP.
GENERATION PROPERTY.
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME AN
OPPORTUNITY ARM.
TO SHARE MY EXPERIENCE GROWING
UP.
AND LIVING IN PROPERTY.
DOING GREAT.
I WAS BORN INTO A FAMILY.
OF GAME ENVIRONMENTS.
AND CRYING.
MY MOTHER'S AND FATHER'S
STRUGGLED WITH THEIR OWN DEMONS.
OF VIOLENCE THINK YOU.
AND CRIME AND ABUSE
AND DEEP PROPERTY.
AS A YOUNG GIRL. I WAS LEFT
BEHIND ALONE. NOT KNOWING IF MY
OLDER BROTHER OR MOTHER. WOULD
RETURN TO GIMME.
WE MOVED OFTEN.
AND BECAUSE OF THE NEIGHBORHOODS
AND THE LIVING SITUATIONS AND
THE CRIME AND VIOLENCE THAT.
WE BROUGHT TO THEM AS WELL.
A.
I DID GO TO SCHOOL.
BUT DIDN'T HAVE THE SUPPORT OF
MY PARENTS.
BEING INVOLVED.
IN MY EDUCATION. I WOULD HIDE
FOOD IN MY CLOSET.
.
BECAUSE I KNEW.
THAT I WOULDN'T GET MEALS.
AND I WANTED TO MAKE SURE WHEN
MY STOMACH WAS HURTING. I WOULD
HAVE SOMETHING TO EAT.
AND I REMEMBER THAT IT WAS.
ABOUT THE KICKS
THAT WEEK WOULD PROVIDE FOR.
I'M.
I WAS THERE.
IN THIS CHILDHOOD.
TRAUMA AND NO ONE'S SEEN ME.
EVEN AS YOUNG AS FIVE OR SIX
YEARS OLD FOR. I WOULD SIT IN
CLASS.
AND I REMEMBER MY.
HUNGER WAS SO PAINFUL. AND I
WOULD ALWAYS HAVE A PAINFUL GROW
IN MY STOMACH.
I COULDN'T WAIT FOR LUNCH.
BECAUSE I KNEW THAT. WAS THE
ONLY GOOD MAIL THAT I WOULD
RECEIVE.
GROWING UP.
ALL I CRAVED THAT WAS TO BE
NORMAL FOR.
INSUFFICIENT WITH OTHER KIDS.
AS A MOTHER OF TWO KIDS.
I TURNED TO CAL OR.
PROGRAM.
I CAO WORKS PROGRAMS GIVES ME.
WHEN I NEEDED HELP I RECEIVED
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED A MONTH.
WE CURRENTLY LIVED WITH MY
MOTHER.
.
BECAUSE HOUSING IN CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY IS A VERY EXPENSIVE FOR.
FOR ONE BEDROOM APARTMENT IT IS.
FIFTEEN HUNDRED.
THE CASH AID I RECEIVED.
WENT TO UTILITIES FOOD AND GAS.
.
THERE IS NO WAY I COULD AFFORD
LIVING ON MY OWN.
IT WAS
CASH GRANT.
WAS.
REYES.
IF THE CASH GRANT WAS RAISED.
WHAT I WOULD DO ON HONESTLY?
IS TO PROVIDE.
MY ELDEST SON.
WHICH SHOES.
HE WOULD GO AROUND.
WHICH SHOES THAT DIDN'T FIT HIM
FOR.
THAT HAD HOLES ON THE BOTTOM.
AND HIS SOCKS WOULD GET WET.
IN THE WINTER.
BOYS GROW.
SO FAST.
ALMOST EVERY MONTH IT SEEMS.
ARUM.
OFTEN.
HE OFTEN GOT TEASED.
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T HAVE YOU KNOW.
THE IN SHOES ARE YOU KNOW PANTS
THAT FIT HIM WELL.
I AM.
IN IT BROUGHT ME BACK TO WHEN I
WAS A KID.
I WAS.
ALWAYS TEASED.
I KNOW THE SHAME OF WEARING
CLOTHES THAT DIDN'T FIT. OF
OTHER KIDS
TEASING ME.
MY SON WAS CITIES TO.
THEIR SELF ESTEEM. YOU HAVE WHEN
YOU.
CAN WALK INTO A STORE.
LIKE WALMART OR TARGET.
TO BUY SHOES ISRAEL.
I AM GRATEFUL.
FOUR THE GOODWILL AND GARAGE
SALES.
IT WAS WHAT I COULD AFFORD.
BUT THE SHAME AND HUMILIATION
THAT YOU FEEL AS A CHILD STAYS
WITH YOU.
I WOULD ALSO BY.
HEALTHIER FOOD.
SEEMS LIKE.
FOOD THAT ISN'T.
SO HEALTHY IS LESS EXPENSIVE.
ARM.
GREAT NOW I SOMETIMES WILL CALL
THE FOOD BANKS SALVATION ARMY.
AND OTHER CHURCHES.
I SHOULDN'T.
SOUND IT SHOULDN'T SOUND LIKE.
LUXURY TO MEET THE BASIC NEEDS
LIKE CLOTHES THAT FIT AND
HEALTHY FOOD.
BUT IF YOU. ARE IN POVERTY.
IT'S LIKE WE DON'T DESERVE IT.
I START.
I STARTED GOING TO CHURCH.
AND FOUND A COMMUNITY.
TO SUPPORT ME AND MY CHILDREN.
I'M PARTICIPATING IN THE COW ORG
WORK GROUP. WHERE I CAN SHARE MY
EXPERIENCE
TO HELP MAKE THE SYSTEM BETTER
FOR OTHER FAMILIES?
I'M BEGINNING TO HEAL FROM MY
PAST.
TRAUMA.
FROM THE MENTAL EMOTIONAL.
AND PHYSICAL ABUSE THAT I HAD
GOT FROM MY EX HUSBAND.
SO THAT. I CAN BE THE BEST
VERSION.
FOR MY CHILDREN.
I'M.
THAT'S WHAT I REALLY WANT.
BUT WE NEED.
WE NEED. THE LEGISLATOR.
AND THE GOVERNOR TO SEE S..
WE WANT.
TO BETTER OUR LIVES.
WE DON'T WANT OUR KIDS TO
EXPERIENCE.
WHAT WE EXPERIENCED?
SO WE ASK THAT YOU START.
BY ENSURING.
NO FAMILIES YOU KNOW CHILDREN IS
LIVING AND DEEP PROPERTY.
THIS IS WHY I WOULD LIKE.
THE LEGISLATOR.
TO INCLUDE FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET.
TO BRING GREAT LEVELS UP TO
MATCH.
THE CURRENT FEDERAL PROPERTY
LINE AND.
TO.
PORT A.
POORER OR IT TIES.
RELIEF TO FAMILIES.
LIVING IN DEEP POVERTY LIVING IN
THE PROPERTY.
IS HORRIBLE AND MAKES IT HARD TO
BATTLE.
CLAIM.
UP THAT LADDER OF SUCCESS.
I DON'T WANT MY CHILDREN OR ANY
CHILDREN. IN CALIFORNIA.
TO CONTINUE LIVING THIS
NIGHTMARE OF T..
PROPERTY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SHELAGH.
AS A.
PARENT MYSELF I THINK INTO.
EVERYONE OPPOSITE WITH KIDS
ONCE.
THE HAVE PARENTS WERE FIGHTING
FOR THEM AND SO ON QUITE
APPRECIATIVE OF YOUR ADVOCACY
HERE TODAY.
I THINK.
AND.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA A.
TIGER WOODS BERMAN FINANCE A
THINK WE WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
YOU'RE IT JENDA PROVIDES COST
ESTIMATE TO PROVIDE HAVE COLA
FOR MAPPING CREASES AND WE WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PRELIMINARY
ESTIMATES FOR HALF YOUR COSTS
TIED WITH THE CNI OF FOUR POINT
FOUR. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN WOULD BE SEVENTY TWO
POINT THREE MILLION.
AND BUDGET YOUR WHICH IS ABOUT
SEVEN POINT THREE MILLION HIGHER
AT THE END WHAT'S INCLUDED IN
THE AGENDA. YOU CAN ROUGHLY
DOUBLE THE HOT FOR AN
APPROXIMATION OF FOR YOUR COSTS.
AND WE'RE ALSO JUST POINT OUT
THAT.
THERE DOES CONTINUE TO BE A
STATUTORY MECHANISM FOR
PROVIDING BECAUSE TO THE EXTENT
THAT ADDITIONAL NINETY ONE
REALIGNMENT REVENUES.
ARE AVAILABLE AFTER PAYING FOR
AND ACHIEVE REPEALS. AND PRIOR
GRANT INCREASES.
THANK YOU.
I INADVERTENTLY LEFT OUT THE
DEPARTMENT IN THIS DISCUSSION
AND WANTED TO SEE IF. HE WANTED
TO ADD SOME TESTING.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ON THE LOOK
ALMOST. LIKE YOU'LL NEVER HEAR
ME ARGUE.
AGAINST AND MORE GENEROUS
ASSISTANCE
PAYMENT SYSTEM ON EVERYTHING
THAT MR MECHANISM MENDOZA.
SPEAKS PUBLIC FOR ITSELF. OWN
THE THE ONLY POINT I THINK I'D
MAKE HOME IN SETTING THE CAL
WORKS PROGRAM IN CONTEXT.
IS THAT IT IS INTENDED TO BE
INTERACTIVE WITH.
A SET OF OTHER BENEFITS IN THE
SYSTEMS POTENTIAL.
SO IT'S INTENDED TO BE
INTERACTIVE WITH.
THE SNAP KILL FRESH PROGRAM THE
THE NUTRITION PROGRAM IT'S
INTENDED TO BE INTERACTIVE WITH
POTENTIAL EARNINGS.
ON CALIFORNIA HOUSING EARNINGS
IN EARNED INCOME DISREGARD SO
THAT THEY THERE'S SORT OF NOT UP
MARGINAL THE THE THE MARGINAL
TAX RATE IN A SENSE ON EARNINGS
IS RELATIVELY LOW. OF THE STATE
AS YOU KNOW BEGAN STATE EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT.
ON TWO YEARS AGO MODIFIED THIS
PAST YEAR. ON THE FEDERAL EITC
IS AS PART OF THAT CONSTRUCT
AND OF COURSE THE. LEGISLATURE
IN THE ADMINISTRATION ARE TWO
YEARS AGO ON APPROVED.
A MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES ON ALL
OF THAT IS INTENDED.
TEND TO SORT OF BE AN
INTERACTIVE PARA.
WE FULLY RECOGNIZE NOT EVERYONE
CAN ACCESS ALL PARTS OF IT.
AND WHO'S SO. THEY THE SPIRIT
OF TRYING TO MAKE SURE CHILDREN
ARE LIVING IN DEEP POVERTY I
THINK THIS IS AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT GOAL.
IF I COULD OFFER ONE SORT OF
ADVICE.
FULL SUPPORT FOR PARK IF I WAS.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHERE TO
PUT THE NEXT POST GOING UP TO
THE FIFTY PERCENT OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL FOR THE GRANTS.
IS ACTUALLY AN ANNUAL COST
SOMEWHERE AROUND SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION.
SO WELL. I WOULD SUGGEST
CONCEIVABLY LOOKING AT.
OFFERING SORT OF SYSTEMS OF RENT
SUBSIDIES.
TIED TO YOU KNOW RENT CONTROLS
AND OTHER THINGS LIKE THAT
BECAUSE MY GREAT FEAR IS. IF AS
WE INCREASE GRANT LEVELS IT'S
JUST COMING OUT THE OTHER ADS
THE RAPACIOUS MOST OF THE
HOUSING MARKET IS LIMITLESS.
AND THAT REALLY IS WHAT HAS
DRIVEN THE CALIFORNIA POVERTY
MEASURE IN THE SUPPLEMENTAL
POVERTY MEASURE SO DANGEROUS.
BOMB.
DOT SAID THAT IS IN THEM.
EFFORT TO REIN ON. ANYTHING YOU
HEARD FROM HIM.
PROPONENTS TODAY IT'S JUST A
QUESTION THAT WE'RE IN AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE WHAT GOES IN
ONE WEEK ALMOST LOOKS GREAT ON
THE OTHER.
THANK YOU.
THANK.
BELIAU DID YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE WE WILL NOW TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE TO.
HELLO UP PARENT VOICES AND OUR
FIFTEEN CHAPTERS ACROSS THE
STATE STAND WITH RICH ALLAH.
IN.
PLEADING.
FOR GRANT INCREASES FOR
FAMILIES.
TO PREVENT.
ANOTHER GENERATION FROM LIVING
IN DEEP POVERTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM
HI SABRINA HAMMER THE CALIFORNIA
ASSET BUILDING COALITION IN
SUPPORT THINK IN Q..
MICHELLE SOBRE MINSKY CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND CALIFORNIA.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL ALIGN OURSELVES WITH
THE COMMENTS PARTICULARLY OF
FRANK MECCA.
THIS WE WE IN THOSE SIXTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
REALLY CAN AFFORD TO PREVENT
CHILDREN FROM LIVING IN DEEP
POVERTY AND GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT THE DEVASTATING COSTS.
BOTH FOR THOSE CHILDREN RIGHT
NOW AND LONG INTO THE FUTURE
IT'S SOMETHING THAT ABSOLUTELY
NEEDS TO BE A PRIORITY.
AND I HOPE.
THE CONTINUE TURN IT UP
EMPHASIZE AND AND WORK TOWARDS
THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KEVIN AS THEIR
COLDEST CALIFORNIA BEFORE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION STRONGEST SUPPORT
THIS.
OPPOSE THOUGH IT SHOULD BE
NOTED.
THAT THE GRANTS TODAY I AT THE
SAME LEVEL.
THAT THEY WERE THE MAXIM GRANT
THAT THEY WERE IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE MAYOR
PRICE WITH A NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT. BUT IT'S VERY DIFFERENT
THAN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
THAT'S THIRTY YEARS.
AND.
THE EVERYTHING HAS STAND STILL
IT'S.
AND ALSO SHOULD BE NOTED.
THAT ONLY FORTY PERCENT OF THE
CASE BOTH GET THE MAXIMUM EIGHT.
SIXTY PERCENT OF THE CASE VOTE.
GET LESS THAN ONE PERSON OF THE
MAXIMUM AIN'T.
SO THE REPRESENTATION THAT SEVEN
FOURTEEN IS WHAT FOLKS GET.
IS MAJORITY OF THE FAMILIES
DON'T EVEN GET THAT.
AND AS TO WHERE THE MONEY IS.
EARTH OF GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSED THAT THE SEVEN POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS AVAILABLE
FOR CAL WORKS.
IN IT DON'T THE WAY THE FIGURE
THAT IS THAT THIS THREE POINT.
SEVEN COMING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THEN THE FEDS
MATCH THAT WOULD THINK MATCHES
THAT BY THREE BILLION. IN THIS
BLUFF WILL BE A POINT FOUR
BILLION CARRY OVER.
AND THE GOVERNOR OF PURCHASES
THE SEVEN POINT FOUR AVAILABLE
IN ONLY FIVE POINT ONE IS BEING
USED FOR CAL WORKS.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT HAPPENED WITH
THE TWO POINT THREE BILLION I
THINK OF BOTH THE STUDENT
COMMISSION OR WHEREVER THEY WANT
TO SENATE.
SHOULD BE INVESTED IN CHILDREN
LATIN WE SHOULD STOP THIS CHILD
THE BILL'S
AND USE THAT MONEY TO STOP CHILD
ABUSE IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
SELENA PRIOR WITH SEIU IN
SUPPORT.
I AM KEVIN NANCE CHO
REPRESENTING THE OUT CALIFORNIA
INTERFAITH COALITION WHICH
INCLUDES THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA.
THE NATIONAL COUNCIL OF JEWISH
WOMEN CALIFORNIA LUTHERAN OFFICE
OF PUBLIC POLICY CALIFORNIA
CHURCH IMPACT OF THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE. AND THE
JEWISH PUBLIC AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
WE SUPPORT THIS REQUEST WE
BELIEVE NO CHILD SHOULD HAVE TO
LIVE IN DEEP POVERTY.
YOU CAN.
CLAIRE LEAPT SCHULTZ
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF JEWISH WOMEN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
TRACY PATTERSON CALIFORNIA FOOD
POLICY ADVOCATES IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT.
SHANTI PRASAD SENIOR POLICY
ADVOCATE AT ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK IN OAKLAND
AND POLICY CO CHAIR OF
CALIFORNIA HUNGER ACTION
COALITION. IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT.
AND JUST A PERSONAL NOTE I WAS
ON A FDC AS A CHILD WHEN IT WAS
CALLED A FDC CAO WORKS NOW.
I CANNOT IMAGINE.
BEING ABLE TO. BE AT THE PLACE
THAT I AM TODAY AT THE AT THE
LEVELS THAT THE GRANTS ARE
TODAY.
THANK YOU
THE GAME.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WERE ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT AS WE HEARD FROM
TESTIMONY YESTERDAY AND THE ASUS
STUDY THAT POVERTY IS THE BROOD
OF SO MANY PROBLEMS AND WE THINK
THIS PROPOSAL WILL. HELP
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THOSE PROBLEMS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CHRISTINA GALLAGHER ON BEHALF OF
THE JEWISH PUBLIC AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE AND THE JEWISH FAMILY
SERVICES OF LOS ANGELES AND
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL THINK.
THANK YOU.
CHRIS RESPONSES POLICY ADVOCATE
RICHARD OF THE CALL THIS REMAIN
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS AYE AND STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THIS PROPOSAL.
ON A HAVE SUPPLIED UNITED WAYS
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
SHANE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FOOD BANKS I'M SO TO SAY THAT WE
KNOW VERY WELL THAT HUNGER IS A
ONLY FROM THERE BECAUSE OF
POVERTY AND IF IF THINGS ARE
VERY POOR SUBSTITUTE FOR THE
CASH CANCER BENEATH ON THE FEET
THANK YOU.
JESSICA BAKLOH WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY WE
WOULD SAY THAT NO CHILD SHOULD
LIVE IN POVERTY.
IF ENDING DEEP POVERTY IS THE
BEST WE CAN DO NOW. WE SHOULD DO
THAT.
OUT WE HAVE A LETTER WE SENT IT
TO YOUR STAFF WITH.
SINOPSE WE NOW HAVE
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY SIGNED ON
UNTIL REVISED THE LETTER AND WE
SEND IT WITH THE NEW LOGO'S.
WE URGE YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
THIS PROPOSAL THING.
SING NO MORE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE TO ME TO BRING IT UP TO
THE DYESS FOR ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS THAT WE MAY HAVE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
I'M I AM A FORMER TEACHER AND. I
GUESS YOU COULD SAY I'M STILL
THE TEACHER OF MY COULDN'T
TEACHER AND.
I TAUGHT IN FONTANA UNIFIED
WHICH IS A VERY LOW INCOME
COMMUNITY AND.
SO TO ADD TO THAT AS TEACHERS
THE BURDEN IS ALSO ON AS TO
TRYING TO GO. TO HELP CHILDREN
WHEN THEY HAVEN'T HAD ANY FOOD.
THEY HAVE TWO MATIC EXPERIENCES
AT HOME AND THEY WERE STILL
EXPECTING THEM TO EXCEL IN THE
TEST IN MY MATH TEST.
AND.
BEING UPSET THAT THEY CAN BRING
YOU KNOW BACK A PEEPER WHEN
LEADING HAVE A PEN AT HOME IN
ORDER TO SIGN THAT.
AUTHORIZATION FOR WHATEVER IT
WAS AND SO I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY.
AS A TEACHER FOR SIXTEEN YEARS
I SAW A LOT OF THOSE KIDS AND.
WANTED TO TAKE EVERYBODY HOME
WHEN THEY'RE YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
WAS IMPOSSIBLE I WOULD HAVE HAD
SIX HUNDRED CHILDREN BY NOW.
AND.
IT'S IT'S DIFFICULT OF.
NOT JUST AS A TEACHER BUT AS A
HUMAN BEING TO SEE KIDS
STRUGGLING AND I CAN RELATE TO
THE STORY ABOUT THE ISSUES WITH
HOLES IN THEM. I WAS NOT BORN
IN.
THE UNITED STATES AND WHEN I
CAME TO THIS COUNTRY A WE WERE
VERY POOR AS WELL AND.
BEING NOT FITTING IN AND.
QUITE FRANKLY TRYING TO HAVE
WITH THE OTHER KIDS HAD WAS
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE AND IT WAS
EMBARRASSING AND SO I APPRECIATE
THAT BUT I'M GLAD THAT YOU'RE
HERE. ADVOCATING FOR THIS
BECAUSE YOU ARE DOING SOMETHING
FOR YOUR CHILDREN AND NOT JUST
YOUR CHILDREN FOR THE SIX
HUNDRED KIDS THAT I WOULD HAVE
HAD. AND THAT THE MANY IN
CALIFORNIA SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE AND I
THINK IT'S TIME. YOU KNOW AND I
KNOW WE SAY IT'S TIME EVERY TIME
BUT IT'S TIME TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE DO KEEP.
.
KIDS IN THE FOREFRONT WE TALK
ABOUT MOVING CALIFORNIA FORWARD
AND HOW KIDS IN THE EDUCATION
SYSTEM IS THE KEY TO SUCCESS BUT
IF WE DON'T HAVE. CHILDREN THAT
HAVE A HOME TO GO TO FOOD TO EAT
THEN YOU KNOW ALL OF OUR TALK IS
JUST TALK.
BECAUSE THE KICKED WE CAN'T MOVE
CALIFORNIA FORWARD IF WE CAN
EDUCATE KIDS WE CAN EDUCATE KIDS
IF THEY HAVEN'T HAD FOOD THEY
DON'T HAVE A PLACE TO LIVE. SO
THANK YOU AGAIN AND I APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS AND I KNOW WE'RE
ALL HERE.
IN FOR THE SAME REASON I'M THE
CHAIR OF HUMAN SERVICES IN THE
STORIES THAT I HEAR.
AND IN MY COMMITTEE AS WELL ARE
ARE QUITE FRANKLY DISTURBING
BECAUSE WE ARE THE SIX LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD AND YET
WE'RE HAVING THESE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT. MOVING CHILDREN OUT OF
POVERTY.
.
IN AND I LOOK THROUGH THE REPORT
AND THIS IS THE ELEVENTH
STRAIGHT YEAR WE HAVE NOT A. WE
WILL HAVE BEEN BELOW THE POVERTY
BUT THE POVERTY LINE WE HAVEN'T.
INCREASED.
THE GROUNDS OF THE I'M FROM LA
COUNTY AND IN LA COUNTY. THE.
.
LIVING THOUGH THE RENTS HAVE
ALMOST.
TRIPLED IN IN THE LAST THIRTY
YEARS.
PROBABLY MORE I'VE JUST IN MY
AREA AND WE CAN'T WE HAVE I KNOW
WE CAN'T KEEP UP.
WITH THE LEVEL OF OF THE
INCREASE IN RENTS BUT IF WE CAN
DO SOMETHING FOR THESE CHILDREN
AND I APPRECIATE THIS SOLUTION
ABOUT.
.
THE THESE HOW SUBSIDIZE HOMES
BUT ABOUT ALSO BRING STIGMA TO
SOME OF THESE FAMILIES THAT YOU
KNOW WHO YOU ARE AS SECTION
EIGHT. ARM CHILD THAT'S ALSO
THOUGHT THAT.
DRAMATIC FOR THE CHILDREN AND
IT'S ALSO EMBARRASSING AND SO I.
WE WANT US TO LOOK AT THIS WITH
THE BEST INTENTIONS OBVIOUSLY
BUT ALSO TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE
CAN PROVIDE THESE WITH THE LAST.
BUT THE LEAST AMOUNT OF OF OF A
STIGMA TO THE FAMILIES. AGAIN I
DO APPRECIATE BOTH THE.
THE COMMENT ABOUT THE US
SUBSIDIZE HOMES BY.
IT'S ALSO PART OF THE TRAUMA
THAT WERE IMPOSING ON SOME OF
THESE KIDS AND FAMILIES AT THAT
NOW NOT ONLY ARE YOU ARE CAL
WORKS AND CAL FRAZIER. FAMILY
BUT YOU'RE ALSO A SECTION EIGHT
FAMILY AND SO WE HAVE TO REALLY
THINK ABOUT HOW WE APPROACH THIS
WITHOUT.
ADDING TO THE BURDEN ONTO THESE
FAMILIES I THINK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATH.
SO.
LET ME START OFF WITH.
CORRECT IN ALL OF YOU WE ARE THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD.
I ACCORDING TO WHAT THE
GOVERNOR SAID.
.
WITH THAT.
QUITE FRANKLY WHEN IT COMES TO
ALL OF THE THE PROPOSAL'S TODAY
MY BELIEF IS THAT WE NEED TO.
LOOK AT WHAT WAS CUT IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE AND GET IT ALL
BACK.
BECAUSE AT THAT PERIOD OF TIME
PRIOR TO THAT WE WEREN'T THE
FIFTH LARGEST WE WERE BELOW THAT
SO I THINK WE NEED TO STEP UP
OUR GAME IS A STATE START TAKING
CARE OF OUR FAMILIES.
WITH THAT SAID.
WE HAVE TAKEN MEASURES THE STATE
INCREASE THE MINIMUM WAGE.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME OF
THAT.
WITH WE WE'VE DONE THESE
MEASURES THAT WOULD THESE THINGS
HAS HAPPENED BUT YET WE STILL
HAVE THESE HUGE GAPS.
SO. WHAT WHAT I'D LIKE TO SEE IS
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE HOW HOW
IS THAT ACTUALLY HELPS?
VERSUS HURT VERSUS SPREAD THAT
POVERTY GAP.
SINCE WE HAVE DONE THAT.
BECAUSE I'D LIKE TO SEE THE
NUMBERS ON THAT.
BECAUSE WE WHEN THAT CAME
THROUGH IT WAS YOU NOW WE RISE
ALL SHIPS AND MY CONCERN WAS
WILL SOME OF THE SHIPS ARE GOING
TO SEEK.
AND A LOT OF THOSE THAT DON'T DO
WELL OUR OUR FAMILIES IN
POVERTY.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO THE JOB AND IF THEY DO GET
THE JOB AND THEY GET CUT OFF THE
BENEFITS THEY FALL DOWN THE
CLASS.
AND EVEN IN A WORSE POSITION.
I KNOW THIS BECAUSE MY FAMILY
HAS BEEN THERE.
AND SO SICK OF OLD CRUSTY FOLKS
CALLING OUR CHILDREN WELFARE
BABIES BECAUSE I HAPPEN TO HAVE
TWO OF THEM AT HOME.
WELL NOW.
I'VE BEEN THROUGH THE STRUGGLE
YES AS YOU KNOW THE THE FINGER
WAS IN THE BACK THANK YOU.
IT.
IT'S A HARD PATH.
.
A HEARING YESTERDAY I THINK SET
A LOT WITH ALL THE ACES SCORES.
ONE OF MY COMMENTS IN THAT
HEARING WAS THAT WE NEED TO LOOK
AT IT IN MIND COURAGE AND WHAT I
WANT TO SEE BACK FOR DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IN THE ALLEY  ON
THIS.
IS A LOT OF OUR CHILDREN A LOT
OF OUR FAMILIES HAVE MULTIPLE
SOCIAL WORKERS THAT TRACK THEM
THROUGH THE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS.
IN DIFFERENT SILOS WE DON'T NEED
FOR TWO THREE AND FOUR.
DIFFERENT SOCIAL WORKERS
TRACKING ONE FAMILY.
COMPLETE WASTE OF FONTS.
WE CAN TAKE THAT WE CAN SPREAD
THAT OUT WE CAN HAVE ONE PERSON.
TRACK THESE FAMILIES IN TRACK
THESE CHILDREN'S THROUGH A
LIFETIME.
IN DECREASE CASELOADS AND MAKE
SURE THAT THESE FAMILIES ARE
GETTING THE ADEQUATE THE HELP
THAT THEY NEED. SO LESS OF THEM
ARE FALLING THROUGH THE CRACKS.
AND I QUITE FRANKLY THINK THAT
WOULD BE A MUCH MUCH BETTER USE.
OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
SAID IN THE COMMITTEE THAT YOU
KNOW I'VE I'VE READ TO CHILDREN
WITH DISABILITIES A I SAY QUITE
A BED.
WE SHOULD AND I YOU PROGRAM MANY
HAVE TWO THREE AND FOUR SOCIAL
WORKERS THAT ARE TRACKING YOUR
CHILD. IT MAKES YOU WONDER WHY.
THEY'RE ALL THERE AYE I KNOW
THEY'RE ALL THERE BECAUSE THEY
CARE ABOUT MY CHILDREN IN THE
CARE OF ALL YOUR CHILDREN HER
GOING THROUGH THESE THINGS.
BUT WE DON'T NEED MULTIPLE ONES
DOING THE SAME THING.
BECAUSE THAT'S SOMEBODY ELSE'S
FAMILY THAT COULD BE GETTING THE
HELP THAT THEY'RE CURRENTLY NOT
GETTING.
YOU COULD BE ONE MORE FAMILY.
GETTING THE SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED MAKING SURE THAT THAT
FAMILY DOESN'T FALL THROUGH THE
CRACKS.
SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT NEEDS
TO BE LIKE THAT BECAUSE WE ARE.
FAR.
FAR OVERLY SIDELOAD.
WITH WHAT'S HAPPENING BETWEEN
THE AGENCIES AND THERE NEEDS TO
BE BETTER COMMUNICATION AND
THESE THINGS NEED TO BE LOOKED
AT SO I. REALLY WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THE NUMBERS BACK
WHEN WE GET BACK IN MAY ON
SOMETHING. THAT WOULD RESEMBLE A
WAY TO CUT THAT BACK ORDER.
FIGURE OUT OF WAY WERE WE SHOULD
REFORM THAT.
SO THAT WITH THESE FAMILIES ARE
GETTING TAKEN CARE OF.
BECAUSE I THINK EIGHT MINUTES
RESOURCE.
AND WE ONLY HAVE A FINITE AMOUNT
EVEN THOUGH WE ARE THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD WE
HAVE A GROWING POPULATION.
IN AND WE HAVE FAMILIES AND
THANK YOU FOR HAVING THE COURAGE
TO TESTIFY TODAY.
IT TAKES A LOT.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND AND
TAKING THE TIME AWAY FROM HER
CHILDREN AND AND. BEING HERE
TODAY.
BUT WE NEED THOSE NUMBERS SO
THOSE OF US UP ON HERE ON THE
DYESS.
CAN ADEQUATELY EVALUATE HOW TO
SPIN THESE DOLLARS.
SO I ENCOURAGE BOTH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND ALEJO.
.
MISTER MEG I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS.
ARMED.
BUT I DO WANT TO SEE THOSE
NUMBERS BECAUSE THAT THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN.
NEEDS TO BE SHOWN US WHILE.
THANK YOU MISTER MATHESON WILL
BE RESPONSIVE TO YOUR REQUEST
I'D LIKE TO GO BACK TO THAT
POINT THAT YOU COMMENTED ON
FIRST.
AND THE POINT THAT MR LIFE WERE
MADE ABOUT THE INCREASE IN THE
MINIMUM WAGE IN THAT.
THE CREATION OF A STATE EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT WHICH WE WERE.
.
SPONSORS HAVE BEEN VERY PLEASED
ABOUT IT THE FEDERAL EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT THEIR GREAT.
HARM.
BUT IF YOU'RE LIVING IN SUCH A
STATE OF DEEP POVERTY.
.
IT'S IT'S HOW DO YOU GET ON TO
THE TRACK.
YOU HAVE TO.
.
YOU KNOW THEIR FAMILIES THAT
COME TO US WITH.
VERY LITTLE EMPLOYMENT HISTORY
AND VERY LITTLE.
EDUCATIONAL HISTORY LANGUAGE.
I'M ISSUES AND THE SORT OF IF
YOU GREW UP IN YOU'VE LIVED A
LIFE IN VERY DEEP POVERTY IN OF
ALL THE STRESS THAT THE TEND
INTO THAT.
GETTING TO THE POINT WHERE WE
CAN WE OFFER SOME GOOD SERVICES.
AND WE ALWAYS WANT TO MAKE THEM
BETTER.
BUT GETTING OUT OF THE CRISIS
OF VERY DEEP POVERTY IS IS OFTEN
A PREREQUISITE TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE.
OF THOSE SERVICES AND THAT IF
YOU GET THE SERVICES YOU CAN GET
THE JOB AND THEN WHAT YOU GET
THE JOB YOU GET THE BENEFIT.
OF A MINIMUM WAGE INCREASE OR
YOU GET THE BENEFIT OF AN EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT. SO WE'VE YOU
FROM THE STANDPOINT OF THE FOLKS
THAT YOU ENTRUSTED TO MOVE
PEOPLE FROM WELFARE TO WORK.
IT'S.
EIGHT YOU ARM IT'S AN IMPEDIMENT
TO THE TO THE GOAL OF MOVING
PEOPLE FROM WELFARE TO WORK IF
WE CAN'T LIFT UP.
AT LEAST THAT THAT THE FLOOR IN
WHICH VERY POOR FAMILIES LIVE SO
THAT THEY'RE NOT EXPERIENCING
SUCH A DEGREE OF TOXIC STRESS.
THAT AS I SAID IN MY TESTIMONY
IF IF TODAY'S GOAL IS WHERE MY
LEVIN TONIGHT BEHIND BEATING MY
KIDS. GETTING TO MY JOB IS IS.
YOU KNOW.
IT'S TOUGH TO TO IT TO MAKE IT A
PRIORITY.
AND FOR CHILDREN WHO GROW UP IN
THOSE ENVIRONMENTS.
THE DAMAGE THAT TALKED THE
TOXIC OF POVERTY DOES TO THEM
PHYSICAL DAMAGE TO THEIR BRAINS
WE KNOW FROM THE RESEARCH. MAKES
IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR THEM
TO. THEIR EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT
IS POOR THEIR EMPLOYMENT.
.
SORT OF OUTCOMES ARE POOR SO WE
WANT.
FAMILIES AND CAL WORKS BE ABLE
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF SOME
REALLY.
POSITIVE THINGS THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS DONE ON TO
HELP LOWER WAGE WORKERS HAVE A
BETTER STANDARD OF LIVING.
BUT WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THE
DEPRIVATION THAT MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR MANY PEOPLE EVEN
GET ON THE FIRST RUNG OF THE
LADDER.
THANK YOU NEXT WILL HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILL.
PLEDGES I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS RIGHT THERE I
THINK THAT WAS THAT WASREALLY
IMPORTANT APART IMPORTANT POINTS
TO GET ACROSS THE COMMITTEE
NUMBER THANK OR WITNESS VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE I THINK WE
ALL WE ALL HAVE OUR GOALS
PARENTS TO MAKE LIFE BETTER. FOR
OUR CHILDREN AND YOUR BEING HERE
TODAY IS.
TESTAMENT I HOPE THAT YOUR AND
SOMEDAY YOUR CHILDREN APPRECIATE
HOW HOW WELL YOU DID HERE AND
HOW BRAVE YOU ARE AND AND THE
STORY YOU TOLD BECAUSE IT
TOUCHED US ALL.
AND.
THE CONCERNS ABOUT.
HOW WE BREAK THE CYCLE HOW WE
GET PEOPLE ON OF THAT FIRST RUNG
OR ONTO THE TRACKS IS IS REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT AND SO?
I THINK YOU HEAR FROM US THAT
WE WANT TO WE WANT TO PUSH
FORWARD AND GET AND GET THIS GET
THIS DONE WE CAN'T WE CAN'T LET
THINGS CONTINUE THE WAY THEY ARE
AND.
I BUT IT.
SEE YOU HAVE YOU TO HAVE A LOT
OF SUPPORT HERE AND I WANT THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE WITH US
TODAY.
I'M GONNA AND WE'RE GONNA
EVENTUALLY HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN
BUT WANT TO SAY THAT IN OUR
ASSEMBLY. BUDGET BLUEPRINT AT
THE START OF THE YEAR WE
RECOMMENDED. A COLA ADJUSTMENT
FOR BOTH SS P. AS WELL AS CAL
WORKS.
I'M AS WAS STATED QUITE
ELOQUENTLY EARLIER IT'S NOT LIKE
MILKS ANY CHEAPER THAN IT WAS
THIRTY YEARS AGO. AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR OUR.
PROGRAMS THAT ARE HELPING OUR
NEEDIEST FAMILIES ARE ALSO
GROWING OVER TIME SOME.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD THIS ITEM
OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE THREE.
I THINK
.
THANK YOU.
AFTER A MILITANT RETURN IT BACK
OVER TO TIM JOHNSON.
SO SPECIFICALLY FOR THE FINGER
ALLOCATION.
WE DID AND MAINTAIN STABILITY
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO THE
ELIGIBILITY ADMINISTRATION
COMPONENT.
OF THE SINGLE I THERE WAS A
YEAR OVER YEAR ALLIED DECLINED
AB THIRTY ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION RELATED TO THE DECLINING
CASELOAD AB MOSTLY EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES IN CHILD CARE. IF YOU
LOOK AT THAT ABSENT ANY POLICY
CHANGES THAT WERE MADE FROM
YEARS OF THE FIFTY FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION. ADD DOLLAR DECLINE
WE HAVE BEEN AT THE BUDGET ACTS
ARE ACTUALLY QUITE A START
LOOKING AT THE SINGLE ALLOCATION
METHODOLOGY AND WE HAVE BEEN IN
CONVERSATION A STICKLER
CONVERSATIONS RELATED TO THAT
WILL CONTINUE THAT WORK. AND WE
ARE DOING THAT IN THAT MULTI
PHASE EFFORT SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE ELIGIBILITY ADMINISTRATION
COMPONENT FIRST.
I'M WERE RIGHT IN THE MIDST OF.
WORKING ON ANALYZING SOME DATA
THAT WE WORKED ON IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH OUR COUNTIES. AND TO LOOK
AT ELIGIBILITY ACTIVELY IN WORK
PROCESSES BY AND THE VARIOUS
PROCESSES APPLICATIONS AN
ONGOING CASE WORK THAT THEY HAVE
TO DO SO. AND THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE HOPE TO BRING BACK IN
TERMS OF SOME AND METHODOLOGY
ADJUSTMENTS FOR THE ELIGIBILITY
COMPONENT OUT IN MAY. I'M AND
THEN WE WILL RIGHT THERE FOLLOW
LOOK AT EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
COMPONENTS IN THE OTHER
COMPONENTS WITH A SINGLE
ALLOCATION TO SEE WHAT
ADDITIONAL.
AT AT METHODOLOGY ADJUSTMENTS
WE CAN MAKE I'M WILL BE ENGAGING
IN ADDITIONAL STAKEHOLDER
CONVERSATION ALONG THE WAY AS
THIS EVOLVES AB BUT OUR FIRST
STEP WAS REALLY LOOKING AT THE
STATE ADMINISTRATION DATA AS
WELL AS THE COUNTY DATA THAT'S
BEEN PROVIDED.
GIVE MATH WE ARE PREGNANT.
THANK YOU FRANK MAC AGAIN WITH
THE WTA AND.
WERE ASKING THE ADMINISTRATION
IN THE LEGISLATURE. TO RESTORE
ABOUT FIFTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
OF FUNDING THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE SINGLE ALLOCATION
FUNDING THAT THE COUNTIES
RECEIVE LAST YEAR AND WHAT THEY
WOULD GET NEXT YEAR BASED ON THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THE SINGLE
ALLOCATION IS THAT IT'S THE
FUNDING THE COUNTIES RECEIVE.
TO MAKE PEOPLE ELIGIBLE
DISTRIBUTE ASSISTANCE DO
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES AND CAL
WORKS CHILD CARE.
IF YOU RECALL GOING BACK TO LAST
YEAR'S ME REVISION ON LAST
YEAR'S MAY REVISION AND FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR. WOULD HAVE CUT
COUNTIES ABOUT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS YEAR OVER YEAR.
ON TOP OF A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS THE YEAR BEFORE
AND ESSENTIALLY WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IS BECAUSE OF THE
ECONOMIC EXPANSION. WITH A RAPID
DECLINING CASELOAD AND WE HAVE A
CASE LOAD DRIVEN FORMULA.
IT'S HYPERSENSITIVE ARM TO
SWINGS IN THE ECONOMY SORROW
DURING THE RECESSION CASELOAD
SKYROCKETED AND YOU BUDGETED A
LOT OF MONEY FOR. A FOR SERVICES
MORE THAN WE COULD SPENT
AND SO WHAT WE DIDN'T SPEND.
WE WOULD WE GAVE BACK.
BECAUSE SIMPLY.
IAN OF BARACK GIANT
BUREAUCRACIES THAT RUN THESE.
HUGE PROGRAMS WERE NOT THAT
NIMBLE ARM AND THEN WE'VE HAD A
RAPID ECONOMIC EXPANSION WHICH
HAS CAUSED A SIGNIFICANT
CASELOAD DECLINE AND WE SEE THE
SHIFT ON THE OTHER END THE
PENDULUM SWING FROM THE OTHER
WAY.
.
AND LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDED A HUNDRED AND THREE
MILLION OR SO OF THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION.
IN THE MAY REVISION AND ASK THE
STATE TO WORK WITH THE COUNTIES
ON A NEW BUDGETING METHODOLOGY.
WERE WERE HAVING REALLY
EXCELLENT CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
SS INDIO HAPPEN REALLY
APPRECIATE.
ARM THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AS AS MS JOHNSON POINTED OUT THE
BUDGET THAT WAS PROPOSED IN
JANUARY DOES REDUCE.
THE EMPLOYMENT SERVICES PORTION
OF
THE SINGLE ALLOCATION BASED ON A
A CASELOAD REDUCTION.
.
IT'S IT'S OUR GOAL IN OUR
REQUEST THAT WE JUST HOLD
FUNDING FLAT UNTIL THE NEW
METHODOLOGY CAN BE PUT IN PLACE.
THAT THE CUT ON THE TABLE AND
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET IN
ADDITION TO THE CAUGHT LAST YEAR
ON TOP OF THE CUT THE YEAR
BEFORE. HAS PUT OUR OPERATIONS
IN THE PLACE WHERE WE'RE MAKING
DANGEROUS AN UNHELPFUL CUTS TO
THE PROGRAM. WERE REDUCING THE
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE FOR CUTTING BACK ON
ELIGIBILITY STAFF IT'S TAKING
LONGER FOR PEOPLE.
TO GET ON THE PROGRAM.
AND.
WHILE THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR PREPARING FOR THE RAINY
DAY.
WE'RE PUTTING MONEY AWAY BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT NEXT RECESSION IS
COMING.
YET THAT THE WELFARE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS COMPLETELY
UNPREPARED FOR THAT MOMENT
BECAUSE WE'VE WE'VE NOT CREATED
THAT QUESTION.
ARM AND WHEN THAT NEXT RECESSION
COMES THE RECESSION THE GOVERNOR
TALKS ABOUT EVERY JANUARY IN ITS
PRESENTATION AND WE WILL NOT BE
PREPARED.
BECAUSE WE WILL HAVE TAKEN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BELOW THE MINIMUM
LEVEL. ON THAT'S NECESSARY THESE
ARE THIS IS YOU KNOW AN ARGUMENT
THAT WE MADE LAST YEAR THERE WAS
A LOT OF SUPPORT FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION IS BANNED.
ARMED SUPPORTIVE OF A OF THE
NOTION OF COMING UP WITH A
BETTER WAY TO BUDGET SO WE DON'T
HAVE THESE BIG PENDULUM SWINGS.
FOR ASKING TODAY IS LET'S NOT
MAKE IT WORSE
UNTIL WE COME UP WITH THAT NEW
METHODOLOGY WE HOPE TO COME UP
WITH SOMETHING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATIONAND AND AND THAT
DEVELOPMENT OF THE MAY REVISION.
ARM BUT SORT OF BOTTOM LINE WE
REALLY URGE TO SORT OF HOLD THE
LINE KEEP FUNDING FLAT UNTIL WE
CAN PUT A BETTER METHODOLOGY IN
PLACE OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WE WILL HAVE SALINAS.
.
THEN IT.
I'D LOST IT RIGHT. FOR ME TO
PRIOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SELENA
PRIOR AND I AM GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS ADVOCATE FOR SEIU.
SEIU REPRESENTS THOUSANDS OF
ELIGIBILITY AND EMPLOYMENT
SERVICE WORKERS ACROSS THE
COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES DEPARTMENT
STATEWIDE.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR HAVING.
ME HERE TO SHARE THE PERSPECTIVE
FROM THE WORKFORCE THAT IS
DEDICATED TO HELPING CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES WHO TURNED TO US IN
THEIR TIME OF NEED AND CRISIS.
WHILE HEADLINES MAY TELL YOU
THAT ECONOMIC RECOVERY CAME TO
CALIFORNIA A FEW YEARS AGO. AND
THE STATE ECONOMY IS DOING WELL
I CAN TELL YOU WHAT OUR MEMBERS
SEE EVERYDAY.
AND IT'S A VERY DIFFERENT STORY
FOR SO MANY FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED FIFTY
FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
CUT WILL HURT FAMILIES AND TAKE
AWAY ESSENTIAL RESOURCES NEEDED
TO ADDRESS BARRIERS AND HELP
FAMILIES REACH SELF SUFFICIENCY.
LAST YEAR IT WAS AGREED THAT WE
WOULD SIT DOWN WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO DEVELOP A FUNDING
METHODOLOGY THAT MORE
APPROPRIATELY REFLECTED THE
NEEDS AND REALITY OF THE COW
WORKS PROGRAM.
WE WERE SHOCKED TO SEE ANOTHER
CUT AND THE GOVERNOR'S TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET
PROPOSAL.
LET'S BE CLEAR
THE FAMILIES WHO TURN A COW
WORKS PROGRAM NEED HELP.
THEY HAVE REACHED ROCK BOTTOM
AND THEY COME INTO COUNTY
OFFICES SEEKING ASSISTANCE.
JUST TO COVER BASIC NECESSITIES
TO CARE FOR THEIR FAMILIES.
IF YOU REMEMBER ONE POINT TODAY
PLEASE HEAR THIS.
CASELOADS DO NOT EQUAL WORKFLOW.
CASELOAD THE NUMBER OF CASES
DOES NOT PAIN INACTION AN
ACCURATE PICTURE OF THE AMOUNT
OF WORK IT TAKES TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF EACH FAMILY.
EACH CASE REPRESENTS A UNIQUE
FAMILY WITH UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES
THE UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
MUST BE ADDRESSED IS CALLED
WORKLOAD. EACH CASE IS INTENSE
AS FAMILY OF ARE DEALING WITH
DIFFICULT SITUATIONS AND MANY
BARRIERS THIS IS WHY THE CURRENT
DECADES OLD METHODOLOGY IS
FLAWED.
WHEN IT COMES TO REMOVING
BARRIERS THERE IS NO ONE SIZE
FITS ALL MODEL.
THE MORE TIME WORKERS BEEN WITH
INDIVIDUALS THE MORE LIKELY THEY
ARE ABLE TO REMOVE BARRIERS SUCH
AS LACK OF HOUSING.
CHILD CARE TRANSPORTATION
EDUCATION.
HEALTHCARE NEEDS AN OVERALL
EMPLOYMENT PREPARATION.
AND ALSO TO TO SO THAT THEY CAN
HELP THEM MEET THEIR.
SELF SUFFICIENCY.
CUTS MEAN REDUCTION OF STAFF AND
EVEN LAYOFFS THE END RESULT IS A
SEVERE UNDER STAFFING IN LAS OF
SERVICES AND BENEFITS WHEN THEY
ARE NEEDED MOST.
SOME FAMILIES WILL FALL THROUGH
THE CRACK
THE CRACKS AND THE RESULT IS
COMPLETE DEVASTATION.
CALIFORNIA WILL NEVER BE ABLE TO
FULLY ERADICATE POVERTY WITHOUT
ADEQUATELY RESOURCING SOCIAL
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS THAT ARE
MEANT TO CATCH FAMILIES WHEN
THEY FALL.
WE MUST SUPPORT CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES ON AND THE CHILDREN AND
THEIR PARENTS NOW OR WE WILL NO
DOUBT PAY FOR IT LATER AND AT A
GREATER COST WHEN CHILDREN TODAY
BECOME ADULTS OF TOMORROW WHO
ARE STILL IN POVERTY. TODAY I'M
ASKING YOU TO REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO CUT CAO
WHAT SINGLE APPLICATION BY FIFTY
FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
AND ALSO TO HONOR THE AGREEMENT
MAY LAST YEAR BY ALLOWING
STAKEHOLDERS THE TIME TO DEVELOP
AN ACCURATE BUDGETING
METHODOLOGY BEFORE REDUCING
SINGLE APPLICATION THINKING.
NEXT THE PERMANENT FINANCE ILIO.
A.
TURN FINANCE TERRORISM THINK WE
WOULD JUST NOTE IN THE CONTEXT
THIS CONVERSATION.
FIFTY FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR DECREASE IS.
CAN BE THOUGHT OF AS A PLACE
HOLDER IN THIS INSTANCE WITH
REGARD TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET WE ARE WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH OUR PARTNERS AT
DSS CODA IN THE COUNTIES TO.
RIGHT SIZE A SINGLE ALLOCATION
AND DEVELOP SOME NEW METHODOLOGY
SURROUNDING ELIGIBILITY
COMPONENT ESPECIALLY IN THE NEAR
TERM. AND WE FULLY INTEND TO
PROPOSE SENATE MAYOR VISION.
THANK YOU SIR.
MU TAZ ALMOST LET ANALYST'S
OFFICE. ACCUSE ME.
TACKLE SOME OF THE EARLIER
COMMENTS WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
SINGLE ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY IS
IN THIS PERIOD OF TRANSITION.
AND I DO THAT WILL BE WORKING
BOTH THE ADMINISTRATION AND YOUR
STAFF COME MAY TO EVALUATE THE
UPDATED METHODOLOGY AND PROVIDE
OUR PERSPECTIVE ON THAT.
THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE THREE AT
THIS TIME.
WELL MISTER CHAIR MY CAROL WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. AND WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
REQUEST FOR INCREASED FUNDING
FOR THE SINGLE ALLOCATION. ON IN
ADDITION TO THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE RAISED BY A CI YOU BY THE
WELFARE DIRECTORS. I WOULD NOTE
THAT THIS IS THE FIRST FUNDING
SOURCE THAT PROVIDES THE
SERVICES THAT OUR FAMILIES
DEPEND ON TO REALLY GET THROUGH
THE WELFARE TO WORK PROGRAM MAKE
SURE. THAT THEY HAVE
TRANSPORTATION AND THEY HAVE
BOOKS FOR SCHOOL AND BE ABLE TO
DO THOUGH AND OTHER THINGS THEY
NEED TO BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE THEIR
MEET THE WORK REQUIREMENTS. COME
WE'RE GLAD TO HEAR FROM FINANCE
THAT THEY'RE GONNA BE COMING OUT
WITH HOPEFULLY PROPOSAL MAY
REVISE THAT WILL RIGHT SIZE THIS
IS THEY SAY AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING THAT HOPEFULLY WILL BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT IT IT MAY IN
MAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
KELLY BEAM ON BEHALF OF SAN
MATEO COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF CWD
IS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU JOHN A SITTING ON
BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
OF RESTORING THE COWARDS THING
LOCATION FUNDING THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MARTHA GROW
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF.
AND SEE DEPUTIES PROPOSAL
RESTORING OPTED FOR MILLION IF
YOU NOTICE ON YOUR AGENDA.
ON PAGE NINETEEN SHOWS THE
NUMBER OF CALYX HOMELESS
FAMILIES.
AND IT'S A FLUCTUATION OF RENT
INCREASES AND AS YOU SEE THE
COWARDS GRANTS ARE FOLLOWING
VERY SHORT. FAMILIES COULD FALL
INTO HOMELESSNESS IF WE DON'T
HAVE THE APPROPRIATE RESOURCES
TO PROVIDE IMMEDIATE.
WITH IMMEDIATE SUPPORT TO
PREVENT THEM FROM. LOSING THEIR
APARTMENT ARE LOSING THEIR
HOUSING SO WE URGENTLY NEED THE
SUPPORT NEEDED TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES OF THESE FAMILIES ARE
GOING THROUGH SO MANY
FLUCTUATIONS AND CHANGES.
THANK YOU.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE ALSO WANT
TO SUPPORT THE CW DE A PROPOSAL
AND I ALSO WANT TO CONCUR WITH
THE COMMENTS MADE BY MISS PRIOR
THANK YOU.
JUSTIN GARRETT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL TO RESTORE THE PROPOSED
CUT TO THE SCENE ALLOCATION I'M
WE ALSO APPRECIATE. THE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS RELATED TO
REVISING THE METHODOLOGY
ENSURING ALIGNMENT BETWEEN
COUNTY COSTS IN STATE FUNDING
FOR THIS PROGRAM. I'M WE THINK
IT'S PRUDENT TO KEEP FUNDING
STABLE TO ENSURE THAT THERE ARE
NOT FOR THEIR SERVICE AND
STAFFING REDUCTIONS ON TO
ENSURE.
COUNTIES ADEQUATELY PREPARED FOR
THE NEXT RECESSION AND TO ALLOW
MORE TIME FOR THESE ONGOING
METHODOLOGY DISCUSSIONS THANK
YOU.
SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN CHRISTOFFEL GOKU
WITH THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES. FOR ALL OF THE
REASON%
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN DISCUSSED
FOR ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
RESTORATION PROPOSED.
THANK YOU SIR.
KELLY BUCKS HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS THE VENTURA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
COLUSA COUNTY AND SUPPORT.
OF THOSE SINGLE ALLOCATION OF
RESTORATION AND LOOK FORWARD I'M
TO HEARING THE PROGRESS ON THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT OCCUR BETWEEN
NOW AND MAY THINK.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE RESTORATION.
THE GAME.
ANDERSON CATHARINE CESSATION OF
BANKS IN SUPPORT OF THE
RESTORATION WE DON'T WANNA BE
PICKING UP THE SLACK THE SIMILES
ARE FORCED TO SERVICES THINK.
THANK YOU SIR.
SEE NO MORE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS FOR
ANY.
COMMENTS THAT WE MAY HAVE.
SEEING NONE.
MAYBE IT'S FAIR IT SEEMED LIKE
THE DEPARTMENT WAS SAYING. THAT
THE PROPOSED SINGLE ALLOCATION
REDUCTION WILL BE RESTORED AS
PART OF THE MAY REVISION.
I JUST ASK THAT FINANCE DSS.
BE ENGAGED PER THE AGREEMENT WE
HAD AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
THREE OPEN AND BOND ISSUE FOR
.
IF HE'S GOOD
NNOVA. ARE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOU MISTER WHAT
OF.
THE NEXT ITEM IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL FOR. A
HOME VISITING A DEMONSTRATION AS
PART OF CAL WORKS PROGRAM ON I'M
GONNA ASK OF MS JOHNSON JUSTICE
WITH. HIGHLIGHTED.
CAN JOHNSON APARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES SO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET DOES INCLUDE AT TWENTY
SIX POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE AT EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET BUT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
EIGHT POINT FIVE MILLION OVER
THE NEXT THREE YEARS. FOR HOME
VISITING INITIATIVE IN THE CAL
WORKS PROGRAM.
WHILE THE CAO WORKS PROGRAM.
REQUIRES PARTICIPATION
PERMITTIVITY IS THERE ARE
PARENTS WITH CHILDREN UNDER THE
AGE OF TWO THAT ARE EXEMPT FROM
THOSE REQUIREMENTS TO WORK AND.
I WOULD REALLY WANT TO WORK TO
ENGAGE THOSE FAMILIES ARE IN A
DIFFERENT WAY THAN WE DO UNTIL
THEY. ARE AT NO LONGER EXEMPTED
FROM THAT REQUIREMENTS SO. I'M
THIS PROPOSAL IS LOOKING AT THAT
POPULATION AS WELL AS A CHILD
ONLY CASELOAD TO SEE WHAT WE CAN
REALLY DO TO REMOVE BARRIERS TO
WORK AND PROVIDE SOME SUPPORTS
IN TERMS OF PARENTING. FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT AND SO ON.
WE ARE.
LOOKING AT AYE LEVERAGING
EXISTING HOME VISITING EFFORTS
ACROSS THE STATE SO WE DO SEE
THIS AS A PARTNERSHIP WITH THOSE
HOME VISITING ORGANIZATIONS AND
ARE COUNTIES AND. I'M OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S A AT A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF EVIDENCE AROUND THE EFFICACY
OF HOME VISITING I'M AS IT'S.
CURRENTLY IN PLACE WITH A LOT
OF EFFORTS HAPPENING WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH IN THEM ETERNAL INFINITE
EARLY CHILDHOOD HOME VISITING
PROGRAMS SO FORTH. AND REALLY
WHAT WE WANT TO EVALUATE IN THE
THREE YEARS OF THIS I'M
INITIATIVE IS TO TO DETERMINE
IF.
ENGAGING THESE FAMILIES WITH
HOME VISITING MAKES A DIFFERENCE
UP ESSENTIALLY THEIR READINESS
TO ENGAGE IN THE FULL ARRAY OF
THE SERVICES UNDER CAL WORKS
PROGRAM.
AND THAT'S AND THAT'S WHAT WE
LOOKING AT IN TERMS OF THE BR
EVALUATION.
WE ARE HOPING THAT WE WOULD ON
AVERAGE SERVE SOMEWHERE AROUND
SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED FAMILIES AB
PER MONTH.
IN TERMS OF THE POPULATION WERE
TARGETING IN OUR EFFORT WHICH
AGAIN IS YOUNG PARENTS UNDER THE
AGE OF TWENTY FIVE FIRST TIME
PARENTS ARE PREGNANT.
WE THERE'S ABOUT THIRTY
THOUSAND FAMILIES ALONE WITHIN
THE COWARDS CLEVELAND ELIGIBLE
SO AGAIN WE WE KNOW THE
INVESTMENTS AND HOME VISITING
THAT ARE.
OCCURRING TODAY I DON'T QUITE
MEET THE NEED WITHIN THIS
PROPOSAL WE REALLY HOPING TO
ENGAGE.
AT LEAST AT SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED
FAMILIES A MONTH AND IT'S
VOLUNTARY FOR BOTH THE OUR
FAMILY AS WELL AS OPTIONAL FOR
THE COUNTIES TO OPT IN IN TERMS
OF THE PROPOSAL SO HAPPY AND
ANSWER A QUESTION.
ABOUT IT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WANNA FIRST THOUGHT
START BY THINKING THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR INCLUDING. A
HOME VISITING PROPOSAL.
AND RESPECTFULLY URGE THE
ADOPTION OF GOVERNOR BROWN'S
PROPOSED CAL WORKS HOME VISITING
INITIATIVE AND UND. AN
ADDITIONAL FIFTY MILLION ANNUAL
INVESTMENT IN THE PROGRAM IN
ORDER TO ENHANCE AND EXPAND
VOLUNTARY EVIDENCE BASED HOME
VISITING FOR CAL WORKS FAMILIES.
THE COW WORKS HOME VISITING
INITIATIVE WILL STRENGTHEN THE
YOUNGEST CALIFORNIANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
WHILE ALSO ENHANCING THE IMPACTS
OF CAL WORKS
ALTHOUGH UNMET BASIC NEEDS
ADVERSE EXPERIENCES AND
CIRCUMSTANCES OF ECONOMIC
HARDSHIP. CAN UNDERMINE THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
FAMILIES.
VOLUNTARY EVIDENCE BASED HOME
VISITING PROGRAMS HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THAT THEY IMPROVE
OUTCOMES FOR BOTH PARENTS AND
CHILDREN IN STE COUNTLESS WAYS.
THESE PROGRAMS CAN GENERATE
PUBLIC SAVINGS BY INCREASING
HEALTHY BIRTHS.
BOOSTING POSITIVE PARENTING
PRACTICES REDUCING CHILD
MALTREATMENT INCREASING FAMILY
SELF SUFFICIENCY IN THE FORMS OF
ADULT EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT.
CAREER TRAINING AND EMPLOYMENT.
THE COW WORKS HOME VISITING
INITIATIVE AS PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. WOULD ALLOW
COUNTY HUMAN SERVICE AGENCIES TO
PARTNER WITH OTHER PUBLIC
AGENCIES AND COMPUTER COMMUNITY
PROVIDERS. TO OFFER EVIDENCE
BASED HOME VISITING PROGRAMS ON
A VOLUNTARY BASIS TO FIRST TIME
PARENTS UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY
FIVE PARTICIPATING AND CAL
WORKS.
WHO ARE PREGNANT OR PARENTING A
CHILD UNDER TWO YEARS OF AGE?
I URGE SUPPORT FOR THIS PROPOSAL
AND ADDITIONALLY URGE ADOPTING
THE FOLLOWING ITEMS.
TO EXPAND AND ENHANCE THE CAL
WORKS HOME VISITING INITIATIVE.
ALLOCATE AN ADDITIONAL FIFTY
MILLION TO EXTEND AND ENHANCE
THE REACH OF THE SERVICES TO CAL
WORKS FAMILIES BEYOND FIRST TIME
PARENTS. UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY
FIVE.
TO PROVIDE ONE TIME ALLOWANCES
OF FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
PARTICIPATING FAMILY IN THE FORM
OF A NEW PARENT SUPPORT. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ASSISTING FAMILIES
WITH ONE TIME NEEDS SUCH AS
CRIBS. CAR SEATS CHILD PROOFING
SUPPLIES FOR THE HOME AT TETRA.
TO ENSURE THAT HOME VISITORS ARE
WELL CHINA AND IN THE PRINCIPLES
OF STRENGTH BASED PRACTICES
CULTURAL COMPETENCIES AND
SUPPORTING FAMILIES TO NAVIGATE
THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM AND
UTILIZE THE ARRAY OF SERVICES.
AND SUPPORTS AVAILABLE TO THEM.
TO BUILD AN ADEQUATE START UP
TIME.
AND COST ALLOWANCES FOR COUNTIES
IN ORDER TO THE ORDER TO
MAXIMIZE THE SUCCESSES OF THIS
INITIATIVE. AND TO MAKE THIS
PROGRAM A PERMANENT FEATURE OF
THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM. AND ALLOW
FOR OPEN IN CONTINUOUS
ENROLLMENT OF ELIGIBLE
INTERESTED FAMILIES.
VOLUNTARY EVIDENCE BASED HOME
VISITING PROGRAMS ARE ONE OF THE
BEST INVESTMENTS CALIFORNIA CAN
MAKE.
TO ENSURE CHILDREN IN FAMILIES
LIVING IN POVERTY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCEED.
CALIFORNIA CAN AND SHOULD JOIN
THE THIRTY OTHER STATES THAT ARE
ALREADY INVESTING GENERAL FUNDS
AND OR FEDERAL TEN OF DOLLARS IN
A VOLUNTARY EVIDENCE BASED HOME
VISITING PROGRAMS TO THROW
STRENGTHEN AND SUPPORT CHILDREN
FAMILIES.
WITH ME TO.
I IN SUPPORT TODAY OF A MORE
ENHANCED AN EXPANSIVE HOME
VISITING INITIATIVE ARE FAR OFF
ON NEON AND ANGELA BROKE
THROUGH.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MN.
ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS OF THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THE NEWS
FAMILY PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM ITS
SUPPORT AT EVIDENCE BASED HOME
VISITING THAT HELPS BREAK THE
CYCLE OF POVERTY.
BECAUSE OF NF P. AND HOME
VISITING MY DAUGHTER AND I ARE
THRIVING TODAY AND I AM A PROUD
CULTURE COLLEGE GRADUATE.
MY NAME IS FOR IDEA AND I AM A
GRADUATE OF THE NURSE FAMILY
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM DELIVERED BY
SOLANO COUNTIES KNOWS FAMILY
PARTNERSHIP IN FAIRFIELD
CALIFORNIA.
I AM THE PROUD MOTHER OF MY
DAUGHTER WHO IS NOW SIX YEARS
OLD.
AS A CLIENT I RECEIVE REGULAR
VISITS ABOUT EVERY OTHER WEEK
FROM MY NFP NERDS HOME VISITOR
RHONDA STARTING WHEN I WAS JUST
FOUR MONTHS PREGNANT.
WHEN I WAS TWENTY SIX YEARS OLD
LIVING IN FAIRFIELD I FOUND OUT
I WAS PREGNANT WITH MY DYING
DAY.
FROM THE BEGINNING I WAS TOLD
THAT I HAD A HIGH RISK PREGNANCY
AND I FOUND MYSELF IN THE
HOSPITAL AT SIXTEEN WEEKS
PREGNANT AND THEN AGAIN AT
TWENTY WEEKS.
I HAD NUMEROUS HOSPITAL VISITS
INTO EMISSIONS DURING MY
PREGNANCY.
I WAS A FIRST TIME MOM AND TO
HAVE SUCH A DRAMATIC HIGHWAYS
PREGNANCY WAS STRESSFUL.
I HEARD ABOUT THE NFP PROGRAM
DURING ONE OF MY HOSPITAL STAYS.
A SOCIAL WORKER ASKED ME IF I
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN SOLANO
COUNTY IS THERE'S FAMILY
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM. WHEN
THERE'S WILL COME TO MY HOME ON
A REGULAR BASIS DAME PREGNANCY
AND THROUGH MY CHILD SECOND
BIRTHDAY.
I MUST SAY THAT I WAS REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT HAVING HOME
VISITING NURSE WHO WOULD MEET
WITH ME AT MY HOME INSTEAD OF ME
BEING IN THE HOSPITAL.
MY FIRST THOUGHTS
WHERE THAT THIS NURSE WAS GOING
TO BE CHECKING ON ME MY VITALS
IN THE BABY. HOWEVER I WAS
SHOCKED THAT HE WAS SO MUCH
MORE.
MINERS RUN THAT PROVIDED ME WITH
ONE ON ONE PAINTING CLASSES AND
IS A POP A SOLID SUPPORT SYSTEM.
BONTA CONNECTED ME WITH
RESOURCES ABOUT MY PREGNANCY
CHILDBIRTH BREAST FEEDING CHILD
DEVELOPMENT PARENTING AND GOAL
SETTING.
SOON AFTER DOING THAT PROGRAM MY
NFP NURSE RHONDA IDENTIFY MY
MOVES AT RISK FOR DEPRESSION
WHICH WAS TRIGGERED BY MY
PREGNANCY.
I WAS REFERRED TO COUNSELING
WITH ROBIN A HOME VISITING
SOCIAL WORKER. BETWEEN MY ENOUGH
* AND SOCIAL WORKER THEY
SHAPE THE TRAJECTORY OF MY LIFE.
ON OCTOBER SIXTY THOUSAND ELEVEN
MY LIFE CHANGED.
MY BABY GIRL WAS BORN AT THIRTY
FIVE WEEKS
SHE WAS LETHARGIC AND HAD A
FEVER AND SPENT TIME IN THE
NEONATAL INTENSIVE CARE UNIT.
MY GOD AND I HAD OUR OWN
PERSONAL NURSE WHO CAREFULLY
WATCH MAYBE HE'S DEVELOPMENT AND
MOTOR SKILLS.
NASH RHONDA HELP ME FIND
RESOURCES TO KEEP MY DAUGHTER
HEALTHY.
NOW MY BABY IS SIX YEARS OLD AND
THRIVING PHYSICALLY EMOTIONALLY
AND SOCIALLY.
THE REQUESTED MY PREGNANCY AND
DELIVERY. MY PARTY BECAME MY
BABY'S HEALTH.
SEMI MY NEXT STEPS AS AN ADULT
AND SINGLE MOTHER WHERE LIMIT
SAID. PART SUING A HIGHER
EDUCATION HAS ALWAYS BEEN
IMPORTANT TO ME BUT WHEN I FOUND
OUT I WAS PREGNANT ADDED ENOUGH
COLLEGE WAS SOMETHING I COULD
DO.
LIKELY I HAD NASH RHONDA IN
SOCIAL WORKER ROBIN TO TEND TO
FOR ENCOURAGEMENT. BOTH OF THEM
ENCOURAGED ME TO PURSUE MY
EDUCATION. ON MY OWN I LIVE
NEVER THOUGHT BEING A SINGLE MOM
AND OBTAINING A DEGREE WOULD BE
POSSIBLE BUT THE TWO OF THEM
MADE IT REALISTIC FOR ME EVEN
WHEN I THOUGHT IT WAS OUT OF
REACH.
THEY BOTH MADE ME FEEL LIKE I
COULD DO IT IT WAS A VERY
EMPOWERING. THEY'RE ABLE TO SHOW
ME THAT YOU CAN SET GOALS
ACHIEVE THEM AND MAKE THEM WORK.
HAVING MY OWN PERSONAL HOME
VISITING TEAM WAS VERY INSPIRING
SPENDING TIME WITH THEM MADE ME
REALIZE THAT ONE AWAY WITH MONTH
INMY COMMUNITY JUST LIKE MYSELF
IN GIVE BACK TO THEM.
I'VE ALWAYS WANTED TO FIND
MEANING IN EVERYTHING THAT I DO.
MY SOCIAL WORKER ROBIN DISCUSSED
A PROGRAM CALLED BLACK INFANT
HEALTH BE AYE AGE
WHICH AIMS TO IMPROVE BIRTH
OUTCOMES AMONG AFRICAN AMERICAN
MOTHERS AND BABIES.
I CREATED A GOAL TO WORK FOR BE
AYE EIGHT.
NOT ONLY DID I GRADUATE FROM NFP
WHEN MY DAUGHTER WAS TWO YEARS
OLD BUT ALSO FROM COLLEGE.
OBTAINING A BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN
SOCIOLOGY IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN WITH A FOUR POINT OH
GPA.
IF YOU WOULD HAVE NEVER TOLD ME
AT THIRTY FOUR YEARS OLD I WOULD
BE A SINGLE MOM. WORKING FULL
TIME WITH A DEGREE IN PURSUING
ANOTHER DECREE A NOT BELIEVE YOU
HOWEVER HERE I AM IN FRONT OF
YOU TODAY ENCOMPASSING ALL THOSE
THINGS.
NINE A FULL TIME FAMILY HEALTH
ADVOCATE FOR THE BLACK INFANT
HEALTH PROGRAM.
I FEEL LIKE THIS POSITION IS
DEATHLY GIVING BACK WHAT WAS
GIVEN TO ME AND IS AN HONOR TO
BE ABLE TO SERVE THE COMMUNITY I
WAS SET UP BY RHONDA AND ROBIN.
WHEN I GOT THE JOB I CALLED
ROBIN AND I CRIED BECAUSE OF MY
SUCCESS.
NOW I AM PURSUING A MASTER'S
DEGREE TO BECOME A LICENSED
COUNSELING.
THEN NFP PROGRAM NOT ONLY HELP
ME AS A MOM BUT AS AN
INDIVIDUAL.
HELP ME BETTER MYSELF AND NOT IN
A POSITION THAT ALWAYS WANTED TO
BE AND. I FELT LIKE SO MUCH HAS
CHANGED SINCE I ENTERED THE
PROGRAM A FEW YEARS AGO.
IT'S ENCOURAGING FOR ME TO SEE
HOW FAR I'VE COME.
NURSE RUN OVER SO HELPFUL DURING
MY PREGNANCY IN THE EARLY YEARS
OF MY DAUGHTER'S LIFE.
WE STILL STAY IN TOUCH UNTIL
THIS DAY. HAD ONE NURSE LIKE HER
WHO I COULD TRUST WITH QUESTIONS
ABOUT MY HEALTH WHEN I WAS
PREGNANT. MY DAUGHTER'S HEALTH
WHEN I WAS A NEW MOM. CHILD
DEVELOPMENT AS SHE GREW AND MY
CAREER GOALS HAS HELPED ME TO BE
A SUCCESSFUL PARENT.
I WILL CONTINUE TO SIRE MY KEY
ME THROUGH BE AYE H. IMPLANTING
THEM IN THE DIRECTION OF
IMPROVEMENT OF HEALTH AMONG
AFRICAN AMERICAN MOTHERS AND
BABIES. MY HOPE THAT IS NICE
FAMILY PARTNERSHIP IS MADE
AVAILABLE TO EVERY MOM THAT
MEETS THIS PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM
AS VALUABLE AS IT OFFERS A NEW
MOM A CHANCE AT HAVING A
POSITIVE FIRST TIME PAINTING
EXPERIENCE.
IT'S HARD BEING A NEW MOM ON
YOUR OWN.
NURSE FAMILY PARTNERSHIP GIVES
YOU SOMEONE TO HAVING YOUR POINT
A.
TO HELP YOU BE THE BEST MOM YOU
CAN BE.
THE NURSES RECOGNIZE YOUR
STRENGTHS
AND HELP YOU TO BELIEVE YOU CAN
DO IT.
I KNOW WITHOUT A DOUBT. THAT
OTHER FAMILIES LIKE ME WITH A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES THAN MINE CAN
BENEFIT FROM THIS PROGRAM.
I WILL CONTINUE TO PAY A FIRE BY
ENSURING MORE FAMILIES BENEFIT
FROM ITS AMAZING SERVICE THAT
MAKES A DIFFERENCE IMPACTS LIVES
AND EMPOWERS FIRST TIME PARENTS
TO BE THE BEST THEY CAN BE. I
TRULY HOPE THE CALIFORNIA BUT
CONTINUE SUPPORTING GREAT
EVIDENCE BASED HOME VISITING
PROGRAMS LIKENESS FAMILY
PARTNERSHIP.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMAN ARAMBULA
AND MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ANGELA ROCK
FROM ALLEN HERE FROM CHILDREN
NOW THINK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA
FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY.
CHILDREN NOW IS A NONPROFIT
PUBLIC POLICY RESEARCH AND
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION WORKING TO
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF CALIFORNIA
KIDS WE WORK ON POLICY ISSUES
ACROSS EDUCATION HEALTH AND
CHILD WELFARE DOMAINS INCLUDING
HOME VISITING.
I'M HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL UP PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR TO.
IMPLEMENT THAT HOWARD'S HOME
VISITING INITIATIVE AND
ADDITIONALLY HE TO FIND AN
ADDITIONAL FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
ANNUAL INVESTMENT IN THE PROGRAM
IN ORDER TO ENHANCE AND EXTENDS
THE REACH OF SERVICES FOR CAL
WORKS FAMILIES.
INCREASING SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH
POINTS EARLY CHILDHOOD IS A
CRUCIAL PERIOD OF TIME TO
ESTABLISH CHILDREN'S FOUNDATION
FOR LIFELONG HEALTH WELL BEING
AND SUCCESS. AND THE SCIENCE
ALSO MAKES IT CLEAR THAT
RELATIONSHIPS ARE WHAT FUEL THIS
EARLIEST BRAIN DEVELOPMENT.
IN THE FIRST FEW YEARS OF LIFE
BABY'S BRAINS ARE FORMING MORE
THAN ONE MILLION NEW NEURAL
CONNECTIONS EVERY SECONDS.
AND WHITE SUPPORTS THAT IN THE
STRONGEST WAY IS A STRONG STABLE
NURTURING RELATIONSHIP WITH AN
ADULT.
RESEARCH ALSO SHOWS THAT FIRST
TIME YOUNG PARENTS ARE
VULNERABLE AS WELL THE
PREFRONTAL CORTEX OF THE BRAIN
AND A YOUNG PERSON'S EMOTIONAL
MATURITY SELF IMAGE AND
JUDGMENT.
ARE STILL DEVELOPING UNTIL AGE
TWENTY FIVE.
YET WE ALSO KNOW THAT PARENTING
A VERY YOUNG CHILD PLACES%
ENORMOUS PHYSICAL EMOTIONAL
DEMANDS ON ADULTS.
PARENTS MAY NOT ALWAYS HAVE WHAT
THEY NEED OR KNOW WHERE TO TURN
FOR SUPPORT EVEN WHEN IT WAS IS
WITHIN REACH IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITY.
THIS IS A CRITICAL TIME TO
SUPPORT FAMILIES WITH YOU WILL
GENERATION PROGRAMS THAT FOSTER
THEIR SKILLS AND CAPACITY TO
TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES. AND TO
BEST TAKE CARE OF THEIR
CHILDREN.
POVERTY AND ECONOMIC HARDSHIP
CAUSE STRESS FOR PARENTS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO MEET THEIR
FAMILY'S BASIC NEEDS AND CAN
IMPACT MANY ASPECTS OF
CHILDREN'S HEALTH GROWTH AND
LEARNING. BUT THEY'RE PROVEN
RESOURCES AND SUPPORTS THE CAN
HELP FAMILIES NAVIGATE THESE
OBSTACLES.
CURRENTLY THEY ARE NOT REACHING
ENOUGH CALIFORNIA FAMILIES.
HOME VISITING PROGRAMS MATCH
EXPECTANT AND NEW PARENTS WITH
TRAINED PROFESSIONALS WHO
PROVIDE FAMILY CENTERED COACHING
EDUCATION SUPPORT. ON AN
INDIVIDUAL VOLUNTARY BASIS.
HOME VISITING REINFORCES PARENTS
OWN EFFORTS AND ABILITIES TO
GIVE THEIR CHILDREN THE BEST
START POSSIBLE. AND FOSTERS THE
CRITICAL PARENT CHILD BOND THAT
SETS THIS FOUNDATION FOR LONG
TERM HEALTH WELL BEING AND
SUCCESS.
HOME VISITING AS DEMONSTRATED A
SPECTRUM OF POSITIVE OUTCOMES
THAT DEFLECT AGAINST THE WORST
EFFECTS OF A FAMILY STRUGGLE
WITH PROPERTY.
AND PROVIDE VULNERABLE CHILDREN
IN FAMILIES WITH CRITICAL AND
LIFELONG PROTECTIVE FACTORS.
HOME VISITING ADDITIONALLY IS
VERY SCALABLE. IT'S ALIGNED SO
THE BEST PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION
SCIENCE THEIR FIDELITY CONTROLS
REPLICABLE. AND THERE ARE IS A
STRONG FOUNDATION OF LOCAL HOME
VISITING PROGRAMS AROUND THE
STATE CURRENTLY FUNDED BY
FEDERAL AND LOCAL SOURCES THAT
STAND READY TO ASSIST THE
DEPARTMENT IN IMPLEMENTING THIS
PROGRAM.
WE APPLAUD THIS COMMITTEE FOR
LAST YEAR INCLUDING A SIMILAR
INVESTMENT.
IN THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET FOR HOME
EVIDENCE BASED HOME VISITING FOR
HOW WORKS FAMILIES AND WE WOULD
URGE YOU THIS YEAR. TO.
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
AND ADDITIONALLY INVEST FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS THANK YOU.
THROUGH AYE BORN.
NO COMMENTS.
ALEJO MADE.
THANK YOU OUR OFFICE.
HIS NECK.
OUR OFFICE REVIEWED THE
GOVERNOR'S HOME VISITING
INITIATIVE WE MET WITH EXPERTS
REVIEWED THE LITERATURE.
AND THE EVIDENCE AS IT IS IS
STRONG HOMEBUILDING IT'S BEEN
WELL STUDIED HISTORICALLY AND WE
THINK AS A RESULT THAT'S FROM A
POLICY PERSPECTIVE IT WARRANTS
THE LEGISLATURE'S CONSIDERATION.
.
WE'VE VIEW THE HOME VISITING
INITIATIVE A SORT OF THE
CORNERSTONE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR THE USE OF FREE
DUBBED HANNAH FUNDS
SO FROM LAST YEAR TO THIS YEAR
THE GOVERNOR ANTICIPATES THAT.
THE COWARDS CASE WILL DECLINE
NOTABLY. THAT FREES UP SOME
TANNA FUNDS IN NEED THE BROADER
CAO WORKS BUDGET.
INCLUDED IN THE AGENDA ON PAGE
TWENTY SEVEN.
IS A UP A BRIEF TABLE.
THAT SUMMARIZES THE VARIOUS
COMPONENTS OF THIS FREED UP TEN
OF RESOURCES IT SOMEWHAT GREATER
THAN TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AND THE CORNERSTONE IF I MENTION
IS. THIS YEAR'S HOME VISITING
INITIATIVE AS WELL AS THE HOME
VISITING RESERVE AND OUR OFFICE
WOULD POINT OUT IN THINKING
ABOUT THIS TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THAT. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALIS BUT ONE APPROACH.
AND THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY NOW TO THINK ABOUT
THIS TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AND DEVELOP ITS OWN PRIORITIES
FOR THE TEN A PROGRAM FOR THE
COVERAGE PROGRAM INSIDE THE TENT
OF BUDGET.
.
WHICH COULD INCLUDE A GREATER
LEVEL OF FUNDING FOR HOME AND
VISITING OR SOME OTHER.
.
TOOK POLICY PRIORITY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE FINDS BUT IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR FOR THIS
COMMITTEE TO THINK ABOUT ITS
PRIORITIES FOR THESE FUNDS.
MISTER CHAIR IF I MAY BEFORE WE
HEAR PUBLIC COMMENT.
.
OFTENTIMES HELPFUL FOR US TO PUT
A FACE ON WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AND.
MISS MENDOZA WHO TESTIFIED
EARLIER. HAD BOTH A TEN YEAR OLD
AND A TWO YEAR OLD AND UNDER THE
CURRENT VERSION OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL SHE WOULD
HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED.
BECAUSE SHE HAD ONE MORE THAN
ONE CHILD. SHE ALSO WAS OVER THE
AGE OF TWENTY FIVE AT THE TIME
SHE HAD THE SECOND CHILD AND SO
THERE'S A SECOND EXCLUSION. AND
REALLY WOULD WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE A. PROGRAM THAT'S ROBUST
AND INCLUDING ALL OF THE
FAMILIES THAT COULD BENEFIT.
.
PART OF FINANCE.
BERMAN FINANCED HER WORDS I
THINK WE JUST NOTE THAT.
I'VE GIVEN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PRIORITIES AVAILABLE TANNA FUNDS
AND A TARGET POPULATION FOR THIS
PROGRAM WE SUPPORT THE.
HOME VISITING INITIATIVE AS
PROPOSED THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BUT THIS POINT WILL GO AHEAD
NOBODY'S SEPTA PUBLIC COMMENT.
COME ON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JAMIE
MAO HIGHER REPRESENT THE CHILD
ABUSE PREVENTION CENTER AND THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY RESOURCE
ASSOCIATION.
WHEAT FIRST LIKE TO THINK IDEA
ASSESS THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
.
AND DOCTOR ARAMBULA FOR A
LIFTING THE VISIBILITY OF HOME
VISITATION PROGRAM. AYE WE
ECHOED THE SENTIMENT STATED BY
DOCTOR ARAMBULA AND SUPPORT
ENHANCEMENTS EXPAND THE REACH
BEYOND FIRST TIME PARENTS UNDER
TWENTY FIVE. AND BEYOND THE
EXPANSION WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SEE
LANGUAGE INCLUDED TO STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE FAMILIES. TO BE
CONNECTED WITH LOCAL FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTERS AFTER
COMPLETING THE HOME VISITATION
PROGRAM TO ACCESS SERVICES AND
RESOURCES AND HAVE A SUPPORT
SYSTEM IN THE COMMUNITY AFTER
THE PROGRAM ENDS. AT THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY RESOURCE
ASSOCIATION SIFRA HAS FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTERS THAT CURRENTLY
UTILIZED MODEL AND WE FOUND THAT
IT'S VERY SUCCESSFUL IN THE HOME
VISITATION PROGRAM. IS CONNECTED
WITH THE FAMILY RESOURCE CENTER
AND IT'S VERY SUCCESSFUL FOR THE
FAMILIES WHO HAVE COMPLETED THE
PROGRAM.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THE DIALOGUE AND APPRECIATE THE
DIRECTION THAT THE CONVERSATIONS
I DON'T THINK YOU.
SELENA PRIVACY ARE YOU IN
SUPPORT.
TELE MENDOZA WITH PARA VOICES OF
CONTRAST COUNTY.
I'M ON THE BEHALF OF PARENTS
LIKE ME.
WHO WERE OVER THE AGE OF TWENTY
FIVE WHEN I HAD MY SECOND CHILD?
I SUPPORT THE CHAIRS PROPOSAL TO
MAKE THIS HOME VISIT PROGRAM
AVAILABLE TO ALL CAO WORK
PARENTS.
AND I STRONGLY BELIEVE.
NOT ONLY.
GOING TO VISIT YOU KNOW FOR THE
SUPPORT OF THAT BUT ALSO
BRINGING SOMEONE IN TO CHECK
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH BECAUSE.
WHEN I HAD MY SECOND CHILD.
I WAS BEING ABUSED
AND NOBODY KNEW.
SO I THINK THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
WITH EVERYTHING THAT'S GOING ON
IN THE WORLD THANK YOU.
Q..
JENNIFER CRAPPY PARA VOICES
CALIFORNIA SO WE SUPPORT AT THE
CHAIRS PROPOSAL TO INCLUDE ALL
FAMILIES I'M AND I THINK ABOUT
YOU KNOW MY OWN CHILD. AND AND
MY GRAND BABY AND YOU KNOW AS
SHE WAS THE CAL WORKS MOM AND ON
MEDI CAL AND.
YOU KNOW AT THAT PROCESS TO.
INCLUDE YOUR SECOND YEAR YOUR
CHILD INTO THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM
YOU KNOW THERE'S A WHOLE
APPLICATION PROCESS THAT NEEDS
TO HAPPEN AND AS A YOUNG PARENT
HERSELF.
THIS WAS REALLY CHALLENGING AND
SOMETHING THAT SOMEBODY LIKE A
HOME HEALTH SPECIALISTS COULD
HAVE REALLY SUPPORTED HER TO DO
SO THAT HER CHILD IS IN AND OUT
BEHIND ON HER IMMUNIZATIONS AND
OTHER ISSUES. DUE TO NOT BEING
ABLE TO GET HER MEDICAL STARTED
ON TIME
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE STILL
PREVENTS HE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE
FUND CALIFORNIA AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE DEPARTMENT FOR
MAKING US A PRIORITY.
AND STRONGLY SUPPORT ON DOCTOR
ARAMBULA IS A PROPOSAL TO.
INVEST ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
INTO HOME VISITING.
WE KNOW FROM THE RESEARCH THE
TREMENDOUS GOOD THAT HOME
VISITING CAN DO FOR FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
IT MAKES SENSE FOR US TO BE
INVESTING A IN MAKING SURE THAT
THE POOREST FAMILIES IN THOSE.
THAT ARE IN THE CAL WORKS
PROGRAM HAVE ACCESS TO THIS
IMPORTANT PROGRAM THANK YOU.
ON A HOUSE ABIDE WITH UNITED
WAYS OF CALIFORNIA I WILL ALIGN
MY COMMENTS WITH MY COLLEAGUE AT
CDF THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KEVIN AS THEIR COALITION
CALIFORNIA WELFARE WELFARE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION TH I WILL
DITTO ALL PREVIOUS TESTIMONY
THANK YOU WITH SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARGARET COURT
THE FIRST FIVE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HERE REPRESENTING ALL
FIFTY EIGHT LOCAL FIRST FIVE
COUNTY COMMISSIONS ACROSS THE
STATE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL. IN ADDITION TO DOCTOR
RAMBLES PROPOSAL TO ADDING
ADDITIONAL FIFTY MILLION I DO
REMEMBER THIS HEARING LAST YEAR
WHERE WE BROUGHT UP OF.
HOME VISITING CLAIM AS WELL WHO.
I HAD A VERY COMPELLING
TESTIMONY AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
SHE WOULD HAVE NOT RECEIVED HOME
VISITING UNDER THE CURRENT
PROPOSAL BECAUSE SHE HAD TWO
CHILDREN. AND SHE WAS ALSO OVER
THE EDGE TWENTY FIVE SO REALLY
I'M STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THE THE
LOOK AT THIS PROPOSAL AND WANT
TO THANK ALSO THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE DEPARTMENT FOR EXAMINING
THIS PSALM. EXAMINING EVIDENCE
OF EVIDENCE BASED HOME VISITING
THANK YOU.
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU JUST GO ARE THE WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY ALSO VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL IN
SUPPORT OF THAT AND ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF DOCTOR ARAMBULA HAS.
AN ADDITIONAL A BENEFIT TO US
MAKE SURE THAT EVERY PARENT IN
THE PROGRAM CAN BE SIR.
LITTLE ERIC HARRIS ON BEHALF
MARCH DON'S IN SUPPORT OF THE
DEMONSTRATIONS PROPOSAL AS WELL
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER AROUND OF
THIS PROPOSAL THAT.
FRANK MCCOURT THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ALSO IN SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL IN
THE.
THE CHAIR'S ARM EXPANSION OF IT
THANKS.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY.
MATHIS.
I ANY THIS PRO PROPOSAL DISCOS
BACKED LAID STATED EARLIER ABOUT
THE USE OF TAKING THESE WORKERS.
BY LOOKING AT HOW WE'RE DOING
THAT.
WHICH WOULD THEN GIVE US MORE
WORKERS THAT WE COULD SEND IN
THE HOMES THIS IS THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
QUITE FRANKLY IN OUR DAY AND
AGE HIT THE KIND OF WAS MY MIND
OR NOT HAVING DISCUSSIONS ABOUT.
GETTING ALL THESE WORKERS A
SMART CARD A TABLET AND HAVING
THEM GOING BE IN EVERY SINGLE
HOME OF A CALPERS PARENT.
.
WE'VE GOT A LONG WAY TO GO TO
GET THERE AND THIS IS A GOOD
STEPS OF THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
US FOR.
ANYONE ELSE.
I JUST A COMMENT I'D LIKE TO TO
ASK.
THAT THE.
ELLIE  CONSIDER WORKING WITH
THE SS.
AND OUR STAFF TO FIGURE OUT HOW
MUCH.
IN GENERAL FUND MONEY WOULD
REQUIRED A TOP WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED.
TO IMPLEMENT THE X. AN EXPANDED
VERSION OF THIS PROGRAM.
AND HOPE WE CAN COME BACK TO
LISTEN IN MAY.
WITH THAT WITH THAT INFORMATION
WE HAD GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EVERYONE
INCLUDING ANOTHER AMAZINGLY
COMPELLING WITNESS TODAY. SO
MUCH MUCH APPRECIATED THANK YOU.
SO WE WILL BE HOLDING HOLDING
THIS ITEM OPEN
I.
RIGHT ON TIME.
I WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE FIVE
AND START WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO.
I'VE THAT BIG MISTER CHAIR MUCH
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT HERE I WANT PRESENT ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF AND IS A MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN.
IN AN EFFORT I WOULD COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECT ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA IN THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS WESTERN LAW
CENTER.
A LOT POVERTY WE WANNA
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN INCREASE
THE TEMPORARY SHELTER. UP TO
EIGHTY FIVE ARE DOLLARS PER DAY
FOR CAL GRANT FAMILIES ABOUT THE
THAT'S UP FROM SIXTY FIVE.
DOLLARS ARE WE ALSO WANT TO
ELIMINATE THE REQUIREMENT OF THE
BENEFIT BEING YOU SIXTEEN DAYS
CONSECUTIVELY WE. WE HAD.
DONE THIS LAST YEAR BUT NOW
AFTER REFLECTION BEGIN TO
REALIZE ITS PLAY BETTER TO
SCATTER THEM OUT. ON IN THE
COULD BE SOME EFFICIENCIES AND
SAVINGS AS WELL ASSEMBLY HAS A
NEED TO USE THE ENTIRE SIXTEEN
DAYS SO THAT WE THOUGHT IT WAS A
BETTER.
A BETTER APPROACH.
I IN THE INTEREST OF A BREVITY.
I'D BETTER.
IT'S A THAT THE PROPOSAL WE
ASSUME WILL BE BETWEEN TWELVE
AND FIFTEEN A MILLION BUT AND
IT'S JUST A BREVITY I'D HAVE A
WITNESS.
GREAT THANK YOU.
I BELIEVE THAT WHEN A SLOW DAHLE
SUDDEN. MOVEMENTS ARE RUSHING Y.
I BEG YOUR PARDON.
I'M LOOK WILL LIKE THAT THANK
YOU SO MUCH OF WHAT THE ME
INTRODUCE ALLEY SUTTON WHO IS
THE BRANCH CHIEF OVER HOUSING.
I SIGHED IN RELIEF THAT WITH
RESPECT TO ME.
YES THE WE.
HAD PROVIDED THERE WAS A BILL
ON ON THIS LAST YEAR'S BOMBING
IT PROVIDED A LITTLE BIT OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON IT.
AND ACTUALLY IN AB TWO THIRTY
SIX LAST YEAR WE HAD BAND.
REQUESTED TO DO A REPORT TO TO
GIVE BACK THE LEGISLATURE AT THE
END OF THIS YEAR AROUND.
THE ACTUAL TRUE COST OF.
OTHER NIGHTLY SHELTER SO WE'RE
IN THE MIDST OF DOING THAT WE DO
ON YOU KNOW.
I JUST REMIND ANECDOTAL COUNTY
BASIS WE ARE HEARING IT IS QUITE
DIFFICULT TO THE HOUSE AND FIND
A SAFE.
NIGHTLY MOTEL FOR SIXTY FIVE
DOLLARS A NIGHT SO I THINK YOU
KNOW WE ARE WE'RE IN THE MIDST
OF OF GATHERING DATA ON IT RIGHT
NOW BUT I'D I DON'T THINK THAT.
WE DISAGREE WITH THAT HE SAID
THAT.
.
IN ON THE ON THE MERITS OF IT ON
THAT THE SIXTEEN DAY CONSECUTIVE
WE HAVE PROVIDED SOME TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ON THE BILL. THAT'S
OUT AND I BOTH LAST YEAR AND
THIS YEAR SORT OF SUGGESTING
THAT PERHAPS MAKING IT WITHIN A
THIRTY DAY WINDOW OUR HOPE
REALLY IS AS WE HAVE THIS ANDY
JUST PETER TO PARADE THESE
TOGETHER. AND TO PROVIDE SORT OF
A ROUTE FOR PERMANENT HOUSING
STABILITY RATHER THAN SOMETHING
THAT WAS SORT OF GOING IN AND
OUT OF THAT THE MOTELS
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR SO. JUSTA
I'M A FAMILY MAN THAT WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING IN PROVIDING JAN.
RICK.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE A LOW
INCOME.
TIRE WOULD SPUR TO FINANCE IT
THINK WE WOULD JUST NOTE NOT
WITHSTANDING THE MERIT OF THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD LIKELY BE IN THE
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY ON GOING IN GENERAL
FUND.
AND WITH THIS REAP. THIS
PROPOSAL AND OTHERS THAT WERE
INCLUDED AS PART OF THE BUDGET
WERE WORKING WITH WITH YOUR
STAFF OF THE COMMITTEE TO.
HELP IN ANY WAY THAT WE CAN AS
THE DEFAULT THROUGH MY.
GREAT. I WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE FIVE.
A FRANK BACK WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
WHEN I THINK THE.
THE AUTHOR AND WE'RE PLEASED TO
CO SPONSOR. FROM OUR MEMBERS
STANDPOINT THE GENESIS WAS OF A
MESSIAH MID WITNESS SUCH AN
ALLUDED TO.
WE HAVE FOLKS THAT ARE HOMELESS
ON THE VERGE OF HOMELESSNESS
ELIGIBLE FOR HOMELESS ASSISTANCE
BENEFIT.
TO GET THEM OFF THE STREET AND
IT'S EXTREMELY DIFFICULT IN MANY
PLACES TO FIND.
A A PLACE THAT WILL TAKE SOME
THE FIVE DOLLARS IN SO. THAT THE
GOAL OF THE INCREASE IS NOT TO.
INCREASE THE BOTTOM LINE OF
THOSE SHELTER PROVIDERS BUT
ACTUALLY TO BE ABLE TO FIND A
PLACE FOR PEOPLE TO STAY. ON THE
SAME THING WITH THE OTHER
ELEMENTS OF THE PROVISION IN SO
WE THINK THIS THIS WILL HELP US
GET PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS AND
TO WORK ME APPRECIATE.
ARM THE AUTHOR AND ABOUT MR
MAIENSCHEIN AND URGENT
CONSIDERATION.
FARMS CHAIR MICRO WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY COME
WE ALSO SUPPORT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO'S
AUGMENTATION REQUEST ARM AND A
WE THINK GIVEN THE SITUATION
THAT WE SEE IN THE STREETS
AROUND HOMELESSNESS. ARM FOR
POOR FAMILIES THAT THIS IS AN
ABSOLUTELY URGENT REQUEST I'M I
DO WANT TO.
THOUGH CALM ENTERED SUGGESTS
THAT.
MISS SUTTON'S REMARKS THAT
THERE WE NEED
WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT BETTER
WAYS TO WEAVE TOGETHER THE WAY
THESE PROGRAMS WORK. EL IS LONG
OVERDUE MANY OF THIS PROGRAM
PARTICULAR DATES IT'S TIME BACK
IN THE EARLY NINETEEN NINETIES.
THIS IS A VERY DIFFERENT TIME
WE HAVE A LOT AND WE'VE LEARNED
A LOT IN THE LAST TWENTY FIVE
PLUS YEARS AND WE OUGHT TO BE
PUTTING THAT TO PRACTICE AND WE
ALL BE LOOKING AT THE WAYS IN
WHICH OUR CURRENT PROGRAMS. CAN
WORK BETTER TOGETHER THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR.
MICHELLE SOBRE ARENSKY
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND IN
STRONG SUPPORT THINK HIM.
TRACY PATTERSON CALIFORNIA FOOD
POLICY ADVOCATES IN STRONG
SUPPORT BECAME.
SELENA PRIOR SEIU IN SUPPORT.
KEVIN I THINK CHOLISH CALIFORNIA
WELFARE RIGHTS WORK
ORGANIZATIONS OF COURSE.
STRONG SUPPORT.
PROGRAM WAS ENACTED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN.
THE TIME THEY WERE PAYING THIRTY
DOLLARS A DAY.
FIND IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE.
BUT FOURTEEN YEARS LATER WHEN UP
TO FORTY.
THE TWO THOUSAND SIX A ONE UP TO
SIXTY FIVE. THREE AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TO STILL THE SIXTY FIVE
DOLLARS.
AND SIXTY FIVE DOLLARS WHO IT
DOESN'T GET YOU A PLACE THAT IS
HABITABLE FOR KIDS.
THE BUT THE SIXTEEN DOLLARS IN
THE IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN YOU
COULD FIND A PLACE MAYBE IT'S
SIXTEEN DAYS.
THESE DAYS EVERY PARTICLE AND
APPLY FOR PART BUT YOU HAVE TO
FILL OUT AN APPLICATION YOU HAVE
TO TURN AND THE CHECK YOUR
CREDIT. THERE'S A WHOLEBUNCH OF
PARIS TO GETTING PLACES.
SO IT'S GOOD TO HAVE THE CONF.
CUMULATIVE THE THE DAY'S TO
BEEN STAGGERED SO YOU ONLY GET
SIXTY DAY SO MAYBE TO THIS ACT
THERE WITH MY UNCLE AND THEN I
GO TO A HOTEL FOR THEIR THREE
DAYS COMFORTABLE FLEXIBILITY.
BUT THE THIRTY DAYS IS NOT
ENOUGH TIME FOR PEOPLE TO FIND A
PLACE.
SHOULD BE SIXTY DAYS OR NINETY
DAYS THANK YOU.
JUSTIN GO CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL THANK
YOU SIR.
ANDERSON COVERAGE DECISION IF IT
MAKES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE FIVE A BRING IT UP TO
THE DYESS FOR ANY QUESTIONS WE
MAY HAVE.
SEEING NONE WE WILL HOLD THIS
ISSUE OPEN. AND SINCE.
YOU'RE PRESENTING ON ISSUES
SIXTEEN I WANTED TO SEE IF
SOMEONE EVER SANTIAGO WANTED TO
PRESENT ON THE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I APPRECIATE A HOBBY A BRIEFING
IN THE COMMITTEE'S INTEREST
THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU YES PLEASE.
THANK YOU HERE PRESENT.
IN SUBCOMMITTEE ONE THE
APPROPRIATION OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS. OUGHT TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES FOR THE
PURPOSES OF PROVIDING FINE FUNDS
TO QUALIFIED NONPROFITS IN ORDER
TO DELIVER THE NECESSARY
IMMIGRATION SERVICES TO
CALIFORNIANS. ARE CURRENTLY OR
FORMERLY RECIPIENTS OF A TPS.
I THINK MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU.
NEXT ON THE PROPOSAL WE HAVE.
.
RECTOR LIKE PORN AND MARCELLO
RUIZ.
IF YOU HAVE A COPY.
BOB.
MARCELA REESE OF COURSE I'M
HEADS ARE IMMIGRATION SERVICES
BRANCH IN SO I'LL ASK HER TO.
AFTERNOON CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MASALA RESA MIGRATION REFUGEE
PROGRAMS BRANCH.
THE DEPARTMENT WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT EARLIER THIS YEAR AFTER THE
ANNOUNCEMENT OF THE END OF TP
ASTRAL SALVADOR DEPARTMENT MADE
AN INVESTMENT OF THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO HELP WITH
THE RE REGISTRY SHOULD.
AND WORK WITH PARTNERS
PARTICULARLY IN THE LOS ANGELES
AREA WHERE THERE'S A HIGH
CONCENTRATION OF TPS.
HOLDERS OF THE DEPARTMENT WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT CURRENTLY ARE
CURRENT STATUTORY STRUCTURE
ALLOWS FOR MOST OF THE SERVICES
FOR FOR. TPS HOLDERS AND OF
COURSE ISSUES AROUND THE BUDGET
ARE A PRIORITY A DECISION BEFORE
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR.
THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ILIO.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE ISSUE
SIXTEEN.
KEVIN AS THEIR QUARTERS
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION TO STRONG SUPPORT
THIS PROPOSAL THINK.
DANIEL SHARP AT THE CENTRAL
AMERICAN RESOURCE CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT WE
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
BRINGING ATTENTION TO THE TPS
COMMUNITY AND ITS ENORMOUS LEGAL
SERVICE NEEDS THAT HAVE. ON
PREVIOUSLY BANNED BAN ON
RECOGNIZE SO THANK YOU.
YOU SIR.
MISTER CHAIR MY CARE WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WE'RE ALSO IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON BECAUSE OF MY
* WITH CENTRAL VALLEY GOING
TO CHRISTIAN COLLABORATIVE WITH
SPORTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON PRIEM AARTHI WITH
SERVICES IMMIGRANT RIGHTS IN
EDUCATION AT WORK SIREN WHERE IN
SUPPORT.
I COMMEND.
REPTILIAN ONE HAVE YOU TO US
BECAUSE WE THE KITCHENER SINFUL
CONDITION I WOULDN'T SUPPORT.
CHRIS RESPONSE OF THE CHAIR OF
THE COLLEGE FROM IN IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS INSTRUCTS APART.
AFTERNOON DAHLE KENOSHA FROM THE
IMMIGRANT LEGAL RESOURCE CENTER
WHERE ALSO IN SUPPORT.
HUMAN.
RENEE PARA SAIL YOU CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NO MORE AND NO ONE ELSE
RUNNING IN THE DOOR REPUBLIC
COMMON ON ISSUE SIXTEEN. A BRING
IT UP TO THE DYESS FOR ANY
COMMENTS WE MAY HAVE.
I'D LIKE TO ADD MY OWN TO SENSE
IF I CAN'T I HAD THE HONOR OF
GOING TO EL SALVADOR THIS YEAR
WITH THE SPEAKER. AND A
DELEGATION AND WHO HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF MEETING WITH THEIR
PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDENT.
AND HEAD OF THEIR CONGRESS
AND SAW FIRST HAND WHERE A.
THAT TPS.
RECIPIENTS ARE RECEIVED INTO
THEIR COUNTRY.
AND IT WAS REMOVED THAT.
THAT MANY OF THESE.
CALIFORNIANS WERE BEING TAKEN
FROM OUR COUNTRY AND PUT INTO A
COUNTRY THEY DID NOT KNOW.
AND IT WAS A MEMORY THAT WILL BE
SCARRED IN MY MIND FOR AWHILE.
AND HAVING A CITY IN MY
COMMUNITY MENDOTA WHICH IS A
MAJORITY EL SALVADORAN.
I KNOW THAT THIS ISSUE IS CLOSE
TO HOME FOR ME AS WELL SOME.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
SIXTEEN OPEN AT THIS TIME AND
WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR BRING UP FOR.
WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE SIX.
MISTER CHAIR I COULD JUST ASK
BACK ON ISSUE FIVE WERE THERE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS ON THE
HOMELESS HOUSING LOAN PROGRAM
OTHERWISE WE'LL GO TO SIX.
GOOD.
TO THIS.
PHONE.
WELL LAST.
FINE IF THAT'S OKAY IN THE.
SO WE HAVE TO PROPOSALS.
I KILL WITH POSTED LE.
WE CUT HIM.
NO WE DON'T SURROUND THAT.
IF THE UP.
MY APOLOGIES MISTER CHAIR.
MICRO THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY.
THESE ARE.
THE PANEL THAT WE'RE HERE TO
DISCUSS THE ADVOCATES PROPOSALS.
ANSWER KEVIN AND I ARE GOING TO
EACH HAVE A PROPOSAL TO. TALK
ABOUT.
.
THE FIRST ONE THAT I WILL
DISCUSS IS THE.
IS THE TIME CLOCK.
FOR COWARDS.
AS I'M SURE YOU'RE AWARE.
.
THAT FEDERAL CLOCK ALLOWS UNDER
CANNOT ALLOW US FOR. A RECIPIENT
TO STAY ON EIGHT FOR SIXTY
MONTHS.
ALMOST SOME TWO THIRDS OF THE
STATES IN THE UNITED STATES
RIGHT NOW IN FACT DO YOU HAVE A
SIXTEEN MONTH TIME CLOCK.
.
WE A AND.
IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE. IT TIME
OF SIGNIFICANT FISCAL DISTRESS
FOR OUR STATE.
MAYBE CHANGE THAT CLOCK AND WE
WENT TO.
WE MADE TWO CHANGES ACTUALLY WE
WE WE STARTED THE SO CALLED
TWENTY FOUR MONTH FLEXIBLE
CLOCK.
THAT ALLOWED RECIPIENTS APART
SPEIGHT IN A WIDE RANGE OF
ACTIVITIES.
AND THEN AFTER THOSE TWENTY
FOUR MONTHS WERE USED UP.
A FAMILIES CAN HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FOUR MONTHS ON
ASSISTANCE THAT WAS BASED ON THE
CANNIBALS.
AND SO THAT'S THOUGH WORLD THAT
WE'VE LIVED IN CENTS TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE. WE ONLY
HAVE FORTY EIGHT MONTHS ON
ASSISTANCE.
FOR YOU FOR A. OF A PERCENTAGE
OF OUR FAMILIES A PORTION OF OUR
FAMILIES THIS THIS ACTUALLY AXES
OF SIGNIFICANT BARRIER. AND IT
DOES SO I THINK IN TWO WAYS
FIRST OF ALL FOR FAMILIES WHO
HAVE I THINK SIGNIFICANT
BARRIERS JUST TO BE ABLE TO
EFFECTIVELY PARTICIPATE ON
WELFARE TO WORK. PEOPLE WITH
LEARNING DISABILITIES PEOPLE WHO
MAY NOT WHOSE ENGLISH IS NOT
THEIR FIRST LANGUAGE.
PEOPLE WITH MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES FOR EXAMPLE THEY
FREQUENTLY NEED MORE TIME JUST
LIKE WE SEE WITH PEOPLE HAVE
DISABILITIES WE HAVE AN
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES ACT.
THAT ALLOWS PEOPLE HAVE THAT
TIME THAT THEY NEED IN ORDER TO
GET THROUGH ACTIVITIES.
SO WE HAVE A OR A POPULATION
THAT REALLY COULD USE NOT ONLY
SIXTEEN MONTHS BUT PROBABLY
BEYOND THAT IN SOME CASES
BECAUSE OF THEIR. PARTICULAR
SITUATIONS THAT THEY HAVE.
AND THEN THE SECOND GROUP OF
PEOPLE THAT WE SEE THAT ARE I
THINK IMPACTED SIGNIFICANTLY BY
THE LIMIT OF A FORTIETH MONTH
CLOCK.
OUR FAMILY SEWER AND EDUCATION
PROGRAMS
AND IT HAS BECOME INCREASINGLY
DIFFICULT. I GOT THROUGH COLLEGE
IN FOUR YEARS.
THAT'S NOT VERY COMMON ANYMORE
AND I THINK PARTICULARLY FOR
PEOPLE ON CAL WORKS WHO HAVE
OTHER WORK ACTIVITIES THAT THEY
HAVE TO MEET. ON THEIR PROGRESS
THROUGH TO A FOUR YEAR DEGREE OR
EVEN GETTING THROUGH A TWO YEAR
DEGREE. CAN FREQUENTLY TAKE
THREE YEARS OR MORE.
I DO A LOT OF COWARDS TRAINING
THAT CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES LIKE AT THE MEET A LOT
OF RECIPIENTS.
ARM AND ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I
GET IT EVERY SESSION IS AYE MAK
MIKE I I HAVE I'M I'VE GOT A
NOTICE THAT MY FORTY EIGHT
MONTHS ARE ABOUT TO EXPIRE. BUT
THE PROGRAM THAT I MEAN THAT THE
COUNTY HAS PUT ME IN. WILL I'M
WILL END AFTER MY FORTY EIGHT
MONTHS.
WHAT SHOULD I DO?
AND I LITERALLY DON'T DON'T HAVE
AN ANSWER FOR THEM I HAVE NO
SUGGESTION FOR THAT.
HOUSEHOLD AT THIS POINT ABOUT
WHAT THEY SHOULD DO I THE ONLY
THING REALLY THEY CAN DO IS TRY
TO GET A LEGAL SERVICE ATTORNEY.
MAYBE GO BACK AND COUNT AND SEE
IF THAT COUNTY ACCURATELY COUNT
OF THE NUMBER OF MONTHS. BUT
BEYOND THAT THERE'S NOTHING WE
CAN DO TO HELP MAKE SURE THAT
PERSON COMPLETES THAT PROGRAM.
SO FOR THESE REASONS AND I JUST
THINK ON THE GROUNDS OF BASIC
EQUITY AND THE FACT THAT THE.
TO REMIND US ALL THAT THE
DECISION TO GO TO A SIXTEEN
MONTH CLOCK. WAS DONE.
AS WE ELIMINATED A LIFE THERE
WITH THE RIGHT TO BENEFITS OVER
A PERSON'S TIME ON AID THE
ENTIRE TIME THEY'RE ON A WE YOU
SO NOT HAVE ANY TIME LIMIT AT
ALL. SO FOR US TO GO FROM THAT
A SIXTY MONTHS DOWN TO FORTY
EIGHT. UM SEEMS RATHER ARBITRARY
AND WE WOULD REQUEST THAT THE
COMMITTEE CONSIDER. RESTORING
THE SIXTY MARK TIME CLOCK FOR
COWARDS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE CABINET THE CHORUS A
CALIFORNIA WOMAN RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION.
I JUST MORE AB ONE MORE THING
THAT THE AVERAGE STAY ON WELFARE
BUT TWENTY FIVE MONTHS.
SO NOT EVERYBODY COMES TO THE
SIXTH MONTH.
AND PUT OF THOUGHT GOING TO
THROW A WOULD HELP THOSE WHO
REALLY REALLY NEED IT.
PROPOSAL THAT THAT THAT A
PROBLEM THAT WE'VE HAD. FOR YOU
KNOW MY NUMBER OF YOURS IS
PEOPLE WHO WERE ALREADY IN
COLLEGE WHEN THEY APPLY FOR
PUBLIC BENEFITS.
THEY GET WHAT THEY CALL SELF
INITIATED PROGRAM THE DONORS TO
SIP.
AND WHEN YOU ASSERT BICU GOING
TO COLLEGE THEY ALLOW YOU TO
CONTINUE WHAT HE STARTED RIDE
THEN STOPPING WHICH JUST
STARTED.
IF YOU DON'T GET STUDY TIME.
BUT IF YOU OUR REFER TO COLLEGE
BY THE WELFARE SYSTEM.
EARL IN WITHOUT BEING A SIP THEN
YOU GET STUDY TIME.
SO THE PROPOSAL OVER HERE IS WHY
CAN'T SIPS GET WORTH THIRTY TIME
AND THEY'VE ALWAYS SAID WHAT
THAT WITH A TECHNICAL ERROR. IN
THE LEGISLATION THOUGHT THIS IS
JUST GOING TO FIX THAT INSAFE
AGAINST PARTY TIME AS A REGULAR
PERSON GOING TO COLLEGE.
SHE ALSO GETS THIRTY TIME AS THE
SIP.
AND I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION TO
PROBABLY THINKING.
LIKE I THINK FOR THE DIRECTOR
ATARI.
I USUALLY DIRECTOR BY MY MEMORY
DOESN'T GO BACK FAR ENOUGH TO
TELL WHETHER THAT WAS A
TECHNICAL ERROR OR WHAT HAPPENED
I MEAN OBVIOUSLY THERE'S AND.
INCONSISTENCY.
NO OBJECTION TO THAT
THE THE ONLY THING I WOULD NOTE
A PURPOSE TO HAROLD'S. COMMENTS
ON THE SIXTY VERSUS FORTY EIGHT
MONTHLY.
IS THE IT'S A TIME LIMIT IN
CALIFORNIA ON ADULTS
IT'S NOT ON. CHILDREN CHILDREN
REMAIN ELIGIBLE UNTIL THEY TURN
EIGHTEEN OR EVEN BEYOND
DEPENDING ON EDUCATION.
ALL THE.
SO I I WOULD JUST MAKE THAT NO
BUT I MEAN THAT'S NOT TO.
ARGUE.
THE POINT ABOUT THERE BEING ON
ADULTS WHO.
WIND UP IN DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES PROMPTED HIM THEY.
TWO GROUPS BROADLY THAT WERE
BEING CHARACTERIZED.
FOR FOR THOSE FOR WHOM THERE'S
LIKE IT'S A SIGNIFICANT
DISABILITY.
WHO?
WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING ANYWAY
AND THIS IS NOT ARGUE AND SIXTY
MONTHS AS WE SHOULD BE? ARE
LOOKING FOR ANOTHER LONG TERM
SOLUTION IN TERMS OF LINKAGE TO
WITH THE SYSTEM
DISABILITIES.
ARM BUT CERTAINLY IN THIS DAY
AND AGE FOR PEOPLE TRYING TO
COMPLETE A COLLEGE DEGREE ON
GETTING CLASSES.
A CHALLENGE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA OF ANY
COMMENTS.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ON ISSUE SIX
OF THE.
MICHELLE SOBRE VINCE GAGE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF BOTH A
ADVOCATE PROPOSAL'S RUDE AND
NOTE THAT. CHILDREN ARE ARE PART
OF FAMILIES SO.
MAKING SURE THAT WE GO BACK TO
A SIXTEEN MONTH CLOCK IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
DIONNE AARON THERE ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AS THE ONE PERSON IN THE
ROOM BUT DOES HAVE THE MEMORY.
SO YOU.
YOU GAVE ME AN OPENING I JUST
COULDN'T. COULDN'T PASS IT UP AS
ONE OF THE ALL AS ONE OF THE NOT
THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL BUT AS
ONE OF THE NEGOTIATORS ON THE
BILL IT WAS A TECHNICAL ERROR WE
NEVER HAD ANY INTENTION.
OF DISCRIMINATING AGAINST
AGAINST SIPS VERSUS THOSE THE
GATE THAT GOT THE REFERRAL FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OR ITS ALLIES BE
CLEAR ABOUT THAT. THE OTHER
POINT THAT I WANTED TO MAKE IS
THAT IS AS THE DIRECTOR POINTED
OUT WE NEED TO BE CREATED THAT
ENTITLED WEEK WE LEFT THE
ENTITLEMENT FOR CHILDREN CRY.
BUT THE MOMENT YOU TAKE AWAY
THE GRANT FROM THE PARENT THAT
AFFECTS THE CHILDREN HERE TAKING
ABOUT REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT'S COMING INTO THAT
FAMILY.
AND SO ON WE NEED WE NEED TO
RECTIFY THAT GO BACK TO SIXTY
MONTHS AGAIN.
I'M WE WERE NOT THE PEOPLE THAT
VOTED FOR SIXTY MONTHS IN THE
FIRST PLACE HYPE THE FEDS DID
THAT.
ARMY IN AN EXCHANGE THAT SOME
OF US WERE VERY UPSET ABOUT IN
THOSE YEARS WHEN IT HAPPENED BUT
WE HAVE TO LIVE WITH THAT ARM
BUT IT JUST SEEMS TO ME IT'S
TIME TO GO BACK TO SIXTY MONTHS
AGAIN THOSE FAMILIES THAT ARE
SITTING IN COLLEGE. AS YOU JUST
SAID.
ARE STRUGGLING TO MAKE IT AND
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS THAT OVER
THE YEARS WE'VE WHEN WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL AND
FOUGHT THE PROPOSAL WHEN THE
DEPARTMENT IS. NOT THE
DEPARTMENT WHEN THE
ADMINISTRATION WAS PROPOSING TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF OF MONTHS
AND THAT KIND OF THING.
OF THE STARS OF OUR SYSTEM AND I
MEAN THE THE FIPS WOULD COME UP
AND TESTIFY RIGHT ABOUT THE
MEANING THE MEANING OF WHAT IT
MEANT TO BE ABLE TO GO TO TOOK.
CHICKEN ACADEMIC IN A DEGREE AND
THE FACT THAT THEY COULD GO OFF
OF PUBLIC ASSISTANCE THAT'S WHAT
YOU WANT I WANT.
EVEN SO ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO
TO ACHIEVE THAT AND TO ENCOURAGE
IT WE SHOULD BE ENCOURAGING AND
THAT'S THE WAY WE WROTE THE
ORIGINAL LEGISLATION WAS TO
ENCOURAGE THAT.
THANK YOU AND I JUST WANTED TO
RECOGNIZE FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
THE ON AIR ENORMOUS WHILE. YOUR
EXPERTISE HERE.
SHANTI PRASAD ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM.
PENNY COVER IS A CESSATION OF IT
BANKS IN SUPPORT OF OF
PROPOSALS.
SIR.
IT'S ME AGAIN SELENA PIRACY ES
UN SUPPORT.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
I'LL BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS
FOR ANY QUESTION.
I WOULD HAVE A COMMENT.
NEITHER OF THESE
PROPOSALS HAVE COST ESTIMATES I
WAS WONDERING IF.
DEPARTMENT WAS ABLE TO HELP US
IN PROVIDING A COST ESTIMATE.
OVER THE NEXT MONTH OR SO.
SO THAT WE CAN HELP TO
DELIBERATE.
WE CERTAINLY WORK WITH PUBLIC
FINANCING.
ABSOLUTELY FIGHTS CAN.
GREAT THANK YOU WOULD BE GLAD TO
WORK WITH THEM.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE SIX
OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE SEVEN.
I'M GOING TO BE JOINED BY TODD
PLANNED OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
FAMILY ENGAGEMENT APARTMENT
DIVISIONS ARM. LET ME QUICKLY
START OUT ON THIS
SURE THERE'S LONG JOURNEY COMING
TO THE.
ARM AS YOU KNOW ON BOTH BECAUSE
WE THOUGHT IT WAS A GOOD IDEA IF
IT IS A GOOD IDEA. THE
FINGERPRINTING SYSTEM IS GOING
TO AND
FOR CAL WORKS RECIPIENTS ON OR
APPLICANTS.
ALL AT THE END OF JUNE.
THE. IN THE COURSE OF.
PLANNING FOR ENDING IT WE LOOKED
AT SOME POSSIBILITIES
OF USING SOME AUTOMATION SYSTEMS
TO SEE IF WE COULD SIMPLIFY. AND
MAKE IT EASIER AND LESS PAPER
BURDENSOME FOR SOME PEOPLE TO
APPLY. HARM THAT BECAME A
CONTROVERSIAL ISSUE IT MADE
SENSE NOT TO PURSUE IT.
MOVE IN THE SPIRIT OF COMEDY.
ARM AND SO WE WILL BE WHAT WE
INTEND TO DO IS.
RETAIN CURRENT PROCEDURE OF FOR
ALL APPLICANTS
AND.
TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE ARE
FUTURE POSSIBILITIES TO. OFFER.
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO USE.
AUTOMATED SYSTEMS ETCETERA FOR
IDENTIFICATION WE WILL ADDRESS
THAT IN THE WORK BEING.
LORD.
YEAH WITH A UNIVERSAL WORK WITH
AN APPLICATION.
AND.
LEAVE THAT THERE.
M. NEXT ON MY AGENDA HAVE MIKE
HERALD WITH WESTERN CENTER LAN
PARTY.
UNLESS MISTER BLAND AT SOMETHING
WANTED AT NOT ONLY ECHO THE.
THOUGHTS OF THE DIRECTOR THAT I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF COMMON
GROUND HERE ON THE ENDING OF US
FOR US AND.
ESSENTIALLY WILL BE PUTTING
FORWARD IN ALL COUNTY LETTER
ALONG THE LINES MISTER LIKE BORN
JUST SAID OF SENSUALLY
CONTINUING THE CURRENT PRACTICE.
RESPECTED IN PERSON.
VERIFICATIONS.
NOPE NO KBA SYSTEM.
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AGAIN
MIKE CARROLL WITH WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY UP FIRST SO I
JUST WANNA.
PLEASED TO HEAR THE
ADMINISTRATION.
SAY THAT THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
BE PURSUING THE KBA SYSTEM.
WE'VE SPENT A LOT OF TIME WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OVER THE LAST
YEAR MANY OF US IN THIS ROOM
HAVE TO STAFF INCLUDED.
AND WE THINK.
THIS ACTUALLY VERY GOOD NEWS
AND THAT THE STAKEHOLDERS HOPE
WE NOW CAN WORK FOR TOWARDS.
COMPROMISE.
TO GO AWAY TO MOVE FORWARD.
THAT WILL MAINTAIN BALLPARK
STRONG PROGRAM INTEGRITY
STANDARDS THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE.
AT THE SAME TIME ALSO
POTENTIALLY DELIVER.
ON THE PROMISE OF GETTING
WELFARE BENEFITS IMPROVE MORE
QUICKLY AND CORRECTLY AND
ACCURATELY OVERTIME.
SO JUST A COUPLE OF COMMENTS
THOUGH IS WE GO FOR IT I AS WE
GO INTO THAT PROCESS I WANTED TO
KNOW.
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WERE REALLY STRIVING FOR IN THIS
PROCESS IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PROGRAM'S REALLY. ON TREAT
EVERYONE THE SAME.
WEEK I THINK IN THE PAST IT
WOULD BE FAIR TO SAY THAT AND
I'VE HEARD MR AMERICAN OTHER OF
VENUES MAKE THE FOLLOWING
COMMENT. THAT IT'S NO ACCIDENT
THAT MEDI CAL HAS SOMEWHAT FEWER
RULES THEN THE SNAP PROGRAM THAT
WE KNOW IT'S CAL FRESH. AND THAT
THE WILL POWER TO PROGRAM THE
TANF PROGRAM HAS MANY MORE RULES
THAN THE THAN THE SNAP PROGRAM
MORE THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM IS.
AND A LOT OF THAT IS BECAUSE.
OF SORT OF A BIAS THAT HAS.
WE CREATED OVER TIME TOWARDS
CASH ASSIST.
AND YOU KNOW THAT THAT BIAS IS I
THINK.
A LEGACY THAT WE ALL LIVE WITH
IN CALIFORNIA AND FRANKLY ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY. AND I THINK
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE WOULD
WANT TO MOVE FORWARD AS WE GO
THROUGH THIS PROCESS AND MAKING
THOSE DETERMINATIONS. IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE REALLY IS NO BIAS
THAT WE DON'T LOOK AT CAST.
ANY DIFFERENTLY THAN WE LOOK AT
SNAP BENEFIT FROM EBT CARD OR A
MEDI CAL CARD LIKE THEY ARE ALL
THEY SHOULD ALL BE TREATED THE
SAME. IN THE PUBLIC'S MIND THE
SHALL BE TREATED THE SAME WAY BY
CLIENTS AND SO THAT I THINK ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE LOOKING
FOR IS THE HAVE REALLY SIMILAR
REQUIREMENTS AROUND PROGRAM
INTEGRITY THAT WOULD APPLY
ACROSS THE BOARD.
AND I THINK FOR US THE AYE WE'VE
HEARD A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THIS
IDEA THAT THE DEPARTMENT. MAY
NOW IN THE ABSENCE OF KBA GO
BACK TO REQUIRING APPLICANTS TO
HAVE TO COME TO THE WELFARE
OFFICE CAO WORKS APPLICANTS TO
OFFICE.
TO PROVE THEIR IDENTITY NOW A
FEW YEARS AGO WESTERN CENTER WAS
ONE OF THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL
S. B. NINE FORTY FIVE BY SENATOR
PAN. THAT ACTUALLY CREATES A
PATH FOR.
THEY'RE TO BE.
ONLINE APPLICATION AND FOR TO
ESSENTIALLY TO GET ELIMINATE THE
REQUIREMENT THERE BE FACE TO
FACE INTERVIEWS.
SO THAT PROPOSAL THAT WE'RE
HEARING ABOUT THIS.
POTENTIAL DRAFT ACL.
WOULD SEEM TO.
BE INCONSISTENT WITH S. B. NINE
FORTY SEVEN AND WE WOULD BE
CONCERNED THAT IF THE RESPONSE
STILL LIMITING KBA WAS TO CREATE
ANOTHER STEP FOR RECIPIENTS TO
HAVE TO GO THROUGH.
WE'RE HOPING THAT THEY'LL BE A
MEETING OF THE MINDS BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE STAKEHOLDERS. TO FIND AN
ALTERNATIVE THAT THAT DOESN'T.
ASSIST APPEAR TO REOPEN THAT
NEGOTIATION DISCUSSION AROUND S.
B. NINE FORTY SEVEN IF I COULD
CLARIFY. FOR THE COMMITTEE S. B.
NINE FORTY SEVEN WAVED THE
REQUIREMENT FOR FACE TO FACE
INTERVIEW IT DID NOT ELIMINATE
THE REQUIREMENT TO PRODUCE.
DOCUMENTATION ESTABLISHING
IDENTITY
THIS THE THE DIFFERENCE AND.
WHEN AS WE REFER TO CASH RATHER
THAN THE OTHER BENEFITS
IS NOT BECAUSE WE ARE THINKING
ABOUT.
PEOPLE WHO SEEK THE BENEFIT.
ARE IN ANY WAY. LESS GOOD LESS
WORTHY.
IT IS THAT.
THE SNAP BENEFIT AND THE
MEDICAID BENEFIT.
CANNOT BE CONVERTED TO CASH
EXCEPT ACTUALLY BUT THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION IN ONE INSTANCE OF
RETAILERS ON THE OTHER AND IN
BOTH CASES THAT LEGAL BRIGHT
TRAIL BEHIND.
AND WE IN THE OIG AND D. H. CS
MEDICAID FRAUD GOAL AFTER.
THE CASH PROGRAM IS A TARGET FOR
THE SOPHISTICATED.
CYBER CRIMINALS WEEK WEEK WE
HAVE. CURRENTLY EXPERIENCES
WHERE WE ARE HAVING OUR CLIENTS
BESIEGED ONLINE BY VERY
SOPHISTICATED SCAMS
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO.
IN ANY WAY IMPLY THAT IT IS THE
POOR PERSON SEEKING BENEFITS.
AGAINST WHOM WE ARE PROTECTING
THE CASH PROGRAM CALIFORNIA HAS
A THIRD.
THIRD OF THE WHOLE CASH PROGRAM
IN THE COUNTRIES IN CALIFORNIA
WE SUPPORTED WE BELIEVE WE'VE
DEFENDED.
BUT WE HAVE TO DEFEND ITS
INTEGRITY UP TO THIS POINT I'VE
BEEN ABLE TO SAY WHENEVER ASKED.
HOME PRESS OR PUBLIC DO I
BELIEVE WE HAVE PROGRAM
INTEGRITY I I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
SAY YES I. DO I HAVE NO QUALMS
IT'S ESSENTIAL THAT WE PRESERVE
THE ABILITY TO GO ON SAYING THAT
AND SO WITH RESPECT TO MISTER
HAROLD.
S. B. NOT OF MY FORTY SEVEN DID
NOT. ELIMINATE THE REQUIREMENT
TO PROVIDE DOCUMENTATION AND
THAT WILL BE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S POSITION GOING
FORWARD.
CAROL SURE.
.
A YEAH WE DON'T DISAGREE WITH MR
LIKE PORN AYE AYE THAT'S THE
CASE AND EFFECT I THINK THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS DOES AN
EXCELLENT JOB. APPOINTEE NOW
WITH THE CURRENT REQUIREMENTS
ARE FOR PROVIDING IDENTIFICATION
I MEAN THE REALITY IS THAT RIGHT
NOW. ALL VIRTUALLY EVERY
APPLICANT FOR TOWER STILL DOES
HAVE TO GO TO THE WELFARE OFFICE
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
PRODUCE IDENTIFICATION THEY'RE
GOING AFTER PRES.
UP.
A BIRTH CERTIFICATE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN WE KNOW THAT AND WE
DON'T DISAGREE THAT WE WHAT'S
ROTH PROGRAM INTEGRITY STANDARDS
AND EFFECT WE WOULD ARGUE THAT
THE PROOF WITHIN THE EVIDENCE
THAT THE SEAT THIS PROGRAM
REALLY DIDN'T PRODUCE ANY
DUPLICATE AID FRAUD.
THE NOT THE NUMBERS ARE
EXTREMELY LOW THAT IT ACTUALLY
PRODUCED AND I THINK THAT IS
BECAUSE OF THE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRAM FEATURES THAT ARE BUILT
IN AROUND THE FILE CLEARANCE
THAT ARE OUTLINED IN YOUR
ANALYSIS.
AND SO I THINK.
.
NO NO OFFENSE INTENDED TO THE
DEPARTMENT.
I AS I NOTED I THINK MUCH OF
WHAT WE OUR LIVING WITH HERE IS
A LEGACY ISSUE.
BUT I DO THINK THAT WE WOULD
REALLY WANT WE SUPPORT THE
COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATION THAT
WE ADOPT THE FILE CLEARANCE
PROCESS AS PART OF THE STATUTE
SO THAT IT THE BONNET WE CLEAR.
TO PEOPLE ON THE OUTSIDE AS WELL
NOTES THAT WE HAVE STRONG
PROGRAM INTEGRITY REQUIREMENTS
IN THAT WHERE WE'RE BEING VERY
CAREFUL ABOUT THE WAY THEY WERE
SPENDING THE PUBLIC'S MONEY. AND
THEN LASTLY I THINK WE WOULD
ALSO DOORS.
THE RECOMMENDATION OF SOME
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT LANGUAGE
THAT TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE WAYS
THAT THE MEDS PROGRAM CAN BE
ENHANCED AND MADE BETTER.
AND THEN LASTLY I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT IS.
THAT THERE IS THIS HUB.
PROJECT ONLINE I DO THINK THAT
PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR ADVOCATES
AND THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO COME TOGETHER AND
TO LOOK AT NEW AN IMPROVED WAYS
PRESS THE OPERATOR ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATIONS.
THANK YOU NEXT BILL OF JANET TO
SOLVE.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM I WANT TO ECHO
SOME OF THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE WESTERN
CENTER REGARDING WANTING TO OF
COURSE MAINTAIN AIR INTEGRITY OF
THE PROGRAM IN APPRECIATING THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT.
REGARDING KBA IN OUR CONCERNS I
THINK FOR THOSE SAME REASONS WE
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THIS MOVE
THIS PROPOSAL TO RELEASE AND ALL
COUNTY LETTER. AND WE ARE SEEING
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION THAT IS
SEEKING TO PENALIZE IMMIGRANTS
FOR THEIR USE OF CRITICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS.
AND THAT INFORMATION IS ALREADY
BEEN IN THE PAST IN THE MEDIA
AND IS ALREADY HAVING AN IMPACT
ON INDIVIDUALS WERE ASKING TO
DESCEND ROLE AND SO WE WOULD
JUST ASK THAT WE TAKE. CAREFUL
CONSIDERATION OF ANY NEW
BARRIERS OR ANY NEW HURDLES AND
REALLY THINK ABOUT THE SPEED OF
WHICH WE ARE MOVING IN WITH
THESE PROPOSALS. AND BECAUSE OF
THIS PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE
POPULATION THERE ARE FOLKS AYE
THAT HAVE THEIR US CITIZEN
CHILDREN THAT HAVE GRANTS.
WHOSE PARENTS ARE.
DO NOT HAVE IMMIGRATION STATUS
AND SO WE WOULD BE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT TYPE OF
CHANGE THIS QUICK CHANGE WOULD
HAVE AN EFFECT ON THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT MAY BE SEEKING
ASSISTANCE. AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION FOR PART OF FINE
FOLK PLANTS PROBABLY.
PROCESS IN ADDITION TO THE
OTHER LANGUAGE.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF I COULD BE
VERY CLEAR WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO DO.
CHANGES ABSOLUTELY NOTHING IN
CURRENT PROCEDURE OTHER THAN AND
FINGERPRINT.
NOTHING ELSE CHANGES.
BERMAN FINANCE A LIVE.
DEPARTMENT FINDS HER WHICH WE
CONCUR WITH THE DEPARTMENT
STATEMENT SO FAR.
WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE SEVEN.
KEVIN AS THEIR KALRA SUCCUMB
AFFORDABLE FOR RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS.
THROUGH EXTENT THAT THERE ARE
PROBLEMS WITH THE CAL SHAPE
PROGRAM IS THE SAME PROBLEMS
WITH THE STEP PROGRAM.
WE READ ABOUT HOW. THERE'S ALL
KINDS OF OF HACKING OF STEP
BENEFITS DISTILLING THEM AND ALL
THIS SORT OF PROBLEM SO I THINK
THE SAME PROBLEM EXISTS THERE.
AND WITH STIFF WITH WITH A
LIMITED THE THE STEP IN THE
CALPERS PROGRAM AND TWENTY
ELEVEN. NOTHING CHANGED
PERMITTED FRAUD HAS TALKED ON UP
THE STATE EARNS SO NOTHING HAS
REALLY.
CHANGE AND.
.
IT WAS SUPPORT A PROGRAM THAT
THEY'RE SUGGESTING THANK YOU.
SHE IN CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FOOD BANKS I FIRST WANT TO THANK
THE THE STAFF.
FOR THE IN DEPTH ANALYSIS
SUSPICIONS WERE GOING INTO THE
SCOPING PROCESS IN AND HOW
DISCUSS
I THINK IT'S VERY HELPFUL TO
HAVE THIS.
AND THE RECORD AND AND THE FOOD
BANKS ARE OFTENTIMES THE SITES.
WHERE FOLKS ARE COMING FORWARD
TO ASK TO BE DISMANTLED AND SO I
JUST WANTED TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
MISTER STILL ABOUT THE
SENSITIVITIES COMMENTS WE
APPRECIATE?
THE VERY CLOSE ATTENTION AS WE
BUILT THESE NEW PROCEDURES AND.
SIR.
SIGNAL FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE SEVEN I'LL BRING IT UP TO
THE DYESS AND.
I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
DISCUSSION ON THIS IMPORTANT
TOPIC.
I'M REALLY INTERESTED IN AN
APPROACH THAT DOES THREE THINGS
FIRST IT CODIFIES THE CURRENT
FILE CLEARANCE PROCESS FOR
COMMERCE.
SECOND IT THAT ADOPTS
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
TO EXPLORE HOW MEDS IMPROVEMENT
COULD WORK IN THIRD AVOIDS ANY
PREMATURE CHANGES TO REMOTE
ACCESS FOR CAL WORKS APPLICANTS
BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE THE
DEPARTMENT HAS. WALKED THAT BACK
A LITTLE BIT.
AND IN THAT VEIN I'M GOING TO
REQUEST THAT STAFF WORK TOWARDS
DRAFTING TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD CODIFY THE CURRENT
PROCESS FOR US TO CONSIDER BY
MAY REVISION.
I AGREE WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM THESE
DECISIONS SHOULD BE MADE IN THE
LONG TERM APPLICATION HUB.
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS TO WHICH THE
DEPARTMENT SEEMS VERY COMMITTED
WERE GLAD FOR THE WORK BEING
DONE TOWARDS CREATING EASE OF
APPLICATION TO THE HUB. AND WITH
THAT WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN.
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE A.
I THINK WE DID PAID SIR.
YOU'RE RIGHT AND WERE NOW ON
ISSUE NOT.
TO COME OVER HERE.
CHEMICALLY WAGES THEY BRANCHED
OVER THE CAL THRASH.
SNAP PROGRAM
IN CALIFORNIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU FOR THE INVITATION
THANK YOU FOR THE.
EXCELLENT ALICE'S JUST A COUPLE
THINGS TO HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU ON
FIRST OF ALL TREND OR DOES YOUR
YEAR AGO I WAS SAYING WAS THE
FIRST TIME IN FIFTEEN YEARS THE
CASELOADS WERE FALLING I'M
PLEASED TO REPORT.
THE LAST SIX SEVEN MONTHS WE'VE
BEEN FLAT WE'VE LEVELED UP EVEN
AS THE POOL OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE CONTINUES TO SHRINK WE
APPEARED TO MAKING PROGRESS AT
IN ACCESS AND RETENTION AND
FINING FOLKS UP.
PARTICIPATION RATE IS NOW
SEVENTY TWOPERCENT ON TWENTY
ELEVEN WE WERE FIFTY PERCENT SO
WE ARE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND HOLDING STEADY ON
OTHER. EY INDICATORS I THINK.
COUPLE KEY POPULATIONS WE
ALWAYS LOOK AT CHILDREN.
CHILDREN MAJORITY OF OUR
POPULATION WE CONTINUE TO BE
WATCHING THEIR ENROLLMENT
PARTICULARLY CHILDREN MAKE
STATUS FAMILIES ARE SOME
DIFFERENT THINGS HAPPENING
THERE.
ARE GREAT PROGRESS IN SENIORS
ACROSS THE MAJOR POLICY CHANGE
ON DECK FOR THIS YEAR IS THE A
BY THE TIME LIMIT FOR SOME
WORKING ADULTS. CURRENTLY SLATED
TO BE IMPLEMENTED IN SAN
FRANCISCO SANTA CLARA AND SAN
MATEO COUNTY SEPTEMBER FIRST.
I WOULD BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T
MENTION THE PROGRAMS ON PEBBLE
RESPONSIVENESS TO DISASTER THIS
PAST YEAR BOTH THE NORTHERN AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. A TWO POINT
NINE MILLION IN THE NORTH AND
FIVE POINT SEVEN IN THE SOUTH TO
BOTH PEOPLE WHO ARE WITH THE
PROGRAM AND PEOPLE WHO ARE ONLY
WITH PACIFIC FOR A MONTH. AFTER
A DISASTER.
I JUST TO HIGHLIGHT MANY MANY
NEW THINGS AS WE CONTINUALLY
IMPROVE THE PROGRAM THE STATE
HUB WHICH WILL TALK ABOUT LATER
WERE ALSO TACKLING INITIATIVE TO
REDUCE OVER ISSUANCES IN
OVERPAYMENTS WHICH CONTINUES TO
BE A LONG STANDING CHALLENGE FOR
CLIENTS AND COUNTIES. WE'RE
LOOKING AT OUR LANGUAGE ACCESS
PARTICULARLY AS WE MOVE TO MORE
TECHNOLOGIES TO CONTINUE TO BE
OPEN TO ALL WE'RE EXPANDING OUR
ENT. EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
SERVICES THE ONLINE SANTA
ONLINE.
RESOURCE CENTERS MENTION OF THE
ANALYSIS AND WE'RE ALSO LOOKING
AT CONTINUING TO MAKE HEALTHY
FOOD MORE ACCEPTABLE TO OUR
HEALTHY CALTRANS INITIATIVE SO
ALL THAT ON DECK FOR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. AND A YOU MENTIONED
FOOD OTHER CAL FOOD PROGRAMS
ANALYSIS BUT I KNOW THERE ALSO
SEPARATELY LISTED SO WILL HOLD.
COMMENTS ON THAT.
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE HAVE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HELLO AND
COMMENTS ON THE ISSUE.
I THOUGHT WHAT'S BERMAN
OFFENSIVE THINK WE WOULD JUST
HIGHLIGHT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROVIDE ELEVEN
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS FOUR
POINT TWO MILLION GENERAL FUND
RECOGNIZING THE IMPACT TO ABLE
BODIED ADULTS THAT DEPENDENCE
AND.
THE FACT THAT.
THE.
THE ELIMINATION THIS WAIVER WILL
HAVE ON THEM COME SEPTEMBER.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ON ISSUE
NINE AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NONE I WILL BRING IT BACK
UP TO THE DYESS AND.
WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN.
AS I AM PRESENTING ON TEN ELEVEN
TWELVE AND THIRTEEN I WILL AWAIT
ANOTHER. MEMBER COMMENT LEAVE ME
OF MY CHAIR DUTIES. AND WITH
THAT WE WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE
FOURTEEN.
NEXT.
THE A GOOD FOR ALL INVOLVED. FOR
THE COMPANY.
SO WILL BE JOINED IN A MINUTE
FROM MY COLLEAGUE AT THE CENTER
FOR IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER.
SHE BERRYHILL.
SO TRACI PATTERSON WITH
CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES
OUR ORGANIZATION'S MISSION IS TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE ACCESS TO FOOD AND TO
IMPROVE THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS
BY INCREASING THEIR ACCESS TO
NUTRITIOUS AND AFFORDABLE FOOD.
AND WHEN WE SAY ALL CALIFORNIANS
THAT IS INCLUSIVE OF ALL OF US
WHO AKE CALIFORNIA OUR HOME AND
ARE STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS
MEET.
CAL FRESH AND OTHER FOOD
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS MUST STRIVE
TO BE INCLUSIVE AND RESPONSIVE
TO THE NEED OF IMMIGRANT
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY IN OUR
CURRENT CLIMATE OF FEAR.
INCREASE DISCRIMINATION AND
DEPORTATION OF OUR NEIGHBORS.
INVESTING IN NUTRITION AND BASIC
NEEDS KEEPS CHILDREN LEARNING
PARENTS WORKING AND FAMILY
STRONG AND ALLOWS ALL OF US TO
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR COMMUNITIES.
CAL FIRST ANOTHER FOOD
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM SHOULDN'T
DETER OR DISCOURAGE IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES MOST OF WHICH INCLUDE
U. S. CITIZEN CHILDREN FROM
SEEKING HELP WHEN THEY NEED IT.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT LOW INCOME
CHILDREN WITH FOREIGN BORN
PARENTS ARE LESS LIKELY TO
RECEIVE FOOD ASSISTANCE THAN OUR
OTHER CHILDREN.
IMMIGRANTS HAVE HIGHER RATES OF
EMPLOYMENT THE MANY U. S. BORN
CITIZENS BUT OFTEN WORK IN JOBS
THAT PAY THEM LESS.
AND TAXES PAID BY IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES CAN HELP SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS
FOR ALL PEOPLE WORKING LOW WAGE
JOBS HEALTHY NUTRITION
ASSISTANCE HELP THEM IN THEIR
FAMILY STAY HEALTHY. THRIVE AND
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR SOCIETY.
THEREFORE WE RESPECTFULLY AND
URGENTLY REQUESTED DSS TO
CONVENE A STAKEHOLDER GROUP TO
PROACTIVELY ADDRESS HOW WE CAN
PROTECT THOSE CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE
FOR FOODASSISTANCE SO THAT FEAR
DOESN'T IMPACT THEIR DECISION TO
SEEK HELP FOR THEIR FAMILIES. TO
STRENGTHEN THE STATE SYSTEMS
USED FOR CAL FRESH AND THE
LINKAGES TO OTHER FOOD
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS AND
RESOURCES. AND TO WORK TOWARDS
MODERNIZING CAL FRESH TO BE MORE
INCLUSIVE OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
AND SO WE ASK THAT WE CONVENE
STAKEHOLDERS WERE WORKING AT THE
INTERSECTION OF IMMIGRATION AND
FOOD. SO THAT WE CAN PROACTIVELY
WORK TOWARDS A MORE INCLUSIVE
VISION OF FOOD FOR ALL IN
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU AND NEXT WITH GINA
TESLA YES GOOD AFTERNOON AT CAP
SEE MY ORGANIZATION WAS ACTUALLY
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX
IN RESPONSE TO QUOTE UNQUOTE
WELFARE REFORM AND CRUEL FEDERAL
LAWS. THAT EXCLUDED NUMBER OF
LEGAL IMMIGRANTS FROM PUBLIC
BENEFITS PROGRAMS.
THESE LAWS CAME ON THE HEELS OF
PROP ONE EIGHTY SEVEN AN ANTI
IMMIGRANT INITIATIVE AND TENGAN
INTENDED TO TARGET SCAPEGOAT
IMMIGRANTS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SINCE THEN IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
ADVANCED A NUMBER OF IMMIGRATION
REFORMS INCLUDING REMOVING SOME
OF THOSE EXCLUSIONS FROM OUR OWN
PROGRAMS HOWEVER THERE ARE STILL
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS THAT
ARE LEFT OUT OF OUR HEALTH
SYSTEM. AND SAFETY NET BECAUSE
OF THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS
TODAY OVER FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS FACE FOOD
INSECURITY WORRYING ABOUT WHEN
THEY'LL GET THEIR NEXT MEAL
HUNGER DOESN'T DISCRIMINATE. OUR
COMMUNITIES ALSO STRUGGLED
INCOME INEQUALITY IN ADDITION TO
THE INCREASING ECONOMIC BARRIERS
STEMMING FROM THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS.
COVERAGE IS ONE OF THE MOST INTO
PORTENT TOOLS TO REDUCE POVERTY
AND TO IMPROVE HEALTH WHEN LOW
INCOME CALL FOR MEANS REGARDLESS
OF STATUS OF STATUS HAVE ACCESS
TO NUTRITION ASSISTANCE WE
STRENGTHEN OUR STATE. AND CREATE
A STANDARD FOR FOOD ACCESS THAT
ALLOWS FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES
TO LEAD BETTER AND HEALTHIER
LIVES BECAUSE EXCLUSIONS BASED
ON STATUS HURT OUR STATE.
LOCKING OUT IMMIGRANT FAMILIES
FROM CRITICAL ASSISTANCE NOT
ONLY SETS BACK ENTIRE FAMILIES
BUT IT SETS BACK OUR STATE. WE
HAVE HALF OF OUR CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE AT LEAST ONE
IMMIGRANT PARENTS WE HAVE TO DO
MORE TO ENSURE THAT NO
CALIFORNIA GOES HUNGRY WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE ARE
INVESTING IN THE STABILITY OF
FAMILIES THAT IS INTRINSICALLY
LINKED. TO OUR STATE'S LONG TERM
FUTURE.
WE REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
PROPOSAL TO BRING TOGETHER
STAKEHOLDER GROUP THAT WILL WORK
THOUGHTFULLY TOWARDS THE GOAL IS
TO STRENGTHEN PROTECT AND
ADVANCE POLICIES THAT REFLECT
THE NEEDS AND OPPORTUNITIES IN
OUR STATE. NOT THE DESIGN A
RHETORIC OF AN INCREASINGLY
AVERAGE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
IT'S THE DEPARTMENT HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON THIS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU I I THINK THE ONLY
BECAUSE IT WOULD MAKE A STUDENT
BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDER GROUP.
OBVIOUSLY I THINK WE'RE ALL
VERY SENSITIVE TO.
THE.
POTENTIAL.
REGULATORY CHANGES A FEDERAL THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND
FINDING WAYS TO.
MOVE AND.
MAY ENSURE CONTINUED ACCESS OR
INCREASE ACCESS WITHOUT CREATING
JEOPARDY.
AND BECAUSE.
THE GOAL.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HELLO.
A TIGER WOODS' PARTNER FINANCE
WE'D ECHO THE SENTIMENTS OF
DIRECTOR WHITE BORN THAT WE
WOULD BE OPEN THE CONVERSATIONS
TO THE EXTENT THIS PROPOSAL
BECOMES PROPERTY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE FOURTEEN.
MICHELLE STILL PREVENTS HE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE FOOD FOR ALL PROPOSAL THINK.
THE COMMITTEE.
SHANTI PRASAD ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF FOOD FOR ALL.
ANDERSON HEALTH ASSOCIATION IF
IT MAKES IN SUPPORT.
SIR.
THIS IS NOT INNOCENT OF ALL
IMMIGRANT AGGRESSION
COLLABORATIVE STRONG SUPPORT.
CARLY PINKEL AT THE FOOD BANK OF
CONTRA COSTA AND SOLANO IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
A HUMAN.
NO IT BOTTOM WITH CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT. SERVING
FARMWORKERS.
CALPERS PROGRAMS WHEN THE
PROGRAM IT'S UNDER UTILIZED BY
FARMWORKERS AND MANY ARE MIXED
AT ITS FAMILIES WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THE BARRIERS OF
EXCLUSION SO THIS IS A GOOD
PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
FRANK NICHOLAS YOU TO BE
DETAINED SUPPORT.
I JUST GOV ARE SLOW AT THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL AND BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
GET A CHANCE TO COMMENT AFTER
THE SUMMARY OF THE. CALL FRESH
UPDATE JUST A DISJOINTED TAKE A
MOMENT TO CONGRATULATE THE
COVERAGE PROGRAM FOR THE. YOU
KNOW THE RESPONSE OF THE
DISASTERS IN CALIFORNIA AND.
THEIR AGILE RESPONSE TO THE
NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
I CAN.
WE KNOW THIS ONE LOCAL ENEMY
GRANTED MEAN SO CAMPESINO. YEP
WILLIAMSON GLASSES.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON BRING IT BACK UP TO THE
DYESS.
CREW GONNA ASK THE ADVOCATES OF
I CAN'T A DRAFT TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD ACHIEVE THE
GOALS IN YOUR PROPOSAL FOR ALL
PARTIES TO CONSIDER.
WITH WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD
THIS ISSUE OPEN AND MOVE ON TO.
ISSUE TEN
.
I'M GOING TO GO.
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN IF IT
PLEASES YOU I'D LIKE TO THE
PRESENT TEN ELEVEN TWELVE AND
THIRTEEN TOGETHER.
I ABSOLUTELY WELL IDENTIFY THEM
AS WE GO THROUGH.
DESPITE THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY
ONE IN A CALIFORNIA.
UNFORTUNATELY FACES HUNGER.
A CRISIS THAT DEMANDS THE STATE
DEVELOP A PROPORTIONATE
RESPONSE.
WHEN INCLUDING THE STATE'S HIGH
COST OF LIVING WE HAVE THE
NATION'S HIGHEST POVERTY RATE.
TWENTY POINT SIX PER.
CALIFORNIA'S WORLD LEADING
AGRICULTURAL REGIONS ARE
IRONICALLY SOME OF OUR NATION'S
HUNGRY OF CITIES.
WITH BAKERSFIELD BEING NUMBER
ONE IN MY OWN HOMETOWN OF FRESNO
BEING NUMBER FIVE.
CALIFORNIA SH IS OUR STATE'S
MOST IMPORTANT DEFENSE AGAINST
HUNGER.
WHILE MANY RELY ON THIS BENEFIT
AMOUNTS TO LESS THAN TWO DOLLARS
PER MEAL. THAN WHAT WE NEED AND
THAT IS LESS THAN WHAT WE NEED
TO PURCHASE A HEALTHY DIET.
WITH SUCH A LOW BENEFIT NEARLY
ONE THIRD OF HOUSEHOLDS THAT
RECEIVE SNAP STILL MUST RELY ON
FOOD BANKS TO MEET THEIR MOST
BASIC NEEDS FOR FOOD.
THE AMERICAN RECOVERY AND
REINVESTMENT ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
NINE INCREASED MONTHLY CAL FRESH
BENEFITS BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
NINE AND TWENTY THIRTEEN.
BOOSTING THEIR PURCHASING POWER
SO THAT THEY MAY HAVE BURKE
HUNGER AND ALSO HELPS TO
STIMULATE OUR ECONOMY.
WELL THIS INCREASE IN BENEFIT
ONLY LASTED A FEW YEARS IT WAS
DOCUMENTED TO HAVE REDUCED
HUNGER.
AND INCREASE THE PURCHASES OF
HEALTHY FOOD.
SINCE THE ARE A BOOST TO SNAP
BENEFITS WAS TERMINATED THE
AVERAGE FAMILY OF THREE HAS HAD
THEIR BENEFITS REDUCED BY TWENTY
EIGHT DOLLARS A MONTH.
AN INCREASE OF CAL FRESH MONTHLY
BENEFITS WILL HELP REDUCE HUNGER
FOR MANY CALIFORNIANS WHILE ALSO
ALLOWING FOR THE PURCHASING OF
HEALTHIER FOOD. WHILE ALSO
INCREASING THE LOCAL ECONOMY.
FOOD INSECURITY CAN BE A MAJOR
RISK FACTOR TO HEALTH PROBLEMS
INCLUDING DIABETES.
TWO AND A HALF MILLION
CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN DIAGNOSED
WITH DIABETES
ACCESS TO HEALTHY FOOD HAS BEEN
FOUND TO HELP TO CONTROLLED.
THIS DISEASE AND TO HELP IT
INDIVIDUALS AND HERE TO STRICT
MEDICATION REQUIREMENTS.
OVER THE PAST DECADE INITIATIVES
THAT PROVIDED SUPPLEMENTAL
BENEFITS TO CAL FRESH RECIPIENTS
HAVE SHOWN THAT WHEN LOW INCOME
FAMILIES HAVE MORE MONEY FOR
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES. THEY BUY
AND EAT MORE FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES.
TELL FRESH HELPS OVER FOUR
MILLION PEOPLE PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE.
HOWEVER WITH THE BENEFIT AMOUNT
IS SO LITTLE THAT LIMITS THE
ABILITY TO PURCHASE MORE
EXPENSIVE FRESH FOOD.
SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITION INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS PROVIDE MATCHING
DOLLARS TIED TO THE PURCHASE OF
CALIFORNIA GROWN FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES.
THESE PROGRAMS ARE OPERATED
LOCALLY THROUGH OUT THE STATE.
TO MAXIMIZE THESE INCENTIVES WE
MUST INTEGRATE CALIFORNIA'S%
FRUIT AND VEGETABLE BENEFITS
INTO THE CAL FRESH ELECTRONIC
BENEFIT TRANSFER PROGRAM. WHICH
IS WIDELY ACCEPTED BY FOOD
RETAILERS STATEWIDE.
AS WE WORK TO INCREASE THESE
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
WE STILL HAVE HUNGRY
CALIFORNIANS.
NEARLY ONE THIRD OF HOUSEHOLDS
RELY ON FOOD BANKS
FOOD BANKS ARE A KEY TO MAKING
SURE THAT OUR NEIGHBORS AND
FRIENDS HAVE ACCESS. TO FOOD ONE
SUPPLIES RUN LOW. WE NEED TO
INVEST IN PROGRAMS THAT HELP
PREVENT HUNGER AND FOOD
INSECURITY WHILE ALSO DEDICATING
FUNDS TO INCENTIVIZE AND PROMOTE
QUALITY HEALTH FOOD. PURCHASES
I SUPPORT FOR SPECIFIC PROPOSALS
THAT WILL HELP ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S HUNGER CRISIS
I'M ASKING FOR INVESTMENTS IN
THE FOLLOWING.
FIRST
TWENTY EIGHT DOLLARS PER MONTH
ADDITIONAL CAL FRESH BENEFIT FOR
EACH CAL FRESH HOUSEHOLD.
THIS IS ITEM TEN. INCREASING THE
MONTHLY BENEFIT IN THE PROGRAM
WILL HELP PREVENT HUNGER SUPPORT
HEALTHY FOOD PURCHASES STIMULATE
THE ECONOMY AND CREATE JOBS
WHILE ALSO REDUCING THE PRESSURE
ON LOCAL FOOD BANK. HEALTHCARE
COSTS.
SECOND
ISSUE ITEM ELEVEN NINE MILLION
IN GENERAL FUND TO INCENTIVIZE
THE PURCHASE OF CALIFORNIA GROWN
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES.
THIS WOULD ENABLE THE CAL FRESH
EBT SYSTEM TO INTEGRATE
SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITION BENEFITS
THAT INCENTIVIZE CALIFORNIA
GROWN FRUIT AND VEGETABLE
PROTECTS.
ADDITIONALLY IT WILL ALLOW FOR
SEVEN COMMUNITY BASED PILOTS
TO TEST THE EFFICACY OF AN
ELECTRONIC BENEFITS TRANSFER
MECHANISM.
TO DISBURSE AND TRACK
SUPPLEMENTAL CAL FRESH BENEFITS
EARNED AND REDEEMED BY CLIENTS
COVER ADMINISTRATION COSTS OF
NONPROFIT OPERATORS AND DESIGN
AND CONDUCT A THOROUGH PILOT
PROJECT EVALUATION.
THIRD ITEM TWELVE
TWENTY POINT SIX MILLION IN
GENERAL FOOD FOR CAL FOOD.
THIS WILL HELP CALIFORNIA FOOD
BANKS PURCHASE MORE FRESH FOOD.
CALHOUN IS INCREDIBLY EFFICIENT
AND EFFECTIVE IN FIGHTING HUNGER
BOOSTING NUTRITION AND
SUPPORTING OUR FARMERS.
FUNDS APPROPRIATED TO CAL FOOD
ARE REQUIRED TO BE SPENT ON
PURCHASING AND DISTRIBUTING FOOD
GROWN OR PRODUCED IN CALIFORNIA.
BENEFITING LOW INCOME FAMILIES
WITH MORE ACCESS TO FOOD AS WELL
AS CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
SECTOR SECTOR.
FOR EVERY ONE DOLLAR AND CAL
FOOD SPENT FIVE MEALS A
CALIFORNIA GROWN FOODS ARE
FUNDED.
FUNDING CAL FOOD AT TWENTY POINT
SIX MILLION WILL ENABLE FOOD
BANKS TO DELIVER MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED MILLION MEALS. A
SIGNIFICANT STEP TOWARDS ENDING
HUNGER IN CALIFORNIA.
FINALLY ITEM THIRTEEN TWENTY
FIVE MILLION IN GENERAL FOOD FOR
FOOD BANK INFRASTRUCTURE
CAPACITY.
BESIDES SUFFICIENT FOOD THE MAIN
BARRIER FOOD BANKS FACE IS
INFRASTRUCTURE BOTTLENECKS THAT
LIMIT THE CAPACITY TO SERVE
THEIR COMMUNITY.
TWENTY FIVE MILLION INVESTMENT
WILL PROVIDE LONG TERM BENEFITS
BY ALLOWING FOOD BANKS TO
PURCHASE CLEAN BURNING
REFRIGERATED TRUCKS.
EXPAND COLD STORAGE OR MAKE
OTHER PHYSICAL IMPROVEMENTS
CRITICAL TO THEIR OPERATION.
THIS INVESTMENT WILL ENABLE FOOD
BANKS TO DISTRIBUTE MORE
CALIFORNIA GROWN FRUITS
PARTICULARLY THE HEALTHY PRODUCE
AND PROTEIN ITEMS THAT KEEP.
THAT MUST BE KEPT FOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF WITH
THAT.
PLEASE.
WITNESSES AND.
FAVOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITYTO SPEAK TODAY I'M
CHUNKY PRASAD SENIOR POLICY
ADVOCATE AT ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK IN OAKLAND.
AND POLICY CO CHAIR OF
CALIFORNIA HUNGER ACTION
COALITION WHICH IS A DEVICE
DIVERSE GROUP OF ORGANIZATIONS
WHOSE MISSION IS TO LIFT UP THE
EXPERIENCES. OF THE OVER FOUR
MILLION CALIFORNIANS WHO
EXPERIENCE HUNGER. I'M PROUD TO
REPRESENT THESE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT BELIEVE FOOD IS A BASIC
HUMAN RIGHT.
I'M A FRESNO NATIVE MY
GRANDPARENTS THE AMERICAN
TERRACE IN AN AUDIO TO KNOCK
WERE FARMWORKERS THERE AND IN
ORANGE COUNTY. FROM THE NINETEEN
THIRTIES THROUGH THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES THEY RAISED FOUR
CHILDREN TWO OF THEM VIETNAM
VETERANS. I WAS ON THE FOOD
STAMP PROGRAM AS A CHILD WHEN
THERE WERE ACTUAL FOOD STAMPS.
NOW KNOWN AS SNAPPER CAO FRESH
IN CALIFORNIA THIS PROGRAM IS.
AS DOCTOR ARAMBULA SAID OUR
FIRST AND MOST EFFECTIVE DEFENSE
AGAINST HUNGER.
YET BECAUSE CONFERENCE PROVIDES
ONLY TWO DOLLARS PER MEAL IT'S
NOT ENOUGH AND I WANT TO.
.
ADD TO WHAT DOCTOR ARAMBULA
SAID THAT NOT ONLY DO ONE THIRD
OF HOUSEHOLDS RECEIVING SNAPPED.
UP MUST RELY ON FOOD BANKS
BUT THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE WHO WE
ASK YOU BANKS CANNOT REACH MORE.
PEOPLE CANNOT REACH FOOD BANKS
AND THOSE PEOPLE JUST GO HUNGRY
TOWARDS THE END OF THE MONTH.
CALIFORNIANS FORTY ONE FOOD
BANKS HAVE INCREASED
DISTRIBUTION TO TWO MILLION
POUNDS OF FOOD A YEAR YET WE'RE
UNABLE TO MEET THE NEED NOT EVEN
CLOSE.
AND WITH THREATS OF SNAP CUTS
FROM CONGRESS LOOMING CALIFORNIA
MUST ACT NOW TO ALLEVIATE
HUNGER.
WE SUPPORT DOCTOR ARAMBULA IS
PROPOSAL FOR CALIFORNIA TO
INCREASE THE CAL FRESHMAN IF IT
BY TWENTY EIGHT DOLLARS PER
MONTH. THE AMOUNT THAT IT WOULD
BE IF CONGRESS HUTTON AND AT THE
BENEFIT BOOST FROM THE AMERICAN
RECOVERY AND REINVESTMENT ACT.
INCREASING THIS BENEFIT WOULD BE
A WIN FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS IT
WOULD BE INVESTMENT IN THE
HEALTH AND NUTRITION OF PEOPLE
WHO SUFFER FROM HUNGER. RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT AN INCREASE OF THIS
AMOUNT INCREASES PARTICIPANTS
VEGETABLE AND HEALTHY PROTEIN
CONSUMPTION.
IT WOULD ALSO BE IN A ECONOMIC
INVESTMENT AS FUNDS WOULD BE
SPENT IMMEDIATELY AND LOCALLY.
EVERY ONE DOLLAR OF CAL FRESH
FUNDS SPENT GENERATES A DOLLAR
SEVENTY NINE IN THE LOCAL
ECONOMY.
HOW FAST CAN ALSO PROVIDE THINGS
THAT FOOD BANKS CAN'T LIKE
PROTEINS WHICH ARE DIFFICULT TO
SOURCE BECAUSE OF THEIR
INCREASINGLY HIGH COST?
AND CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE FOOD.
ULTIMATELY BEING ABLE TO CHOOSE
AND PURCHASE YOUR OWN FOOD
RESPECTS PEOPLE'S DIGNITY.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA IS PROPOSAL IS A
SENSIBLE AND REASONABLE
INVESTMENT.
I ASK THAT CALIFORNIA FEDERAL
SNAP PROGRAM TO
LEVERAGE STATE FUNDS TO BOTH
BENEFIT CALIFORNIANS SUFFERING
FROM HUNGER AND TO BOOST THE
ECONOMY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
I WISH TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SHARE MY
CONCERNS REGARDING MY CAL FACE
BENEFITS.
MY NAME IS ELLEN JOHNS I'M
SEVENTY FIVE YEARS OLD AND I
LIVE IN. SAN PABLO CALIFORNIA.
I CAME TO HE CAME TO CALIFORNIA
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE FROM THE
EAST COAST. AND AT THAT TIME I
WAS AT.
I HAD BENEFITS IN FOOD STAMPS
AND MEDICAID AND MEDICARE.
PRESENTLY I GET.
FIFTEEN DOLLARS A MONTH WHEN I
FIRST CAME. IT WAS AROUND A
HUNDRED.
AND I KNOW FOR A FACT THAT A
FRIEND OF MINE IN BERKELEY WHO
MADE.
WHO HAD A TOTAL INCOME A MORE
THAN I HAD? THOUGHT MORE FOOD
STAMPS I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT
WAS ABOUT BUT OF COURSE WE CAN
MAKE ANY. QUALMS ABOUT IT
BECAUSE I DIDN'T WANT MY FRIENDS
BENEFITS QUESTION.
I IN NOVEMBER OF LAST YEAR A
LETTER WAS SENT TO ME.
AND THEY WE DO STE THE SIXTEEN
DOLLAR CALIPHATE SH
BENEFIT TO FIFTEEN DOLLARS.
I HAVE YET TO UNDERSTAND.
WHAT THAT WAS ABOUT?
AND. IN THE BEGINNING WHEN I
FIRST GOT HERE THEY CONSIDERED
TO INCREASING YOUR.
YOUR RENT.
I'M DIFFERENT EXPENSES YOU HAD.
AND CALCULATED THAT INTO YOUR
FOOD STAMP BENEFITS BUT THAT'S
BEEN TAKEN AWAY.
HOWEVER I DO KNOW THAT AT SOME
POINT IF IT WE GETS REDUCED
AGAMBEN APPEALING. AND DUMP SEE
YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT BUT
I'M LEARNING MORE AND MORE
WORKING WITH YOU GUYS. AND I
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS THE TO
DOING.
NOW FIFTEEN DOLLARS GOING IN THE
SAFE WE WILL BUY YOU WHAT. YOU
GUYS SHOP.
WHAT DO YOU GET FOR FIFTEEN
DOLLARS
EVEN MY?
?
BRED.
IS WHAT THREE DOLLARS A LOAF.
AND AFTER BIG YOU WANT A STATE
CAN FOR SOME FISH.
AND SO THEREFORE.
BECAUSE I'M A MOTHER OF THREE
AND A PRUDENT CHOPPER IN CHAT
WITH COUPONS.
I I MAKE DO.
SO TO SUPPLEMENT THAT.
I HAD.
QUESTION IN ANY S. ABOUT
DIFFERENT FOOD BANK.
BENEFITS FOR THE NEIGHBORHOOD
DIFFERENT CHURCHES IN CONTRA
COSTA.
THAT SUPPLEMENT MY INCOME IN
FORTUNATELY.
FOOD BANK AND IN THESE
ORGANIZATIONS A SALVATION ARMY.
AND THE CATHOLIC CHURCH.
HAS BEEN ABLE TO KEEP ME ON
TARGET WITH.
GOOD FOOD HEALTHY FOR.
LAST YEAR IBM INTO A MEDICAL
PROBLEM WHERE I HAD TO HAVE
SURGERY AND HAD WHAT THEY CALLED
THE MY I TO ME.
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THAT WAS ABOUT
A SAID I JUST IF.
PROBLEM AND.
I HAD TO HAVE SURGERY THEREFORE.
I WAS REFERRED TO A NUTRITIONIST
BY MY PRIMARY CARE DOCTOR. AND I
REALLY HAVE TO WATCH.
WHAT KINDS OF FOOD I EAT NOW
EVEN THOUGH I CONSIDERED MYSELF
ALWAYS TO HAVE EATEN A
NUTRITIONALLY? AND ARE
HEALTHFULLY.
I'M ALSO A DIABETIC.
AND RIGHT THERE YOU KNOW YOU I
KNOW THAT.
I DIDN'T OUT OF THAT DIABETIC
SINCE I WAS LIKE IN MY LATE
FORTIES.
AND I WILL ALWAYS WATCH MY
HEALTH BUT FRESH FOODS.
AND.
THE PROPER PROPER NUTRITION IS
IS GOOD.
SO IF YOU WILL.
DO YOU NEED LIKE NUTRITIONAL
DRINKS ENSURE IN THINGS LIKE
THAT WHICH TAKE AWAY FROM THE
MONEY SITUATION SO IF YOU SPEND
THEIR MONEY FOR.
.
THAT KIND OF SUPPLEMENT TO KEEP
YOURSELF HEALTHY ESPECIALLY WITH
THE.
PROBLEM.
A DIABETES
AND THE SURGERY I HAD.
I'M I'M NOT MAKING IT.
AND IT'S ONLY BY THE GRACE OF
NOT THAT.
I'M ABLE TO.
SORT A BALLOTS IN THE IN THE
FOOD STAMP.
.
FOOD BANK UP ORGANIZATION WHICH
HAS BEEN WONDERFUL.
SO AN INCREASE IN IN CAO FRESH
WOULD REALLY BE.
.
MORE THAN A HELP TO NOT ONLY ME
BUT TO.
ON PEOPLE WITH CHILDREN AND.
.
MIGHT MY SENIOR SAID ORDERED AMY
THEY REALLY CAN'T COMPREHEND AND
DO WHAT I DO AT THIS STAGE I
FIGURE IN TEN YEARS IF I'M.
TEN YEARS OLDER AM I GONNA BE
ABLE TO SIT HERE AND EVEN TALK
TO YOU OR BE ABLE TO SPEAK FOR
MYSELF.
OR TO BE ABLE TO GO TO THE
STORE.
HOW ABOUT I GET THERE?
TRANSPORTATION IS YOU KNOW IS A
PROBLEM ALL OVER THIS AREA IN SO
MANY.
SENIORS I SEE AT THE SENIOR
CENTER THAT I VOLUNTEER AT A
COUPLE OF WEEKS.
BRING CONTAINERS AND PACK UP
FOOD.
AND.
THAT'S PROBABLY THE ONLY MALE
THEY HAD THAT DAY.
I STILL COOK FORTUNATELY UNITE
COOK YOU KNOW BY. CULTURAL
THINGS THAT I WANT TO EAT BUT
YOU HAVE TO BLAME AND THE COST
OF LIVING HERE FROM WHEN I CAME
HERE. IS IS IS
JUST I'M JUST SO.
.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE THAT DID THE
COST OF LIVING IN THE COST OF
FOOD HERE WHEN THIS IS A CLIMATE
UNLIKE THE EAST COAST WE DON'T
HAVE A SNOWSTORM. IN ALT Y. IS
FOOD AND PRODUCE HERE HIGHER
THAN WHAT I KNOW IS ON THE EAST
COAST.
I I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT
WHEN THE THE SO MAYBE YOU GUYS
CAN HELP ME WITH THAT ALONG THE
WAY. BUT I KNOW I'M GOING TO DO
EVERYTHING I CAN TO MAKE IT
BETTER.
FOR.
.
YOU KNOW THE SENIORS COMING
ALONG BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT I ALWAYS NAY KNOW
THAT ARE NEAR EIGHTIES AND
NINETIES. DID DID OUT AND NOT
AWARE EVEN OF THE FACT THAT THEY
CAN GO TO THE. TO THE DIFFERENT
CHURCHES INTO THE FOOD BANKING
GET. AND GET US YOU KNOW
SUPPLEMENTAL STUFF.
SO WHEN INCREASING CAO FACE
WOULD BE A GOOD THING TO DO.
AND.
.
WHAT REALLY SURPRISED ME
RECENTLY I HAD ATTENDED A
MEETING WITH?
?
KILEY FINKLE WHO IS ADVOCACY
WORK WITH FOOD BANK AND I FOUND
THAT THE PEOPLE ON SSI ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR.
FOOD STAMP BENEFITS ONLY IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND IN THIS STATE PROTESTS TO
BE.
FOR THE PEOPLE DO GOOD FOR
EVERYBODY AND I CANNOT BELIEVE
AND I'M TELLIN EVERYBODY I KNOW.
THAT WE NEED TO GET ON BOARD
WITH THAT BECAUSE I AM REALLY
UPSET ABOUT THAT POPULATION IT
SHOULD BE DONE A CASE BY CASE
EVALUATION OF COURSE. YOU KNOW
LIKE HOW POUND POUND DEER THIS
STATE DENY PEOPLE ON SSI
BENEFITS.
YOU KNOW NEVER LEFT AND WE NEED
TO INCREASE BUT IF I GET ANOTHER
LETTER LIKE I DID IN NOVEMBER WE
DO SEMI FROM SIXTEEN DOLLARS TO
FIFTEEN DOLLARS.
THE. I WILL HAVE WILL YOU COME
WITH ME TO APPEAL.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIR OF THE VERY VERY
BRIEF I CAN'T SAY BETTER THAN
THAT THAT PARTICULAR ON THE ON
THE CAL FOOD INFRASTRUCTURE
PIECES. JUST TO.
BUT THAT CALVET NUMBER IN
PERSPECTIVE THAT TWENTY POINT
SIX MILLION IS EQUIVALENT TO
WHAT THE STATE DID JUST TWO
YEARS AGO WHEN WE HAD THE DRUG
PROGRAM. CERTAINLY THE DROUGHT
IS COMING BACK.
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THE
LIMITATIONS GIVEN THE CLIMATE OF
FEAR ETCETERA SO WE FEEL LIKE
THIS IS THE MINIMUM THE STATE
CAN DO AND HOW TO FIVE MORE
ASSISTANCE. ON INFRASTRUCTURE
PIECE.
JUST TO PUT A PERSPECTIVE THAT
THE TOTAL NEED FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE IS ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOOD BANKS
ARE ROUTINELY. AND CAPITAL
CAMPAIGNS I'M DOCTOR I'M BILLS
FOOD BANK FOR EXAMPLE IS KIND OF
A SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS ALONE
RIGHT NOW AND JUST PUT THAT
TWENTY FIVE IN CONTEXT REALLY
JUST ASKING FOR THE STATE'S
SHARE THANK YOU. MAKING ETHNIC
WITNESS.
THANK YOU MELISSA ROMERO IF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE CAL FOOD
FUNDING. AND THE FOOD BANK
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING THANK
YOU.
NEXT WITNESS.
CARLY FINKEL AT THE FOOD BANK
APPROACH ACOSTA AND SOLANO I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE CAO
FRESH INCREASE BUT ALSO SPEAKING
TO CAL FOODS. AND INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANTS ARM OUR FOOD BANK FOOD
BANKS ACROSS THE STATE HAVE
REALLY BEEN TRYING TO INCREASE
THE AMOUNT OF PRODUCE WE
DISTRIBUTE. SIXTY PERCENT OF ALL
THE WE DISTRIBUTE IS NOW
PRODUCE.
AND WE'VE BEEN USING THE CAL
FOODS MONEY TO PURCHASE ABBOTT
DISTRIBUTE FRESH PRODUCE BUT A
WITH DON'T HAVE THE REFRIGERATED
STORAGE CAPACITY. TO TAKE AND
STORE AND DISTRIBUTE THAT
MISSILE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANTS WE REALLY HELPFUL IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY
ABLE TO DISTRIBUTE THAT
NUTRITIOUS FOODS THAT. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS BUT.
NO I BOTTOM ALL CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION WE
CAN'T SAY IT ANY BETTER THAN.
MRS JONES I MEAN A FANTASTIC
WORDS YOU COVER ALL THE TOPICS.
THAT AFFECT OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES ARE POOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES
A IN SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL'S
SPECIFICALLY TO THE MISSING THE
THE DROUGHT ASSISTANCEPROGRAM
SO WE NEED TO BRAILLE THAT MONEY
BACK IN HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY.
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW WHEN THE
NEXT EMERGING MAY COME SO WE
NEED TO HAVE THAT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
WE RECENTLY HELEN EVENT IN
STANISLAUS COUNTY WHERE WE HAD A
MOBILE FOOD TRUCK.
COME.
AND WE GAVE AWAY ALL THE FOOD TO
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY FAMILIES NO
QUESTIONS ASKED THAT'S A TYPE OF
FLEXIBILITY WE NEED BECAUSE WE
KNOW THE NEED IS THERE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
TRACY PATTERSON WITH CALIFORNIA
FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE CAL FRESH BENEFIT
INCREASE SHALL I ALSO TALK ABOUT
THE FOR INVESTABLE EVEN TEAM I
WENT THERE ISSUE TO HIM RIGHT
NOW. OKAY THAT THIS WITNESS WHO
WANT TO GO HELP.
THAT'S INCLUDED IN OKAY THOSE
ISSUE LOOK AHEAD OKAY.
SO.
THANK YOU I WOULD WANT LIKE TO
TALK ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA FRUIT
VEGETABLE EBT PILOT AGAIN WITH
CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES
SO AS EVERYONE HAS MADE CLEAR
THE EXTENT OF HUNGER IN
CALIFORNIA IS SIMPLY
UNACCEPTABLE. AND THE FEDERAL
COFFERS BENEFIT WHAT WHO BENEFIT
IS INADEQUATE TO LAST THE MONTH.
I AM IN ONE PARTICULARLY CRUEL
IRONY HERE IS THE ON
AFFORDABILITY OF FRESH FRUITS
AND VEGETABLES IN CALIFORNIA.
FOR LOWER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WE
PRODUCE MORE FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES THAN ANY STATE IN THE
NATION YET CLOSE TO FORTY
PERCENT OF LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
CAN'T EVEN AFFORD ENOUGH TO EAT
PERIOD.
I'M IN TWO THOUSAND SIX WE HAD
WORKED WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
US AUTHORIZE CALIFORNIA LAW TO
ESTABLISH THE HEALTHY FOOD
PURCHASE PILOTS. THAT WOULD
CREATE A SCALABLE FRESH FRUIT
AND VEGETABLE PURCHASE PROGRAM
INTEGRATED ON EBT.
WELL THAT WAS AUTHORIZING
CALIFORNIA LAW IT WAS CONTINGENT
UPON THE RECEIPT OF A FEDERAL
GRANTS
AND WHEN THAT GRANT BECAME MADE
AVAILABLE UNFORTUNATELY
MASSACHUSETTS WITH THE LUCKY
RECIPIENT OF A GRAND STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
BUT WHILE AT THAT TIME OUR
LOSSES MASSACHUSETTS GAIN AT
THIS POINT WE NOW HAVE SEVEN
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE THAT WE CAN
LOOK TO IN THE STATE OF
MASSACHUSETTS WHERE THEY STARTED
WITH THE PILOT AND NOW HAVE A
STATEWIDE EBT INTEGRATED.
HEALTHY INCENTIVE PURCHASE
PROGRAM AND SO RATHER THAN
HAVING TO DESIGN EBT PROGRAMMING
FROM SCRATCH WE CAN MODEL UPON
THEIR EXPERIENCE AND PROVIDE A
DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR MATCH FOR THE
PURCHASE OF CALIFORNIA FRUITS
AND VEGETABLES THAT WILL ALLOW
CALTRAIN SHOPPERS TO STRETCH THE
BUDGET THROUGHOUT THE MONTH.
AND IN THE ABSENCE OF THAT SORT
OF STATEWIDE EBT INTEGRATED
PROGRAMS LOTS OF LOCAL WELL LEFT
PROGRAMS HAVE SPRUNG UP IN
FARMERS MARKETS AND SOMEONE
GROCERY STORES BUT THEY ALL USE
THEIR OWN DIFFERENT COUPONS AND
VOUCHERS AND NAMES. AND
DEFINITIONS.
AND SO THOSE LOCAL PROGRAMS HAVE
IN SOME WAY ALMOST TAKING US
BACK TO THE USE OF FOOD STAMPS
I'M MORE USING VOUCHERS AND WE
ARE BURKE PUTTING THOSE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS AND BURDENS
ON THE LOCALS TO ACTUALLY
PROCESS INTO ACCOUNTING WHEN
THEY COULD BE DOING OUTREACH IN
PROMOTION AND ALL. THE THINGS
THAT LOCUSTS DO BEST.
AS DOCTOR ARAMBULA NOTED THE
BAKERSFIELD AND FRESNO AREA ARE
AMONG THE TOP FROM OF HUNGER IN
THE NATION AND AND AT THE SAME
TIME IN THE AGAIN THE IRONY KERN
COUNTY IS NOW THE TOP PRODUCING
AGRICULTURAL COUNTY IN THE
NATION WITH FRESNO INTO ARE
CLOSE BEHIND.
SO WE HAVE AGRICULTURE ABUNDANT
SIDE BY SIDE WITH EXTREME HUNGER
AND POVERTY I'M AND WE'RE NOT
CONNECTING THE TWO. AND
ESPECIALLY LOOKING AT THAT
BECAUSE OF THOSE LOCAL PROGRAMS
ARE RELIANT ON VOUCHERS AND
LOCAL PHILANTHROPY KERN COUNTY
DOESN'T HAVE A SINGLE COW FRESH
FRUIT AND VEGETABLE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM OPERATING. I'M BY
INTEGRATING ON EBT WE CAN HAVE A
MORE EQUITABLE APPROACH TO REACH
THE REST OF THE STATE. AND LINK
OUR AGRICULTURAL STRENGTHS WITH
OUR RESIDENTS NEEDS.
YOU KNOW THAT BEFORE.
GOOD AFTERNOON NOON CHERNYKH
MANY MEMBERS MY NAMES ELISA
GUESTS AND THE FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE POLICY DIRECTOR AT
SPUR A NONPROFIT BASED IN THE
BAY AREA.
SPURS IN STRONG SUPPORT I'M
COMMENTING ON ITEM ELEVEN THE
EBT INTEGRATION OF INCENTIVES
WEREN'T STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BUDGET REPRESSED BECAUSE WE KNOW
IT'LL MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
AND WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE WE RUN
A PROGRAM CALLED DOUBLE UP THE
BOX
DOUBLE UP FOOD BOXES OPERATING
RIGHT NOW FOR THE PAST YEAR AT
THREE GROCERY STORES ABOUT TO BE
FIVE IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY. AND
WHAT IT DOES IS WHEN ACT
CUSTOMERS ON CAL FRESH COMES TO
THE STORE AND BUYS CALIFORNIA
GROWN FRUITS AND VEGETABLES WITH
THE EBT CARD THEY GET A DOLLAR
FOR DOLLAR MATCH THAT THEY CAN
THEN SPEND ON ANY FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES NEXT TIME THEY COME
TO THE STORE.
IN ONE YEAR WE'VE SERVED TWO
THOUSAND FAMILIES PARTICIPATING
IN CALPERS WHICH EQUALS ABOUT
SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE BASED
ON THE SURVEYS WE'VE GOT. THEY
HAVE REDEEMED EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND DOUBLE UP
FOOD BUCKS FOR FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES.
RESULTS FROM OUR OWN PROGRAM
TRACKS THOSE WE'VE SEEN
NATIONALLY AS WELL.
NINETY PERCENT OF PROGRAM
PERSISTENCE MORE THAN NINETY
PERCENT AGREE ARE STRONGLY AGREE
THAT THEY BUY MORE FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES THEY EAT MORE FRUITS
AND VEGETABLES AND THEY CAN
STRETCH THEIR FOOD BUDGETS
FURTHER THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
TELLING US.
AND THE VAST MAJORITY HAVE ALSO
SAID THAT THEY'D LIKE TO SEE
THIS EXPAND.
OUR LONG TERM VISION IS THE SEED
DOUBLE UP FOOD BUCKS AND
PROGRAMS LIKE IT LIKE TRACY
MENTION THEIR NUMBER IN THE
STATE RIGHT NOW.
EXPAND TO GROCERY STORES AND
FARMERS MARKETS STATEWIDE SO
THAT WE CAN IMPROVE HEALTH FOOD
SECURITY AND SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE.
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL WOULD MOVE
THE STATE IN A STRONG STEP
FORWARD TOWARD THAT LONGER TERM
VISION.
FOR DOUBLE UP FOOD BUCKS AND
PROGRAMS LIKE TO SCALE WE NEED A
SYSTEM THAT'S EASIER TO ADOPT
EASY TO USE AND EASIER TO
ADMINISTER.
LIKE TRACY MENTION WHAT WE USE
PAPER COUPONS THAT'S WHAT THAT
CONFERENCE PARTICIPANTS GET FROM
THE GROCER.
I'M FOR THIS TO BE ABLE TO
EXPAND.
I'M WE NEED A SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS
RETAILERS TO MORE SEAMLESSLY
INTEGRATE THE PROGRAM INTO
EXISTING POINT OF SALE SYSTEMS.
SOMETHING TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
CUSTOMERS TO USE THEIR
SUPPLEMENTAL BENEFITS
AN INCREASE THE PROGRAMS
ADMINISTRATIVE EFFICACY.
THE CALPERS FRUIT AND VEGETABLE
EBT PILOT A WIN WIN WIN.
AT FIGHT POVERTY SUPPORTS HEALTH
NUTRITION AND BOOST CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURE I COULD TALK FOR A
REALLY LONG TIME DETAILS ARE BIG
PICTURE ABOUT THIS AND WOULD
LOVE TO. AND I HOPE WE CAN COUNT
ON YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SELENA PRIOR SEIU IN SUPPORT OF
THE CAL FRESH BENEFIT INCREASE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SPEAKER PLACE.
JUST GIVE OUR FLOW WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU EXPECT REPLACE.
MICHELLE STILL VERBINSKI
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT BECAUSE WE
HAVE ONE IN FIVE CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE FOOD INSECURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU
EXPECTANTLY.
THIS IS NOT INNOCENT ABOUT
IMMIGRANT AGGRESSION
COLLABORATIVE THE COUNTIES THAT
WERE SERVER PRIMARILY FRESNO
TAUGHT TO COUNTY KERN COUNTY. MY
THAT ARE COUNTIES THAT AS WAS
POINTED OUT EARLIER. ARE OF THE
UTMOST IMPORTANCE IN TERMS OF
OUR CULTURE PRODUCTION THAT IN
THE NATION BUT ALSO HAVE AMONG
THE HIGHEST RATES OF POVERTY IN
THE STATE AND THE NATION. SO WE
PROBABLY IN STRONG SUPPORT THIS
INITIATIVE.
ARE THERE ANY FURTHER WITNESSES
IN FAVOR OF.
ISSUES ELEVEN.
TEN ELEVEN TWELVE OR THIRTEEN.
SO I JUST WANTED TO MENTION THAT
I'M I SPOKE ON ITEM TEN BUT I AM
IN SUPPORT OF ALL OF THE OTHER
ITEMS.
X. THANK YOU.
AND.
WHETHER ANY FURTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE PUBLIC IN RELATION TO.
ITEMS TEN ELEVEN TWELVE OR
THIRTEEN NOW BE THE TIME LOOKS
LIKE YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT IT.
WAIT THE I KEPT FRESH AND
HEALTHY CHIEF JUST ONE SMALL
COMMENT ON IT AS YOU CONSIDER
EXPANDING THE INVESTMENT THE
FOOD BANKS JUST A MODEST
INVESTMENT WE NEED FOR THE STATE
TO ENSURE OVERSIGHT OF THAT
THAT'S JUST A SMALL ADDITION.
COME.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER COMMENTS
FROM.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR
THE LA SHOW.
OTTO WAS CARMEN OF FINANCE I
THINK WE WOULD NOTE WITH RESPECT
TO THE STATE FUNDED CAL FRESH
BENEFIT THAT OUT OF YOUR GEN
ENCODES A NUMBER OF COST BUT
DOESN'T INCLUDE ONE FOR THAT
SUPPLEMENTAL BENEFIT WE WOULD
SAY THAT PRELIMINARY ESTIMATES
RIGHT NOW SUGGESTS.
THAT EACH ADDITIONAL DOLLAR PER
INDIVIDUAL. PER MONTH WOULD COST
ROUGHLY FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE
MILLION ONGOING PER YEAR.
AND ROUGHLY TWENTY ONE POINT
NINE MILLION GENERAL FUND
ONGOING PER YEAR IF IT'S ONE
DOLLAR PER MONTH PER HOUSEHOLD.
ANY FURTHER COMMENT.
SAYING I'M GONNA MISS CHAIR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ON YOUR
BEFORE ITEMS.
.
YOU KNOW OFTENTIMES WE SIT ON
THE DIETS AND HERE A LOT OF
PUBLIC TESTIMONY AND.
THERE'S SINGULAR ISSUE I HEARD
LAST YEAR LOUD AND CLEAR WAS
THAT PEOPLE ARE HUNGRY.
AND THAT THERE'S A GREAT NEED
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES TO. HELP
TO FILL THAT VOID.
NAM I BELIEVE THAT ISSUES TEN
ELEVEN TWELVE AND THIRTEEN ARE A
MODEST PROPOSAL TO. MOVE THE
STATE FORWARD AND
TAP AND REALLY WANT TO ENCOURAGE
US TO TAKE A HARD LOOK AT IT AS.
THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WITH THAT I WILL PASS THE
GALLAGHER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARDIO HAD BEEN
HERE AND IF POSSIBLE WE'RE GOING
TO DO ISSUE NINETEEN MAXED.
CHIP MENTIONED SHE. PHONE SO IF
WE CAN GIVE HER A MINUTE SHE TO
SEE IF SHALL RETURN AND WILL DO
ISSUE NINETEEN
SO
.
FOR WAITING ONE MORE MINUTE IF
WE CAN FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARDIO
BEFORE WE BEGAN TO SWING INTO
INFORM YOU IF. THAT'S OKAY AND.
WHAT AN HONOR IT IS TO HAVE YOU
HERE DOLLARS?
CAN WE GET ONE MORE CHAIR FOR
DOCTOR WILL SEND. THAT PERSON
NEEDS IN THAT LAST ONE.
FOR SOMEBODY SITTING. AT LAST
CHECK.
I DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD.
THE WE JUST WANTED ONE IF THAT
CHAIR WAS VERY. THEN WE CAN GET
A DOCTOR OR A WILSON.
DIPLOMA.
FOR ALL.
YEAH
.
WE CAN MAKE ONE SEAT FOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BECAUSE KICKING
ON OUT OF THEIR CHAIRS
OKAY. LOCALES.
SORRY.
THAT REACHED UP WITH.
WE EFFORT.
WE'LL START WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARDIO WHEN YOU'RE READY.
WELL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I
AM HONORED TO BE HERE AND
INTRODUCE CALIFORNIA STATE
BUDGET GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION OF TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR FREEDOM CENTER.
AND THE THE LOTUS WHAT THAT
FOUNDATIONS YOUTH AND FAMILY
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT. INITIATIVE.
A STATEWIDE COLLABORATIVE EFFORT
TO ADDRESS DISPARITIES A CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT FOR LOW INCOME HIGHLY
VULNERABLE YOUTH AND FAMILIES.
IN OUR STATE HE YOUTH AND
FAMILY CIVIC MORTGAGE MANISHA.
WILL INCREASE CIVIC PART CIVIC
PARTICIPATION AMONG LOW INCOME
DISENFRANCHISED YOUTH. AND THEIR
FAMILIES THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
WHICH WILL INCREASE CIVIC WHICH
WILL INCREASE INCREASE CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AND INVOLVEMENT IN
OUR DEMOCRATIC. INSTITUTIONS
THIS INITIATIVE WILL EMPHASIZE
LOCAL LEADERSHIP.
AND AT CENTER ROLE IN PROMOTING
AND PROTECTING DEMOCRACY THROUGH
NONPARTISAN VOTER EDUCATION AND
ENGAGEMENT.
THIS INCLUDES CIVIC CAMPAIGNS
THAT HIGHLIGHT CULTURAL
AWARENESS AND SENSITIVITY
COMMUNITY PROBLEM SOLVING. AND
VITAL IMPORTANCE OF COMMON
VALUES AND ETHICS.
THIS INITIATIVE WILL TAKE MUCH
NEEDED STEPS TO ADDRESS THE LACK
OF TRUST BETWEEN LOW INCOME.
RURAL AND URBAN COMMUNITIES
REGARDING THE PLACE OF
GOVERNMENT AND CIVIC
INSTITUTIONS IN THEIR LIVES IN
OUR LIFE.
THE MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
FREEDOM CENTER AND THE LOTUS
WHAT THE FOUNDATION ARE LEADERS
IN THE STEWARDSHIP IN THE
CULTIVATION OF OUR STATE CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT WORK THEY ARE SHINING
EXAMPLE. A PRECISELY WHAT WE
NEED TO DO IN CALIFORNIA TO
COMBAT IGNORANCE AND ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO EXERCISE. THEIR
POLITICAL POWER.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT INCLUSION OF
THIS APPROPRIATION IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN
CALIFORNIA STATE. OPERATING
BUDGET AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION ESPECIALLY ON THE
STATE WHICH WE COMMEMORATE THE
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY.
OF.
MARTIN LUTHER KING'S PASSING
AND I'M SO HONORED TO JUST BE
HERE FOR W. ALONG. WITH OF THE
LOTUS WHAT THE HERSELF HAS BEEN
ON. A ROLL MODEL IN MY LIFE MANY
YEARS.
THANK YOU SOMEONE FOR NEXT WILL
MOVE ON TO DOCTOR BULKY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND
DOCTOR ARAMBULA FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE THIS
AFTERNOON.
THE MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
FREEDOM CENTER WORKS TO IMPROVE
HEALTH AND WELLNESS IN THE EAST
BAY REGION'S MOST VULNERABLE
HIGH POVERTY COMMUNITIES.
OFFERING YOUTH AND ADULT
EDUCATION AND CIVICS CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AND ETHICAL
LEADERSHIP. AS A MODEL FOR
PERSONAL TRANSFORMATION AND
COMMUNITY PROBLEM SOLVING.
THE CENTER WAS ACTUALLY FOUNDED
IN THE MID NINETIES THROUGH AN
ACT OF LEGISLATION WRITTEN BY
THEN STATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
ARE REALLY WAS SUPPORT OF THE
REPUBLIC GOVERNOR PETE WILSON.
BUSLOADS OF EAST BAY COMMUNITY
MEMBERS TESTIFIED ON A BILL
CREATING A STATE SANCTIONED
CENTER DEDICATED TO THE LIFE AND
LEGACY OF DOCTOR KING CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT YOUTH AND
NONVIOLENCE.
WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF THE HEALTH AND
SERVICES A COMMITTEE FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY AS
WE RECOGNIZE AND COMMEMORATE
FIFTY YEARS SINCE THE
ASSASSINATION OF DR KING.
THIS INITIATIVE COMES AT A VERY
IMPORTANT TIME FOR OUR STATE
EMPIRE COUNTRY.
IT PROMOTES A DEEPER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE ROLE OF
GOVERNMENT CIVICS AND STRUCTURES
THAT INVITE AND REQUIRE
COMMUNITY PARTICIPATION. IN
ORDER TO EFFECTIVELY AND
ORGANICALLY SOLVE COMMUNITY
PROBLEMS.
THE PEDAGOGY INTEGRATES LESSONS
FROM OUR NATION'S CIVIL RIGHTS
LEADERS
BASED ON THE UNDERSTANDING THAT
EACH OF US HAS THE CAPACITY TO
BE GREATER SERVICE.
THROUGH BEING A PART OF
SOMETHING LARGER THAN AND
OUTSIDE OF THE SELF THAT
BENEFITS THE WELL BEING OF
OTHERS.
IT MAKES USE OF A LEADERSHIP
PEER COACHING MODEL THAT
DEVELOPS THE SELF THAT IS OPEN
FOR OTHERS THAT IS SOMEONE'S
SISTER BROTHER NEIGHBOR OR CO
WORKER.
THE CURRICULUM WAS ACTUALLY
WRITTEN BY OUR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR DOCTOR RUTH WILSON. IN
CONJUNCTION WITH PROGRAMMING IN
THE STATE OF WASHINGTON WHERE AN
EIGHTEEN YEAR BIPARTISAN
STATEWIDE LEGISLATIVE
APPROPRIATION.
A POOR ITS NONVIOLENCE
LEADERSHIP OR TRIBES RURAL AND
URBAN COMMUNITIES.
A FIFTEEN YEAR STUDY TRACING
SHORT AND LONG TERM IMPACTS OF
THE PROGRAM IN BOTH WASHINGTON
STATE. AND HERE AT THE FREEDOM
CENTER IS IN THE POCKETS WE
PROVIDED FOR YOU.
HENCE THIS IS AN EVIDENCE BASED
INITIATIVE WITH DOCUMENTED
QUANTITATIVE AND QUALITATIVE
OUTCOMES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE WHICH
INCLUDE INCREASED ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE.
ATTENTION HIGH SCHOOL AND
COLLEGE DEGREE COMPILES AT
NINETY SIX AND EIGHTY SEVEN
PERCENT RESPECTIVELY. IMPRESSIVE
WORKFORCE AND COMMUNITY
LEADERSHIP ROLES AS ADULTS AS
WELL AS QUALITATIVE OUT
OUTCOMES.
THE HIGHLIGHT CONFIDENCE
OPTIMISM WORKFORCE READINESS AND
TEAMWORK SKILLS SOCIAL AND
PUBLIC SPEAKING SKILLS AND
FINDING MEANING IN ONE'S LIFE.
THE CLASSES AND ACTIVITIES AT
THE FREEDOM CENTER INVITE
PARTICIPANTS TO LEAVE CERTAIN
IMMEDIATE SHORT TERM
GRATIFICATION ASIDE. WHILE
PURSUING LONG TERM DURABLE
HAPPINESS AN ACCOMPLISHMENT AS
MODELED BY ICON. AND AMAZING
LEADER THE LOTUS
THIS IS THE ESSENCE OF OUR
NATION'S CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT
AND FARMWORKERS STRUGGLES THAT
ENCOURAGE DISCIPLINE SELF
CONTROL COOPERATION HONESTY AND
THE VALUE OF HARD WORK. TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR BOTH PERSONAL
AND COMMUNITY ADVANCE.
RESEARCH SUGGESTS THAT CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AND VOTING IS
HABITUAL BEHAVIOR YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO DEVELOP A HABIT OF VOTING
REGULARLY ARE LIKELY TO REMAIN
FREQUENT VOTERS.
WHILE THOSE WHO DON'T ARE LIKELY
TO REMAIN ON VOTERS.
THE EFFECT OF CURRENT
PARTICIPATION HABITS WILL BE FAT
FELT FOR DECADES NOT JUST YEARS.
STATISTICS SHOW THAT SCHOOL
RETENTION EMPLOYMENT RATES
STRONGER SOCIAL CONNECTIONS
VOLUNTARISM GREATER QUALITY OF
LIFE AND EVEN LONGEVITY. IS
IMPACTED BY VOTING AND CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT.
WE WOULD LIKE TO DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE LETTERS OF
SUPPORT IN YOUR PACKET THE
EVIDENCE BASED STUDY AND THE
DESCRIPTION OF THE INITIATIVE
AND.
I CLOSE MY COMMENTS WITH.
SINCERE GRATITUDE TO MY SISTER
CAMILLA CHAVEZ AND THAT ALL OF
US WITH.
NEXT POOL HERE WHICH OFFICE.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
ESTABLISH FIFTEEN YEARS AGO THAT
THE LOTUS WORK THAT FOUNDATIONS
MISSION IS TO INSPIRE AND
ORGANIZE COMMUNITIES TO CREATE
VOLUNTEER ORGANIZATIONS PURSUING
SOCIAL JUSTICE.
WE'VE ESTABLISHED INVESTING ALSO
NEED US UNITED NEIGHBOR CHAPTERS
AND TEN RURAL COMMUNITIES IN
THREE CENTRAL VALLEY COUNTIES
KERN TULARE AND FRESNO. THE
LARGEST CASINOS CHAPTERS ARE
BASED IN IRAN LAMONT WHEAT PATCH
LINDSEY WOULD LAKE AND SAYING.
THE RESIDENTS ARE PREDOMINANTLY
LATINO IMMIGRANTS AND
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS.
THE AVERAGE FARM WORKER WORKS
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT MONTHS OUT
OF THE YEAR AND EARNS LESS THAN
TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
TWENTY PERCENT OF KERN COUNTY
RESIDENTS LIVE IN POVERTY.
FRESNO COUNTY HAS A POVERTY RATE
OF TWENTY FIVE PERCENT.
MESSINA'S RECOGNIZE THAT THEY
ARE THE CATALYST FOR THE
SYSTEMIC CHANGES THAT CONSTITUTE
THE SOLUTIONS TO THE PROBLEMS
WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THEY HAVE THE POWER TO MAKE
CHANGES THROUGH THEIR COLLECTIVE
DIRECT ACTION.
THE VISITING ALSO NEED THOSE
CHAPTERS WORK ON COMMUNITY
CONCERNS THEY HAVE IDENTIFIED AS
BEING IMPORTANT. SUCH AS
EDUCATION HEALTH THE ENVIRONMENT
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT IN YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT.
FACING ALSO NEEDLES MEMBERS ARE
TRAINED TO WORK WITH THEIR
NEIGHBORS TO BRING ABOUT CHANGE
IN THEIR RESPECTIVE COMMUNITIES
BY DEVELOPING CAMPAIGNS
CIRCULATING PETITIONS.
DEVELOPING ALLIES AND
COMMUNICATING WITH PUBLIC
OFFICIALS TO ADVANCE POLICY
CHANGE.
VHF HAS DEVELOPED HUNDREDS OF
GRASSROOTS COMMUNITY LEADERS AND
ADVOCATES
B SEAMLESSLY ME THOSE YOUNG AND
OLD.
THEY ESTABLISHED A FIRST YOUTH
GROUP IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
ORGANIZE ANNUAL YOUTH
CONFERENCES. CREATE MULTIPLE USE
LED COMMUNITY MERRILL'S.
STARTED A TEENS GROUP FOR
EQUALITY.
THAT SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSES LGBT
ISSUES IN SCHOOLS AND THE
COMMUNITY.
LET TV PREGNANCY PREVENTION
PROGRAMS AND HAVE TAKEN DOZENS
OF USE ON SUMMER CAMPING TRIPS
IN THE SEQUOIAS THAT TEACH
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP.
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT IN EDUCATION
ARE CORE TO DHS WORK IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN DE HF TRAIN
TWELVE CANVASSERS AND FORTY NINE
VOLUNTEERS TO EDUCATE MAKE
STATUS IMMIGRANT FAMILIES.
UNLESS BEFORE HEALTH FOR ALL
WHICH PROVIDES FULL SCOPE MEDI
CAL TO IMMIGRANTS UNDER NINETEEN
YEARS OLD.
THEY KNOCKED ON OVER A THOUSAND
DOORS HAD MORE THAN FOUR
THOUSAND CONVERSATIONS AND PRE
SCREEN ALMOST THREE HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN THE THIRTY
DAY TIMEFRAME.
IN TWO THOUSAND TEN D. H. HAVE
TRAINED OVER A HUNDRED
VOLUNTEERS TO ENCOURAGE
NEIGHBORS T COMPLETE THE CENSUS
SURVEY. AND THEN ONE DAY THEY
KNOCKED ON THREE THOUSAND DOORS
IN SOUTHERN KERN COUNTY.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON DISMANTLING
THE SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE.
TO BUILD THE SCHOOL TO CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT POP PIPELINE DHS HAS
ESTABLISHED REGIONAL COALITIONS
WITH COMMUNITY AND LEGAL AID
GROUPS TO PROVIDE TOOLS AND
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS THE
DISPROPORTIONATE RATES.
OF SUSPENSIONS AND EXPULSIONS
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
OUR EFFORTS ARE FOCUSED ON
DEVELOPING USE AND PARENTS AS
ADVOCATES TO HOLD THEIR SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS AND SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS ACCOUNTABLE.
IN KERN HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT COMMUNITY ADVOCATES
HAVE BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN
ELIMINATING RACIALLY BIASED
DISCIPLINE POLICIES AND
PRACTICES.
THROUGH THE LOCAL CONTROL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN STUDENTS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN WORKING WITH
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS TO BETTER
SERVE LOW INCOME. ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND FOSTER
USE.
WE ARE NOW WORKING IN CALIFORNIA
CITY WHERE FOUR OUT OF FIVE
AFRICAN AMERICANS ARE BEING
SUSPENDED.
THIS IS THE HIGHEST SUSPENSION
RATE IN THE STATE.
THESE PROJECTS HAVE TAUGHT
COMMUNITY MEMBERS THE IMPORTANCE
OF CIVIC ENGAGEMENT. MANY HAVE
BEEN INSPIRED TO RUN FOR OFFICE.
MISSING ALSO ONLY THOSE MEMBERS
SIT ON SCHOOL BOARDS LOCAL PARKS
AND RECREATION DISTRICTS WATER
DISTRICTS AND CITY COUNCILS.
TWO YEARS AGO AT THE AGE HAVE
PARTNERED WITH THE MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR FREEDOM CENTER. WE
HOSTED THIRTY YOUTH FROM THE BAY
AREA IN WASHINGTON WHO WORKED TO
REGISTER ONE THOUSAND VOTERS AND
INTENSE CENTRAL VALLEY HEAT.
WE WERE EXTREMELY IMPRESSED WITH
THE CONTACT AND COMMITMENT OF
THE SAN LEADERS. THIS FIRST
EXPERIENCE HAS LED TO AN ONGOING
COLLABORATION THIS PAST SUMMER
WE HOSTED THEM OKAY USE AGAIN IN
CURRENTLY FRESNO. OUR EFFORTS
ARE DEVELOPING THE FUTURE
LEADERS NEEDED FOR PRESERVING
OUR DEMOCRACY SEE SEPARATE AND.
THANK YOU.
AND I DON'T THINK IT'S A DRY
HEAT I DON'T KNOW MY BAND TEN
BUT. I KNOW BETTER THAN TO.
DENYING OPPORTUNITY TO DELUDE
US WHAT THAT TO SPEAK AND WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR ANYTHING YOU CAN
THAT THE SENATE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN UP MY COMMENT IS VERY
BRIEF ACTUALLY. I WOULD HOPE
THAT THE COMMITTEE WOULD SEE
THIS AS AN INVESTMENT.
AS YOU ALL KNOW IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY OF CALIFORNIA A WE ONLY
HAVE ONE INTO IT WHEN YOU TO
RICK. UNIVERSITY THAT HAS BEEN
BUILT INTO RUSSIA MERCED AND YET
WE HAVE OVER TWENTY PRISONS.
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY OF
CALIFORNIA SO MUCH OF OUR WORK
IS AS TRIED TO STOP AT SCHOOL TO
PRISON PIPELINE. AND THIS OF
COURSE IS A SAVINGS TO
TAXPAYERS.
THE WITH ALLOWING BILL THAT'S
LIKE SOUND LIKE A LOT OF MONEY
AND IN THIS BUDGET ITEM BUT WE
THINK IT WOULDN'T KEEP MORE
YOUNG PEOPLE OUT OF PRISON.
AND GET THE MOB ON SCHOOL AND
THE COLLEGES OF THAT WILL BE A
ACTUALLY OF THE IT WILL BE IN
AND OF THE FROM FOR THE WHOLE
THING CALIFORNIA. NOT ONLY PUT
THESE TWO AREAS OF THE BUT THE
BAY AREA AND THE CENTER AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY OF WHEN THIS
PROGRAM IS SORELY NEEDED. OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY I DON'T HAVE VERY MANY
OPPORTUNITIES IS KIND OF A
DIRECT. THEY DON'T HAVE MEANT
MANY RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
MANY EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
AND WE BELIEVE ALIKE ALL THE
WORK. OF THE WORK THAT WE HAVE
DONE IN THE PAST IT WOULD START
WITH THE GRASSROOTS IT WOULD
START WITH THE YOUNG PEOPLE OF
THEM IT IS A VERY FRUITFUL. AND
I THINK NOT ONLY WILL OUR AREAS
BE ABLE TO A TO PROFIT FROM THIS
LITTLE SAID A CALIFORNIA WILL
PROFIT FROM THE SOUL AND WE HOPE
THAT THE BUDGET MEMBERS WILL.
LOOK AT THIS VERY SERIOUSLY AND
AS I SAID BEFORE LOOK AT THIS AS
AN INVESTMENT I JUST WANTED TO
ADD THAT THE FIRST TIME I CAME
TO SACRAMENTO.
I WAS TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD.
AND THE BIT ME UP I THINK BEFORE
PUBLIC MOST OF THE PEOPLE IN
THIS ROOM WERE BORN LISA.
FIFTY YEARS AGO SO ONE OF THE
TRONG WITH TEXAS THAT'S ONE OF
THINGS WRONG WITH TEXAS OKAY.
BUT THE IF YOU CAN SEE BY THAT
THE YOUNG PEOPLE HERE IN THIS
ROOM OF THAT WE DO BELIEVE THAT
AT THIS WILL BE A OF. A BADLY
NEEDED INVESTMENT IN OUR YOUTH
BOTH IN CENTRAL VALLEY AND AND
IN THE BAY AREA SOAP LEGAL TO
JEWEL AGAINST OF CONSIDERATION.
YOU VERY MUCH.
DOCTOR WILSON ELECTED AT AN
AWARDS.
I WOULD BE BETTER VERY BRIEF DR
AFFORDABLE AT AND TO YOU AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR WHAT YOU DO.
FOR A OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT ARE
AFFILIATED WITH OUR A
ORGANIZATIONS.
ARE FROM AROUND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN A MOMENT I WANT TO
ADDRESS THAT AGAIN BUT.
.
WHERE PEOPLE DON'T VOTE SCHOOLS
DON'T WORK?
WHERE PEOPLE DON'T VOTE?
HAVE THE HIGHS AND THE FEES OF
GUN VIOLENCE.
WHERE PEOPLE DON'T VOTE?
THERE IS THE.
HORRIBLE
CRUEL.
MYTH THAT.
YOU DON'T MATTER.
THE YOUNG PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM
AND ALL THE YOUNG PEOPLE.
THAT WE ARE PRIVILEGED TO RELATE
TO KNOW.
THAT.
POLITICS POLITICIANS GOVERNMENT.
AND THE RULE OF LAW MATTER.
AND THEY RESPECT AND CARE ABOUT.
THOSE WHO DO MATTER AND OFFICE.
THIS SADDAM BENICIA TEAR.
WELL GENERATE AND MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES PEOPLE THAT HAVE
BEEN LEFT OUT AND LOCKED OUT.
AND OTHER COMMUNITIES WHERE
THERE IS A SENSE OF SERIOUSNESS
ABOUT DEMOCRACY.
.
THIS WILL ASSIST A MORE
EQUITABLE.
THE MORE REAL.
FOR MORE LOVING AND A MORE
PARTICIPATORY SOCIETY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA OUR CHILDREN
HAVE BEEN GIVEN ONE ROLE IN
LIFE.
CDVA.
ASSEMBLY.
THE JOBS FOR THEM THAT MEAN
ANYTHING.
ARE NOT BEEN THEIR HORIZONS
THEY'RE NOT ENOUGH OF SEATS IN
THE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM FOR ALL OF
OUR SEVENTH GRADERS.
IT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT
CIVIC CLASSES GO FROM WEALTHY
NEIGHBORHOODS.
TO ALL SCHOOLS AND IT WOULDN'T
MATTER.
SOME OF THE STUDENTS DON'T KNOW
WHERE TO GET A STOP SIGN FIXED
SOME OF THEIR PARENTS DON'T KNOW
IF THE SCHOOLS NOT WORKING
WHETHER THEY SHOULD GO TO THE
MAYOR ARE NOT.
CLEARLY WE NEED CIVICS
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA NEED
CIVIC THINK CLOSING. ALONG WITH.
.
A GREAT HEADLIGHT IN AND TUTOR
OF OURS SUBTLER WHERE TOM.
I MUST BRING UP THE NAME DOCTOR
KING.
I THINK IT'S ARGUABLE THAT
DEMOCRACY DIE.
ON APRIL FOURTH FIFTY YEARS AGO.
AND IT'S BEEN TWO GENERATIONS
FAMILY BEEN STRUGGLING WITH HOW
TO CREATE. CITIZENSHIP IN
DEMOCRACY EVER SAT. IT IS
IMPORTANT NOW MORE THAN EVER IN
THIS COUNTRY TO HAVE YOUNG
PEOPLE.
BROUGHT INTO THE CIRCLE OF
CARING AND PARTICIPATION.
WE BELIEVE THIS INITIATIVE CAN
HELP YOU THAT IN A SUBSTANTIAL
WAY AND WE'RE ASKING FOR YOU.
TO.
STUDY THIS.
LOOK AT THE FACTS.
AND ASSISTANCE WHEN I STARTED I
MENTIONED THE GEOGRAPHIC OUGHT
TO BREATH WE HAVE ABOUT.
WORKED IN THE UKIAH I ATTENDED
YUROK NATION IN CRESCENT CITY
AND SAN DIEGO.
AND EVERY A MAJOR A SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN TRAINING CLEANING
LA.
BUT SANTA BARBARA.
MONTEREY SALINAS STOCKTON AND
SHARON SACRAMENTO SO WHEN YOU
ADD THIS UP BETWEEN OUR TWO
ORGANIZATIONS. WE GOT THE STATE
COVERED.
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
I'M. I HAVE ON MY AGENDA HAD
DIRECTOR LIGHT BORN AS WELL AS
THE LEON AROUND MOST DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE.
RATHER THAN JUST. ALL THE
OBVIOUSLY THE PROPOSAL THAT TO
SOME MEMBER CARILLO BROUGHT
FORWARD ARM WASN'T IN A PART OF
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL BUT.
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT.
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING ULTIMATELY
IS
A CORNERSTONE OF COMMUNITY
HEALING AND HEALTH.
WHICH IN TURN IS DIDN'T
NECESSARY BUILDING BLOCK FOR
ECONOMIC.
DEVELOPMENT AND AND AND GROWTH
AND PROSPERITY. EARLY IN MY
CAREER I I HAD THE GREAT HONOR
OF WORKING WITH
PEOPLE LIKE FRED ROSS AND JEAN
BOYLAN.
ON GARY DELGADO HAND ALL OF THEM
WERE INSPIRED BY.
THE GIANT AMONG US.
BILLION ARE ALSO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE OF WOULD JUST
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER ANY STATE RESOURCES
NEEDED TO ADMINISTER THIS
PROGRAM AND. OF MAYBE INCLUDE
SOME REPORTING REQUIREMENTS TO
ENSURE THE FINDINGS ARE GOING TO
WEAR ON THE NECESSITY OF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WITH THAT WE WILL NOW TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
NINETEEN.
S. COMPORT.
CLICK SWAY AT THE YOUTH.
WHO BELIEVE THEY'LL BE WAITING
AND I'M GET LINE I WANTED TO USE
THAT TO JUST ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
JUST A PARTNER WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY?
IN AT A YOU KNOW ME FROM MY WORK
HERE.
I BEGAN. OF BEING A ANTI
POVERTY ORGANIZER TWENTY YEARS
AGO AFTER WELFARE REFORM PASSED
AND I KNEW THAT WHAT THE
DIALOGUE HAPPENED.
AT THE NATIONAL AND STATE LEVEL
WAS NOT.
HONEST TO POVERTY AS I KNEW IT A
GROWING UP AND BEING A YOUNG
PERSON AND POVERTY. AND MY FIRST
JOB OUT OF.
IT INTO THIS WORK WAS VOTER
REGISTRATION FOR LOW INCOME
PEOPLE IN WELFARE OFFICES.
THIS IS A RESPONSIBILITY THAT
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
HAS TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF LOW
INCOME PEOPLE WHO COME IN FOR
NEEDS TESTED BENEFITS ARE
OFFERED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REGISTER TO VOTE. BUT THE SPIRIT
OF THE LAW IS MUCH LARGER AND.
INVITES.
PUBLIC NEEDS.
AGENCIES TO ENCOURAGE CIVIC
PARTICIPATION AND VOTER
PARTICIPATION AMONG LOW INCOME
PEOPLE AND IN THE US.
AND SO WERE PROUD TO BE.
SENDING SAID BY SIDE WITH THE
MARTIN LUTHER KING FREEDOM UP.
FREEDOM CENTER AND.
BUT ADLER'S WHAT'S FOUNDATION
AND IN SUPPORT OF THIS REQUEST
AND IF SO CERTAINLY THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HERSELF THINK.
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE WORK THAT
YOU DO IN FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
BEFORE I JOIN THE MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR FREEDOM CENTER. I
WAS TO SCARED TO ORDER AT A
RESTAURANT ON MY.
AND THROUGH CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AND
THE TEACHINGS THAT WE LEARNED
HERE. I WAS ABLE TO LEARN THAT
WE ALL HAVE A VOICE REGARDLESS
OF WHERE WE COME FROM OR WHO WE
ARE.
AND THAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
USE THAT VOICE IN ORDER TO SPEAK
UP FOR WHAT MATTERS FOR THE
VALUES THAT DOCTOR KING TAUGHT.
IN THAT THE LAWYERS WHERE IT'S
AT WORKS TO.
IMPOSE IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
LOVE AND GRATITUDE AND CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT.
YOU.
I MY NAME IS MYRA AND I STARTED.
BEING INVOLVED IN CIVICS WITH
AND THESE.
ORGANIZATIONS WHEN I WAS IN THE
SEVENTH GRADE.
AND I MEDAKA STUDENTS AND BEFORE
I WAS INVOLVED I HAD NO IDEA
THAT EVEN. IF YOU'RE NOT A
CITIZEN YOU HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
INSPIRE AND INFLUENCE CHANGE IN
YOUR COMMUNITY AND YOU DON'T
HAVE TO LET FEAR DETERMINE YOUR
DECISIONS. AND I AM SO GLAD THAT
I GET TO TEACH THAT TO MY LITTLE
SISTERS AND TO MY FAMILY.
AND LET THEM KNOW THAT THEY
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO MAKE
CHANGE.
HUMAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KAY.
.
BEING CIVIC RAIN GAUGE WITH THE
FREEDOM CENTER HAS PUT A MIRROR
IN FRONT OF ME.
HAS HELPED ME SEE THAT.
TO GO FROM BLAMING PEOPLE TO
LISTENING TO PEOPLE.
TO GO FROM ON COMPLAINING TO
ORGANIZING.
AND IT'S HELPED ME SEE THAT I
CANNOT BE GREAT IF MY COMMUNITY
IS NOT GREAT THANK YOU.
I THINK.
IAM HI EVERYBODY MY NAME IS
GOVERNOR THE LAST ITEM ON THIS.
I BEGAN VOLUNTEERING WITH THE
LOTUS WENT THAT THE AGE OF
ELEVEN SO I KNOW HOW THIS I'M
ORGANIZATION CAN TRANSFORM YOU.
MY SISTER TOOK ME THE FIRST
TIME TO DO VOTER REGISTRATION
DOOR TO DOOR AND I GOT PARTNERED
UP WITH NO NOTICE HERSELF. AND.
WE KNOCKED ON EVERY SINGLE DOOR
EVEN THOUGH ON THE BORDER LIST
THERE'S ONLY FORTY DOORS. I'M
SHE SAID EVERYONE NEEDS TO BE
INFORMED OF THE COMMUNITY AND
THE COMMUNITY SO I WANT TO THANK
HER FOR TEACHING ME THE VALUE OF
VOTING I REGISTERED AT THAT.
WHEN I WAS EIGHTEEN AND I WAS
VERY EXCITED THE FIRST TIME I
WAS ABLE TO CAST MY VOTE. AND I
WANT THERE TO BE A PROGRAM IN
ORDER FOR MORE YOUNG PEOPLE TO
HAVE THIS EXCITEMENT AND TO BE
ABLE TO. JUST REGISTER AS MANY
PEOPLE AND IT'S NOT EVEN JUST
REGISTERING VOTERS BUT IT'S ALSO
THE CULTURE I THINK YOU DEVELOP
A CULTURE AS YOU GROW UP AND NOW
I AM. WORKING WITH A LOT IS WHAT
THE FOUNDATION AND I'M HELPING
YOUNG PEOPLE ACHIEVE BY AND I'M
ALSO WORKING WITH THE PARENTS SO
I WANT TO THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH
FOR CONSIDERING THAT.
YOU CAN.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE ARM I JUST WANNA SAY I
WAS SHY I WAS QUIET. AND IN THE
CARE AT ANY CARE ABOUT THE
PROBLEMS HAPPENING IN MY EAST
BAY COMMUNITY. CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
HAS ALLOWED ME TO SPEAK UP IT'S
ALLOWED ME TO GET MY VOICE OUT
THERE.
NOT GETTING THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
OTHER YOUTH LIKE ME I JUST FEEL
LIKE. IT'S IT'S NOT FAIR SO THAT
ALONE IS A.
BECOME A.
NO I BOTTOM MOST THE EARLY
FOUNDATION ON THIS FOURTH DAY OF
APRIL LEAD TO SUPPORT THIS
EMERGING PROPOSAL.
AND THEN ON A PERSONAL NOTE I AM
ONE OF THOSE FROM WORKER KIDS
FROM WOULD LIKE CALIFORNIA.
WHO'S ABLE TO GET OUT NOW I SEE
THESE KIDS HERE AND WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN THEM AS
THOSE OTHER FUTURE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
EATEN IN EVERYONE MY NAME'S JUST
COMPANY ABOUT US AND I'M THE
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
COORDINATOR AT THE DOLLAR'S
WORTH THE FOUNDATION BUT I WANT
TO QUIT GIVE A STATEMENT ON
BEHALF OF MY NEPHEW ANTHONY WHO
COULDN'T MAKE IT HERE TODAY.
SO.
I'LL GO AHEAD AND READ A
STATEMENT AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
SO I'M WRITING THIS LETTER IN
SUPPORT OF THE DEALERS WHAT THE
FOUNDATION I BELIEVE DE CHECK IS
CAPABLE OF RECEIVING SUPPORT
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE.
OF ITS HISTORY AND IMPACT THAT
AFFECTS YOUTH AND FAMILIES TO
THIS DAY I BEGAN VOLUNTEERING
FOR THE D. HF WHEN I WAS TEN
YEARS OLD HELPING. PLAN. ITS TOY
GIVEAWAY AND ITS ANNUAL
CHRISTMAS PARTY AND AFTER
WITNESSING THE WORK THEY DO AND
MY COMMUNITIES ARVIN AND
BAKERSFIELD I AM NOW SIXTEEN
AND.
THROUGH THAT THE HIF I HAVE
GAINED A LOT OF EXPERIENCE IN
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT I HAVE GONE
ORDER DOOR KNOCKING FOAM PAINT
AND CANVAS FOR INITIATIVES THAT.
DIRECTLY BENEFIT MY NEIGHBORHOOD
AND COMMUNITIES AROUND ME MY
FAVORITE CAMPAIGN WAS THE HEALTH
FOR ALL EFFORT RAISING
AWARENESS.
ABOUT ENROLLMENT INTO HEALTH
HEALTH INSURANCE BECAUSE IT
HELPED ME REALIZE THE FOUNDATION
HAS BECOME A PLACE FOR ME. TO
ADVOCATE FOR SOMETHING I BELIEVE
IN.
I WOULD LIKE.
DH UP TO RECEIVE YOUR SUPPORT
BECAUSE I WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE
YOUTH.
LIKE MYSELF GET INVOLVED IN
THEIR COMMUNITY THINK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. OF MY NAME IS
GABRIEL. AND I THINK CIVICS IS
IMPORTANT.
I KNOW I THINK THAT THOUGH.
I A I GOTA CAO SOMEONE IN DEEP
EAST OAKLAND AND THERE'S A LOT
OF DIFFERENT KIDS THAT THEY HAVE
A LOT OF DIFFERENT MIND SETS
THEM WHAT I HAVE RIGHT NOW.
THERE IS.
WITHOUT CIVICS I WOULD KNOW HOW.
I WOULDN'T IT WAS PACIFIC'S I
WOULDN'T BE HERE I WOULD KNOW
HOW TO GET. INFORMED I WOULD
KNOW HOW TO.
RECOGNIZE PROBLEMS AND KNOW HOW
TO GET PEOPLE WHO SHARE THE SAME
OPINIONS AND GET TOGETHER AND
MAKE AND MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
THERE IS.
I HAVE SEVERAL FRIENDS THAT
WOULD VERY MUCH BENEFIT BEING
HERE RIGHT NOW.
AND THEY DON'T THEY DON'T KNOW
THE IMPORTANCE OF CIVICS AND
IT'S NOT TOO LATE FOR THEM TO.
TO LEARN THIS AND THERE'S A LOT
OF KIDS THAT.
I'M A SENIOR AT HOUSE MONTH THIS
LOT OF KIDS THAT ARE.
THAT HAVE A LOT OF PROBLEMS AND
THEY REALIZE PROBLEMS THEY DON'T
KNOW HOW TO FIX THESE PROBLEMS.
AND CIVICS CIVICS IS A GOOD WAY
OF GIVING THEM ABRIDGED MAKING
THIS CHANGE.
SO.
I HOPE THESE GUYS MAKE A GOOD
DECISION TODAY. THANK YOU SIR.
NO PRESSURE.
GOOD VENING MY NAME IS DAVID
AND BEFORE CIVIC THING CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT.
LIKE A LOT OF OTHER YOU'VE
THOUGHT AND CARE ABOUT THE
THINGS GOING ON.
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT ALLOWED ME TO
APPEAL TO A VOICE.
TO SOMETHING BIGGER THAN MYSELF.
IT DEMANDS THAT WE ACTS Y..
AND IT DEMANDS THAT WE.
CHANGE OUR DAILY CONDUCT THE WAY
WE CONDUCT OUR SO.
AND IT DEMANDS THAT WE
ACKNOWLEDGE HISTORY.
AND THE PEOPLE OF THE PAST.
TODAY I AM HERE BECAUSE OF
CIVICS.
I AM ALIVE BECAUSE OF CIVICS.
HI MY NAME IS LAMONT. AND I GO
TO ALAMEDA HIGH IN MY COMMUNITY
I USE TO ONLY.
TAKE TAKE EVERYTHING IN I AM AND
I HAD NOTHING TO GIVE.
AND CIVIC ENGAGEMENT HELP ME TO
UNDERSTAND. THAT.
I HAVE A VOICE AND I HAVE POWER
AND I CAME OUT OF MY SHYNESS TO
BE ABLE TO. HELP MY COMMUNITY
AND.
BEING ABLE TO HELP OTHERS AROUND
ME THAT NEED HELP AND.
.
HELP ME TO REALIZE THAT NOT NOT
ONLY I HAVE A VOICE NOT ONLY I
HAVE POWER BUT OTHERS AROUND WE
HAVE POWER TO AND I WOULD HELP
THEM KNOW THAT.
.
WITH CIVICS WELL BEFORE HIM I
WISH I I WAS QUIET.
IN I FELT LIKE I REALLY DIDN'T
HAVE A VOICE THE SAME IN MY
COMMUNITY AND I BILL AYE WITH
CIVICS.
IT COULD BRING PEOPLE OF VOICE
AND MAKE THEM FEEL LIKE THEY'RE
WORTH SOMETHING.
THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
COMMUTER AND BEFORE. I WAS
UNAWARE OF ALL THE INJUSTICE
THAT WENT ON IN MY COMMUNITY.
AND I WOULD JUST LIVE LIVE
WITHOUT KNOWING THAT THE STUFF
THOSE HAPPENING NOW WILL IMPACT
MY FUTURE.
AND AFTER LEARNING ABOUT CIVIL
FIT CIVIC ENGAGEMENT I WAS ABLE
TO GET INVOLVED IN NOW I HOPE
TO.
GET THE COMMUNITY INVOLVED TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE OF THAT.
GENERATIONS FUTURE CAN BE
DIFFERENT AND WE CAN ALL LIVE
COME THROUGH THE AND.
STRIVING FOR CHANGE THANK YOU.
I COMMEND.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALL MY NAME IS
STEVEN OF THE PRIOR TO ME
JOINING THEM OKAY FREEDOM CENTER
I WAS. AN AT RISK OWE YOU WELL
I'M AWAY TO A PRISON PIPELINE
SYSTEM.
LEARN HOW TO ADVOCATE AS OF
JOINT LA HOW ADVOCATE A SPEAKER
FOR THE COMMUNITY THAT I COME
FROM THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SEBASTIAN IN
PRIOR TO CIVICS I WAS VERY
NARCISSISTIC AND I DIDN'T QUITE
CARE ABOUT WHAT WAS GOING ON IN
MY COMMUNITY. ONCE I HAD GOTTEN
INTO IT AND NOW I'M ENJOYING
BEING A PART OF MY COMMUNITY IN
HELPING.
THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS CA MY ATTORNEY
I'M A STUDENT AT OAKLAND HIGH
SCHOOL AND.
FOR AWHILE I WAS I DIDN'T FEEL
HEARD AND FEEL LIKE I MY
OPINIONS WAY VERY MUCH ON. THE
COMMUNITY THAT I LIVE IN THAT'S
MY COMMUNITY THIS IS THE WORLD
THAT WE ALL SHARE AND WE ALL
LIVE IN. IF FOR MY VOICE NOT TO
BE HER IT.
IT'S LIKE IT'S LIKE I DON'T
MATTER. S. SERVING GAVE EACH AND
THESE.
PROGRAMS A FOUNDATION IN THESE.
.
THESE PROGRAMS ARE BEEN A PART
OF THEY'VE HOLD ME TO SPEAK UP
AND BE THE VOICE FOR THE AND
HEARD AND. OF BEING A PART OF
THE OPEN COMMUNITY AND OPEN HIGH
SCHOOL WE FEEL PUSHED AWAY WE
FEEL. UNCERTAIN THAT PEOPLE CARE
FOR US AND SIEVING GAVE ME IT
WILL HELP PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY
MATTER.
I CAME.
HI MY NAME IS MARIA AND.
BEFORE I WAS GIVEN THE
EDUCATION FROM THE MARTIN LUTHER
KING FAN CENTER I COULD SEE THE
INJUSTICE IN MY COMMUNITY BUT I
DON'T FEEL AS THOUGH I HAD ANY
POWER TO CHANGE ANYTHING. AND I
FELT VERY FRUSTRATED BECAUSE I
FELT THAT NOTHING WOULD EVER BE
DIFFERENT AND I CAN DO ANYTHING
BUT SINCE JOINING THE FREEDOM
CENTER AND LEARNING THAT CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT I'VE LEARNED THAT NOT
ONLY AM I AM POWERED. BY I CAN
EMPOWER MY PEERS IN MY COMMUNITY
SO THANK YOU THE COMMAND.
HELLO MY NAME IS OCEAN SCRUGGS
AND BEFORE I GOT CIVIC LEE.
EDUCATED I WAS JUST ANOTHER
STUDENT IN THE CSU SYSTEM.
WHERE WE WOULD JUST STUDIED THE
SURFACE OF THE PROBLEMS BUT
NEVER THE ROOT NEVER ANY ACTION?
AND WITH CIVIC ENGAGEMENT I'VE
BEEN ABLE TO STUDY THE ROOT OF
THE PROBLEM THE PSYCHOLOGICAL AT
THE PSYCHOLOGY OF THE PROBLEM
AND ABLE TO ACTUALLY TAKE ACTION
UPON THE PROBLEM.
PARTICULAR CRYSTAL MEDINA CENTER
ON IMMIGRANT AGGRESSION
COLLABORATIVE.
I AM A FATHER OF AN ELEVEN YEAR
OLD DAUGHTER AND A FIFTEEN YEAR
OLD SON.
SO I KNOW THAT AT LEAST TO ME
AND MY WIFE THERE IS NO GREATER
INVESTMENT THE BEST INVESTMENT
WE CAN MAKE PAT. DEVELOPMENT OF
OUR KIDS SO THIS PROJECT THAT.
SIX INVESTMENT YOUNG PEOPLE THAT
PICKED NEEDS OUR SUPPORT.
A AS THE CHAIR OF THE CENTER
VALLEY IMMIGRANT AGGRESSION
COLLABORATIVE WILL ALSO RUN
MULTIPLE INTERNSHIP AND
FELLOWSHIP PROJECTS FOR COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND COLLEGE GRADUATES.
AND THEY HAVE REALLY MADE A
DIFFERENCE IN ALL THE WORK THAT
WE DO IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY TO
ASSIST IMMIGRANT FAMILIES SO I
STRONGLY BELIEVE IN THE BEST
THING YOU'VE AND I SUPPORT THIS
PROGRAM HARD.
SEEING NO MORE PUBLIC COMMENT
I'LL BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS
JUST TO ADD MY TWO CENTS IF I
CAN.
YOU NO LIKE THE FEW WORDS CAME
TO MIND AFTER WE'VE HAD SO MANY
EXTRA ORDINARY YOUTH COME AND
SPEAK TO IT.
AND THE FIRST ONE WAS WOKE.
AND THE SECOND WAS EMPOWERED.
I REALLY FEEL THAT YOU HAVE
LEARNED THE TOOLS THAT ARE
NECESSARY IN THIS LIFE TO HAVE A
VOICE AND ADVOCATE FOR YOUR
COMMUNITIES.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT YOUR HERE
TODAY TO ADD YOUR VOICE TO THIS
ISSUE BUT THAT YOU CONTINUE TO
BE ADVOCATES THROUGHOUT YOUR
LIFETIME. SO I HOPE YOU STAY
WILK AND EMPOWERED THROUGHOUT
YOUR LIFE.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
NINETEEN OPEN AND WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARDIO AND
EVERYONE WHO CAME TO PERCENT ON.
A SIMILAR CAREER AND INCOME AS A
MOMENT OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I.
THE WORDS THAT YOU SAY. WOKEN
EMPOWERMENT BRING VERY TRUE.
AND TO SHARED THE TESTAMENT OF
THE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT WERE HERE
TODAY.
AND THE IMPORTANCE OF WHAT THIS
SAYS
I AM A FORMALLY UNDOCUMENTED
YOUNG PERSON IN THIS COUNTRY
THAT HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
RESIDENCY AND CITIZENSHIP.
BECAME THE FIRST ONE IN MY
FAMILY TO BE ABLE TO VOTE A
FAMILY OF SEVEN.
NOW WE'RE A FAMILY OF SIX VOTERS
WITH MY FATHER HOPEFULLY SOME
BECOMING A CITIZEN OF THE UNITED
STATES RACER. AND THE IMPORTANCE
OF SICK CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AND.
ACTIVISM IS HUGELY INSTRUMENTAL
FOR COMMUNITIES AND WE HOPE THAT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA CAN. CAN
REALLY SEE THE IMPORTANCE OF
WHAT THIS MEANS BECAUSE
SOMETHING THAT I READ A COUPLE
OF MONTHS AGO WHEN I FIRST GOT
HERE I'VE ONLY BEEN HERE
FOURTEEN WEEKS IN MY POSITION.
IS THAT THE BICAMERAL A
COMMITTEE SAID. CALIFORNIA MAY
NOT HAVE BEEN AT THE INCEPTION
OF THIS COUNTRY BUT IT WILL
CERTAINLY BE THAT FUTURE. AND
THE FUTURE IS IN THIS ROOM RIGHT
NOW AND THEY CARRY THE TESTAMENT
AND TESTIMONY OF THE FREEDOM
RIDERS A FIFTY YEARS AGO.
OF THE WORK THAT HAS BEEN DONE
THE CONTINUES TO BE DONE AND
THAT WILL BE DONE IN THE FUTURE
AND SO WE AS LEGISLATORS PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN ENSURING. THAT
ALL CALIFORNIANS THAT EVERYONE
THE CALLED CALIFORNIA HOME HAS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR EQUITY.
JUSTICE
AND THE LIFE THAT THEY WANT TO
LEAD AND SO I AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR FOR YOUR TIME AND FOR
ALLOWING THESE YOUNG PEOPLE TO
SPEAK THEIR TRUTH. AND HOPEFULLY
A WE HAVE SOME POSITIVE RESULTS
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS INITIATIVE
AND MOVING THIS INITIATIVE
FORWARD THINKING. THANK YOU
SOMEONE PERFIDIA.
WITH THAT WE WILL RETURN TO
ISSUE FIFTEEN
.
YEAH.
IT DOESN'T TAKE.
I HAVE A FIFTEEN.
WE WOKE.
THANK A DIRECTOR LIKE FOREIGN
PRISCILLA RELEASE BOTH FOR OF
PILING US THAT.
WHO'S GONNA TURN IT OVER TO.
MARCY GOOD EVENING.
TOUGH ACT TO FOLLOW.
.
I. THINK YOU FOR INCLUDING THEM
VERY THOROUGH OVERVIEW OF THE
IMMIGRATION SERVICES PROGRAM.
I I JUST WANT TO PROVIDE YOU A
UP THE ON OF A FEW DEVELOPMENTS.
OF ON THE PROGRAMS AND I WILL
START WITH DOCTOR LEGAL SERVICES
SAID IT WAS GREAT TO SEE A
DOCUMENTED YOU'VE COME UP AND
SPEAK ABOUT.
HER EXPERIENCE SO AS YOU KNOW.
THERE'S A TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION FOR DOCTOR LEGAL
SERVICES AND.
EARLIER THIS WEEK THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ANNOUNCED THAT SINCE THE
INJUNCTION THERE HAD BEEN THIRTY
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS WHO. HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO RENEW THEIR THEIR
DOCTORS STATUS.
I AM PLEASED TO SAY THAT SINCE
WE PRODUCE THE REPORT.
NOW THERE HAVE BEEN FIVE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THAT HAVE
BEEN USED FOR DOC LEGAL SERVICES
THAT'S NINE HER THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN IN ONE MONTH ALONE. WITH A
SIT OVER SIX THOUSAND OF THOSE.
DOT OVER SIX THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS WERE ABLE TO RENEW
THEIR DHAKA LEGAL SERVICES IN
OVER THIRTY THREE HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS. WERE ASSISTED WITH
A DOCTOR RENEWAL FEES.
.
THE UNACCOMPANIED UNDOCUMENTED
MINORS PROGRAM I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT WE EX BACKS IF IF WE TAKE
THE AVERAGE OF THE ARRIVALS TO
DATE WE EXPECT ABOUT FORTY FIVE
HUNDRED. ARRIVALS OF
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS AND INTO
CALIFORNIA WE CURRENTLY SERVE
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
INDIVIDUALS WITH THAT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S ALLOCATED
SO THAT'S JUST A LITTLE BIT
UNDER TEN PERCENT. OF THE OF THE
ARRIVALS. AND.
.
I WANT TO TURN TO THE
IMMIGRATION SERVICES FUNDING
PROGRAM WHICH IS IN ITS THIRD
YEAR FUNDING AND THIS YEAR HAS
SEEN TREMENDOUS ACTIVITY.
IN THE FIRST YEAR FUNDING WE
FUNDED SIXTY TWO ORGANIZATIONS
THAT THIS YEAR WE HAVE FUNDED
NINETY TWO ORGANIZATIONS. AND
THE FUNDING HAS INCREASED OVER
THE LIFE OF THE PROGRAM FOR
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO A
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. THIS
YEAR ALONE THE PROGRAM.
THE PROGRAM DEVELOPED A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT PROGRAM ELEMENTS
ONE OF THEM IS REMOVAL THE FUNDS
FUNDING OUT OF THE FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ROUGHLY THIRTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS OF THE FUNDS
WERE ALLOCATED TO REMOVAL
DEFENSE. INCLUDING A FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THERE'S A SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
BUILDING THE CAPACITY OF THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER THROUGHOUT THE
STATE TO MORE ADEQUATELY ADVICE
IMMIGRANTS OF. OF THE
CONSEQUENCES OF OF ANY CRIMINAL
ACTIONS AGAINST THEM. THERE'S A
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
INVESTMENT SERVICES FOR DEPORTED
VETERANS AND YOU MAY YOU
PROBABLY ARE AWARE THAT THE
GOVERNOR JUST RECENTLY PARDONED
A NUMBER OF OF OF THAT EVENTS IN
THAT THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
VETERANS WHO HAVE ACTUALLY. BEEN
ABLE TO RETURN TO THE STATE AND
SO WE'RE VERY.
FORTUNATE TO HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
ROLL OUT THAT ELEMENT OF THE
PROGRAM AS WELL. AND.
BEFORE THE FIRST TIME ALSO
FUNDING POST CONVICTION RELIEF
SERVICES.
TWO THREE ORGANIZATIONS ONE AN
ORANGE COUNTY ONE IN THE BAY
AREA THIS ISN'T A VERY AND
DEVELOPED AREA.
OF PRACTICE AND ONE WHERE WE
HOPE TO SEE MORE CAPACITY
DEVELOPED AND FINALLY AS A AS A
NOTED EARLIER.
.
WHEN.
ONE OF THE ADMINISTRATION THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCED
THE END OF THE TPS PROGRAM UP
THERE WAS A VERY SHORT WINDOW OF
TIME FOR RE REGISTRATION FOR.
TPS HOLDERS FROM OUTSIDE THE
DOOR THERE ARE ROUGHLY FIFTY
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS WITH TPS.
FROM OUTSIDE THE DOOR IN
CALIFORNIA WITH ROUGHLY FIFTY
THOUSAND US CITIZEN CHILDREN AND
SO. OF WE WERE. ABLE TO
COORDINATE WITH SERVICE
PROVIDERS WHO SPECIALIZE IN THIS
AS IN THIS AREA TO TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT
OF THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF THAT POPULATION COULD
BE SERVED.
AND THEN OF FINALLY IN TERMS OF
PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT.
THIS YEAR.
WE.
CHEMICALLY WAIT MENTIONED THAT
YOU KNOW CAL FRESH'S EFFORTS
ROUNDS AROUND DISASTER RELIEF
OUT WE WERE ABLE TO COORDINATE.
AND A VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
COORDINATION WITH WITH CAL FRESH
WERE TO BE IN ORDER TO REACH OUT
TO IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS. AND
ALSO.
DEVELOPED A STANDALONE PROGRAM
FOR RULED OUT A STANDALONE
PROGRAM FOR DISASTER RELIEF
SERVICES FOR FOR IT FOR
IMMIGRANTS AFFECTED BY THE WILD
WILD FIRES AND CINNAMON OUT BUT
IN OTHER AREAS OF NORTHERN.
CALIFORNIA.
.
ALL BALK ALL CONCLUDE BY BY BY
SHARING SOME OF THE SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES OF
THE PROGRAM SO. I THINK THAT THE
HEADLINES OF THE LAST WEEK ALONE
ARE ILLUSTRATIVE OF THE MAIN
CHALLENGES OF THE PROGRAM
THERE'S A. PRONOUNCEMENT ON
FEDERAL LAW AND POLICY IT SEEMS
LIKE EVERY DAY SOMETIMES TWICE A
DAY. AND THAT CREATES A STRAIN
ON THE ON THE SERVICE PROVIDERS
WHO ARE ON THE GROUND AND TRIED
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF OF THE OF
THE. THAT THE NEW POLICY
PRONOUNCEMENTS CREATE. AND ALSO.
.
IT ALSO GENERATES
I'VE ALONG LIST OF PRIORITIES
AND IT BECOMES REALLY DIFFICULT
TO CHOOSE AMONGST THOSE
PRIORITIES WHETHER IT'S TPS
HOLDERS OR DHAKA OR ASYLUM
SEEKERS OR CHILDREN OR THE API
COMMUNITY. THEY'RE ALL
EXTRAORDINARILY COMPELLING
DEMANDS AND THERE'S THERE'S A
LOT MORE NEED. THAN CAN
CURRENTLY BE MATT EITHER WITH
THE FUNDING LEVELS OR FRANKLY
WITH THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S
AVAILABLE AND I THINK THE.
THE THE PROGRAM RUNS INTO THE
SAME CONCERNS THAT ANY PROGRAM
THAT THE MINISTER THROUGH A CBO
INFRASTRUCTURE RUNS INTO THAT
THERE ARE LONG STANDING LEGACY
ISSUES AROUND.
AROUND CAPACITY IN MANY AREAS
OF THE PARTICULARLY INLAND
CALIFORNIA LAKE THE NORTH
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SURPRISINGLY AND I
MENTIONED THIS LAST YEAR THE
CENTRAL COAST AND ALSO THAT. THE
INLAND EMPIRE SO THE DEPARTMENT
HOUSE.
WHERE POSSIBLE WORKED VERY
CLOSELY AND TRY TO IDENTIFY
OPPORTUNITIES TO EXPAND CAPACITY
IN REGIONS THAT ARE UNDERSERVED
AND ALSO FOR POPULATIONS THAT
ARE UNDERSERVED LIKE THE API
POPULATION? AND SO I WILL I WILL
LEAVE IT AT THAT AND I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THE. NEXT WITHIN A FULL.
GOOD EVENING I'M I HAVE TO SAY
IT'S IT'S PRETTY AMAZING TO SIT
HERE THIRTY YEARS LATER AND SEE
THE ROBUST INVESTMENT AND WORK
THAT IS HAPPENING UNDER THE
PROGRAM.
WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR
HONORING HIS COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE FUNDING THE PROGRAM AT
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE CURRENT FISCAL YEAR AND
DEEPLY APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO WORK. WITH VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS AND CREATING
IMPLEMENTING THIS HYBRID MODEL
TO PROTECT CALIFORNIANS ARE
STATE AGAINST DEVASTATING
DEPORTATIONS AS THE DEPARTMENT
MENTIONED THE PROGRAM HAS
RESPONDED TO A NUMBER OF
CHANGING IMMIGRATION POLICIES
SINCE ITS INCEPTION. AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND IT IS CRITICAL THAT
THE PROGRAM MAINTAIN ITS LEVEL
FUNDING TO ALLOW FOR IT TO
RESPOND TO THE GROWING ATTACKS
ON IMMIGRANTS.
CONTRACTORS ARE FIGHTING EVERY
DAY TO PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES
TO REPRESENTATION FOR
IMMIGRATION SERVICES AND
EVERYDAY THAT FIGHT INTENSIFIES
ATTACKS ANDHAKA ATTACKS ON DP
TPS. ATTACKS ON DUE PROCESS IN
IMMIGRATION COURT JUST THIS PAST
WEEK THE ADMINISTRATION
ANNOUNCED.
THEIR INTENTION TO ESTABLISH
QUOTAS FOR IMMIGRATION JUDGES SO
THAT THEY CAN MOVE OUR CASES
MORE QUICKLY.
YOU KNOW AND WE CLIENTS WOULD
PAY THE PRICE OF DUE PROCESS
THROUGH THAT.
AND SO YOU KNOW THIS LEVEL
INVESTMENT AS.
CHAIRED WILL NOT REACH ALL LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS IN NEED OF
IMMIGRATION SERVICES AND THERE
ARE EXISTING ELIGIBILITY RULES
THAT LIMIT THE UNIVERSALITY OF
LEGAL REPRESENTATION. BUT IT WAS
A CRITICAL AND POWERFUL STEP FOR
A STATE TO CONNECT CALIFORNIANS
TO RELIEF FROM DEPORTATION WE
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT WHILE WE
ALSO LEARNED ABOUT THE
SUCCESSFUL OUTCOMES OF THIS
YEAR'S.
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
INVESTMENT AND ALSO ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
IDENTIFIED THROUGH THE SITE
VISITS INCLUDING HOW WE CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT UNDOCUMENTED ASIAN
POPULATION.
HOW WE CONTINUE TO REDUCE
FINANCIAL BARRIERS TO
DEPORTATION AND THE CAPACITY?
ISSUES THAT DEPARTMENT HAS
RELATED WITH REGARD TO VARIOUS
REGIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THAT NEED SUPPORT THAT NEED
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE AND ARE
MAKING EFFORTS.
TO GET THERE BY QUITE FRANKLY
THE NEED TO SO SIGNIFICANT SO WE
KNOW THAT HE PETITIONS WREAK
HAVOC ON OUR COMMUNITIES IN OUR
STATE AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE CONTINUED INVESTMENT AND THE
REALLY THOUGHTFUL EFFORTS. TO
ENSURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS THESE BARRIERS AND
CHALLENGES THANK YOU THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HELLO
INCLUDES.
SEEING NONE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENTS ON ISSUE FIFTEEN.
DANIEL SHARP WITH THE CENTRAL
AMERICAN RESOURCE CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE PROPOSAL.
AND I I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE.
THAT MS RUIZ AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES FOR ITS
THOUGHTFUL I IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS PROGRAM ITS DEEP COMMITMENT
TO MAKING THE PROGRAM WORK IN
BECOME EFFECTIVE AFTER JUST
THREE YEARS.
THIS IS REALLY TRANSFORMED THE
CAPACITY TO SERVE IMMIGRANTS IN
COMMUNITIES THAT PREVIOUSLY HAD
NO IN IN MANY CASES HAD NO
LEGITIMATE COMPETENT IMMIGRATION
LEGAL SERVICE PROVIDER.
ORGANIZATION OPENED AND HIS NOW
SUSTAIN AN OFFICE IN THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY A HUGE
GEOGRAPHIC AREA WITH A LARGE
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY THAT WHERE
IMMIGRATION FRAUD HAS BEEN
RAMPANT AND. THAT IS LARGELY
THANKS TO THIS PROGRAM SO THANK
YOU AND I HEARD YOUR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR FULL FUNDING.
GOOD EVENING MEMBERS LEASE
ORTEGA'S WITH THE CLOCK A GROUP
HERE ON BEHALF OF CATHOLIC
CHARITIES. AND HAVE THE
CONFERENCE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THE COMMAND.
EVENING GABRIEL GARCIA WITH THE
SOUTHEAST ASIA RESOURCE ACTION
CENTER A REALLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
LEVEL OF FUNDING BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS US TO REACH OUT TO ASIAN
AMERICAN.
PACIFIC HONOR COMMUNITIES AROUND
THE STATE WHO HISTORICALLY HAVE
NOT BEEN OUT REACHED TO WHO
HISTORICALLY HAVE NOT RECEIVED
EDUCATION ON IMMIGRATION
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
THEM.
WITH THIS LEVEL OF FUNDING WE
HAVE SEEN THAT ORGANIZATIONS ARE
ACTUALLY ABLE TO BUILD WITH
THESE API COMMUNITIES AND GET
THEM THE RESOURCES THAT THEY
NEED. THANK YOU SIR.
ARE HAVING A BOX WITH THE
KITCHEN IMAGE FOUNDATION I WANNA
COMMAND OF THE ENGLISH UNITS AS
TEDIOUS AS.
FOR LEAD TO BE THE.
WORKING WITH ORGANIZATIONS UP
AND NO WIND OF THE COAL.
.
ISSUE WITH THE COURTS AND.
JAMMING NINTH OCCM ABOUT OUR
ORGANIZATION WAS ABLE TO ASSIST.
HUNDRED NEEDY INDIVIDUALS
WITHIN THREE WEEKS SO THAT WAS
REALLY A. GOOD FOR OUR BUCK
RECIPIENTS.
WE WERE ABLE TO. HELP THEM WITH
THE FOR HIRE NINETY FIVE SO.
SOME OF THEM ARE HERE TO THEM
WILL TESTIFY TO THE.
GOOD AFTERNOON PREMATURE AT
SIREN SERVICES IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
EDUCATION NETWORKING WHERE
CONTRACTORS CDS HAS SAT THROUGH
THE EYES OF FUNDING STRONGLY
SUPPORT. BY THE FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THIS PROGRAM
IF IT WEREN'T FOR THE WORK OF
CDSS ABOUT WORK FOR THIS FUNDING
OUT WE WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO DO
WHAT WE DO NOW WHICH IS TO HOLD
FREE WEEKLY DHAKA CLINICS.
IN THE BAY AREA WE HOST FREE
DEPORTATION DEFENSE CLINICS
I IN THE BAY AREA LEGAL
CONSULTATIONS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND OF COURSE PROVIDE
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH TO
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHICH IS
NEEDED NOW MORE THAN EVER.
JUST ONE EXAMPLE THAT I WOULD
SHARE IS THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE
ATTORNEYS ARE ON BOARD WITH OUR
ORGANIZATION WHO ARE DOING
DEPORTATION DEFENSE WORK AND NOW
WITH THE SUPPORT THEY'VE BEEN
ABLE TO GO TO THE DETENTION
CENTER IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
AND TO BE ABLE TO SEE CLIENTS
AND THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO GET
THEM OUT ON BOND AND ACTUALLY
REPRESENT THEM IN IMMIGRATION
COURT. AND SO BEING ABLE TO HAVE
THE SUPPORT IS IS VITAL FOR US
SO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AT THE
ALLOCATION FOR US TO CONTINUE
THIS WORK THINKING.
THE GAME.
DIDN'T SLEEP MEDINA BEHALF OF
MALT LEFT THE MEXICAN AMERICAN
LEGAL DEFENSE AND EDUCATIONAL
FUND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL. I'M IT'S JUST GREAT TO
HEAR OF ALL THE WORK THAT'S
BEING DONE IN CALIFORNIA TO FORM
IMMIGRATION ATTORNEYS FORMER
DETENTION ATTORNEY. IT'S REALLY
CRITICAL THAT THOSE CLIENTS GET
SERVICES AT THE DETENTION
CENTERS THERE'S ICE TO PRACTICE
IN WASHINGTON STATE AND. I WANT
TO TELL YOU THAT AS AN ATTORNEY
WAS OFTEN ME HUMPING THOSE
CLIENTS WERE. GATHERING EVIDENCE
AND MAKING SURE THAT THEY GET
OUT ON BOND AND GET REPRESENT
ITSELF UP SERVICES THAT ARE
PROVIDED ARE EXTREMELY CRITICAL
FOR THOSE OXYGEN BEING DETAINED.
WE CAN.
CHRIS FOR SUCH AS POLICY
ADVOCATE WHICH ALL OF THE
COALITION OR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTSOFFERS ON THE THINK THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE DEPARTMENT
HAS BEEN GREAT. ANYTIME I'VE
EVER HAD A NEED OR ANYTHING OF
THAT NATURE OF ALWAYS BEEN VERY
RECEPTIVE TO OUR SORRY CLASS
EYES AMONG CALIFORNIA DANTE
SERVIN. ARE HAVING LEGAL SERVICE
DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT THE LOS
ANGELES REGION AND SERVING
FAMILIES ARE AS FAR AS A CENTRAL
VALLEY AND THEN PART OF THE HIGH
DESERT AS WELL. ITEM WE KNOW
THAT THE FORTY FIVE MILLION
NEEDS CONTINUE AND HASTA OB
DURING THESE CRITICAL TIMES
ESPECIALLY AS WE SEE ATTACKS
FROM THE WASHINGTON DCA ARM. ARE
AS THOSE MENTIONED EARLIER ARE
OUT FOR DIFFERENT REASONS HAVING
A DIFFERENT TIMES PALM. ISLAND
TO INSURE THAT THE EDUCATION IS
ALSO ARE COMING ABOUT BECAUSE WE
THINK THAT'S NOT ONE OF THE MORE
CRITICAL ASPECTS OF ONE
CALIFORNIA.
GOOD EVENING IT'S NOW AFTER SIX
PM.
NO AYE BOTTOMLESS YEARLY
FOUNDATION
I'M GLAD TO BE HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS PROPOSAL. WE ONE
APPRECIATE THE THE GOVERNOR THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THIS INVESTMENT
WE WANT TO THANK YOU THAT
DEPARTMENTS DSS IN THE
DIRECTORIES.
FOR THEIR SUPPORT AND I'M GOING.
THROUGHOUT THE THE GRANT
PROCESSES AND THEN
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROGRAM.
SPECIFICALLY THIS IS FUNDING IS
VERY VITAL TO UNDERSERVED
MARGINALIZE REGIONS.
WE HAVE CLIENTS WHO HAVE
BENEFITED FROM THIS QUALITY
EFFECTIVE LEGAL SERVICES THAT'S
FREE. AND THEY'VE GIVEN US THEIR
APPRECIATION AND THANKS TO.
STATE AND THE DEPARTMENT FOR
PROVIDING THE SERVICES SO WE
CONTINUE TO LOOK FORWARD THIS
ONGOING INVESTMENT THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING I'M DAHLE CAN
NATIONAL FROM THE IMMIGRANT
LEGAL RESOURCE CENTER A
NONPROFIT BASED IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND ONE OF THE LEGAL TRAINING
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS WE WANT TO THANK THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH. ON CDS
ESPECIALLY DIRECTOR RUIZ AND HER
STAFF.
IN OUR ROLE AS A LEGAL TRAINING
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDER WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO GO
ALL OVER THE STATE PROVIDE
TRAININGS IT'S ACTUALLY A ROLE
WE PLAY FOR ALMOST FORTY YEARS.
DURING THAT TIME WE WOULD OFTEN
VISIT PLACES WHERE THERE WERE IT
WAS A LOT OF POTENTIAL BUT TOO
FEW RESOURCES. WITH THIS FUNDING
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS THE ABILITY
FOR THOSE REGIONS AND
ORGANIZATIONS IN THOSE REGIONS
TO BLOSSOM TO ACTUALLY PROVIDE
THE EDUCATION AND OUTREACH AND
LEGAL SERVICES THAT ARE SO
CRITICAL TO COMMUNITIES THERE.
SO WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
INVESTMENT IN THESE
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
ESPECIALLY IN THOSE UNDER
RESOURCE AREAS AND APPRECIATE
YOUR CONTINUING SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
I MISTER CHAIR MY CAROL WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY.
AND WE TO SUPPORT THIS.
THIS THE FUNDING THAT'S BEEN
REQUESTED APPROVED HERE ARMED
AND STANDING WITH OUR OUR
COLLEGE IN IMMIGRATION COMMUTING
ON THIS VITAL ISSUE.
PLAYING GRAM ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
WHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL WE THINK THE PROGRAM.
IS TRULY UNIQUE AND THE BRASS OF
SERVICES THAT COVERS THAT
IMMIGRANTS NEED IN THE SAY AND
THE SCOPE OF THE STATE THAT IT
REACHES AND WE CONTINUE. TO
SUPPORT A STRONG INVESTMENT HERE
AGAIN IN THIS BUDGET THANK YOU
THINKING.
CHRYSALIS PLACENTA VIOLATED THE
CHRISTIAN COLLABORATIVE ONE
CALIFORNIA FUNDING REALLY
DESERVES OUR SUPPORT HAS MADE A
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY OFFERING SERVICES
BY LEGAL SERVICE PROVIDERS THAT
ARE FREE OFCHARGE. AND ALSO
DOING AWAY WITH THE THREAT OF
MULTI JUST ANOTHER. POP PEOPLE
WHO PROVIDE SERVICES AND THEN
GREW IN PEOPLE'S LIVES SO THIS
HAS BEEN A VERY VALUABLE
CONTRIBUTION TO THE IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
WINDHORST THE COMPUTER FUNDING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SONYA
COME FROM FRESNO CALIFORNIA.
I ONE OF PAINT A PICTURE FOR
YOU.
.
PICTURES SELF A SENIOR IN HIGH
SCHOOL SOME NEW THE EXTREME
DETAIL OF WHAT COLLEGE THEY WERE
ATTENDING HOW THEY WERE PAYING
FOR AND HOW TO GET THERE. HOUSE
ONE OF THOSE WHO WAS WHO HAD AN
EXTREME ENTHUSIASM TO HAVE THAT
PLAN.
AS FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
ATTENDANCE AND DEFINED BY
LIMITATIONS OF DECISIONS I DID
AND HOW.
.
STATED BY SINGLE DOCUMET MY
BIRTH CERTIFICATE THAT STATES A
DIFFERENT LOCATION MEXICO. FROM
WHAT I CALL HOME THE U. S. I WAS
OVERWHELMED WITH WHAT TO DO.
QUIEN TODAY'S A PRODUCT OF THIS
BEAUTIFUL STRUGGLE.
I AM A FULL TIME EMPLOYEE AND
STUDENT
GRADUATING IN MAINE DOUBLE
MAJORING IN BUSINESS IN SPANISH.
I AM FAMILY ORIENTED HARDWORKING
INDEPENDENT DOCTOR RECIPIENT.
AND THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS LIKE ME.
PROGRAMS LIKE FUNDING FOR LEGAL
DEFENSE TO KEEP FAMILIES
TOGETHER AND OTHER OPPORTUNITIES
LIKE THIS ARE WHAT CONTRIBUTE TO
OTHER HUMAN BEINGS LIKE ME.
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE HOW MANY MORE
SUCCESS STORIES THERE WOULD BE
OF THOSE OPPORTUNITIES WERE
CREATED INSTEAD OF BARRIERS FOR
THOSE WHO CALL THIS LAND OF
OPPORTUNITY. HOME.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I AM
IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS.
I CAME.
HI MY NAME IS SELENA I AM I AM
ALSO A DOCTOR WE SEE PAN AND I
WAS.
PART OF THIS LEGAL FREE SERVICE
THAT HELPED ME COME OUT OF THE
SHADOWS THIS WHILE.
I COME ALONG WITH FAMILIES OF
EIGHT AND I WORKED IN THE FIELDS
OF PRIOR TO THIS. NOW LIKE
HAPPEN EDUCATION AND A FLL TIME
AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ALL BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS
AND.
AND YOU KNOW WILL COME UP THAT
WE WERE QUITE SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
LAST YEAR AND WILL CONTINUE TO
BE.
I'M ONE OF THE QUESTIONS THOUGH
IS IN LIGHT OF THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION THAT SEEMS AS IF
THEY'RE CHANGING POLICIES.
ON A MOMENT'S NOTICE HOW
RESPONSIVE IS THE ONE CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM TO MEET THE CHANGING
DEMAND.
AND MORE EXPLICITLY I'M REALLY
LOOKING AT THE I NINE AUDITS
THAT. HAPPENED IN MY BACKYARD.
AND THE FACT THAT WE REACHED
CAPACITY WITHIN ONE MONTH FOR
OUR ABILITY TO.
HELP TO PROVIDE DEFENSE AND AM
WONDERING IF THERE ARE OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE MAY HAVE.
TO HELP MEET THIS INCREASING.
NEED.
WITH THAT THE EXISTING.
FUNDING THAT'S AVAILABLE ON IT
EXISTING STATUTORY STRUCTURE.
I BELIEVE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HAS MADE EVERY EFFORT TO BE AS
RESPONSIVE AS AS POSSIBLE WITH
THAT WITH THE PROGRAM.
TO MEET THE NEEDS AND.
WERE ABLE TO ACHIEVE THAT
THROUGH. VERY CLOSE COORDINATION
AND COLLABORATION AND
COMMUNICATION WITH WITH THAT
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS ON THE
GROUND IN EVERY YEAR WITH A NEW
ROUND OF FUNDING WE TRY TO TAKE
A STEP BACK TO LOOK AT WHERE THE
GAPS IN SERVICES. ARE BUT THERE
ARE REALLY LEGITIMATE ISSUES
AROUND PRIORITIZING.
VERY COMPELLING.
CASES WHETHER IT'S YOU KNOW
FUNDING FOR DETAINED INDIVIDUALS
OR OR OR OR FUNDING FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN WHO THE IMMIGRATION
COURTS AS THEY CAN DEFEND
THEMSELVES OR. OR OR FUNDING FOR
TPS HOLDERS ARE ASYLUM SEEKERS.
THERE ARE REAL CHALLENGING.
DECISIONS TO BE MADE ABOUT
WHERE PRIORITY SHOULD SHOULD BE.
.
I WOULD SAY THAT THE DEPARTMENT
ALSO TRIES TO COORDINATE CLOSELY
WITH THE SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO
STAY WITH THEN.
THEIR AREAS OF EXPERTISE SO
EVEN WHEN THEY'RE AT THERE IS A
NEED IN THE COMMUNITY YOU MAY
HAVE A SERVICE PROVIDER THAT
SPECIALIZES IN DHAKA FOR EXAMPLE
OR NATURALIZATION SERVICES. AND
THEY'RE VERY DIFFERENT HE SAYS
THEY'RE IT IT'S A VERY
DIFFERENT.
PROGRAM AREA AND SO THEY'RE NOT
ALWAYS ABLE TO TO SHIFT
PRIORITIES AND AND.
WE WOULD THINK IT WOULD BE
UNWORKABLE TO MAKE THOSE AMOUNTS
OF THEM.
AND I WOULD I WOULD JUST ADD TO
THAT AND SAY THAT THEIR.
ARE STRONG EXISTING STATE
PROTECTIONS AROUND THE WAYS THAT
EMPLOYERS SOMETIMES TARGET THEIR
IMMIGRANT WORKERS AND A REALLY
HIGH LATE THAT.
IT YOU KNOW PART OF THAT I
THINK IS MAKING SURE THE
ENFORCEMENT IS AVAILABLE AND
PREPARED TO RESPOND ESPECIALLY
AT A LOCAL LEVEL WITH REGARDS
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER IN HER
STYLE.
I GUESS THE CONCERN AND WHY I
BROUGHT IT UP AS WE WENT FROM
THIRTY MILLION TO FORTY FIVE
MILLION AND YET WE WERE TOLD THE
CAPACITY OF OUR LOCAL REGION.
WAS SET FROM THE YEAR PRIOR THAT
IT HAD NOT CHANGED WITH THE
INCREASE IN FUNDING. I WOULD
HAVE THOUGHT THAT IT LINEARLY
INCREASED AS FUNDING INCREASED
BUT THAT DIDN'T SEEM TO BE THE
CASE AND SO. I'M JUST TRYING TO
REALLY DO AGAIN AS TIMES CHANGE.
WHAT WE FUND NEEDS TO ALSO BE
REFLECTIVE OF WHAT OUR CURRENT
CHALLENGES ARE INTO JUST WANTED
TO BRING THAT FORWARD?
I THINK THAT THE BUILDING
CAPACITY IS BOTH A FUNCTION OF
OF FUNDING AND TIME.
IT TAKES ORGANIZATIONS TIME TO
BE ABLE TO.
HIGHER STOCK.
DEVELOP THE ADMINISTRATIVE
SYSTEMS THAT ARE REQUIRED FOR
SOMETIME VERY COMPLEX CASES ON.
AND.
DEVELOPING THE SYSTEMS FOR
EXAMPLE FOR A LEGAL PRACTICE.
THAT IS THAT IT'S THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT.
ORGANIZATIONS CAN THAT HAPPEN
HOW THE PRIOR EXPERIENCE CAN
PIVOT TO AND SOMETIMES EVEN EVEN
A YEAR.
SO.
I DON'T KNOW THAT WE CAN SAY
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE A
PERFECT CORRESPONDENCE BETWEEN
INCREASE IN FUNDING AND
INCREASED ORGANIZATIONAL
CAPACITY. THERE ARE AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER I BELIEVE LIKE
LONGSTANDING DEEP. HAVE LEGACY
ISSUES AROUND FUNDINGS FORCED A
CBO INFRASTRUCTURE AND
UNDERSERVED AREAS AND SO WHERE
POSSIBLE THE DEPARTMENT HAS
TRIED TO WORK WITH OTHER
PARTNERS. WHO CAN FOCUS ON
HELPING THOSE ORGANIZATIONS
BUILD?
ORGANIZATIONAL CAPACITY SO THAT
THEY ARE ABLE TO DELIVER ON
SERVICES THAT CAN BE VERY
COMPLEX AND VERY DEMANDING THEY
NEED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
EXPERTISE AND MEET THE CRITERIA
THE ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA FOR
FUNDING. AND THERE'S ALSO ALL
THE THINGS WE DON'T TALK ABOUT
RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO ADMINISTER.
STATE FUNDING AND ITSELF
REQUIRES A CERTAIN LEVEL OF OF
EXPERTISE WERE FOR FOR CBO AN
EXPERIENCE.
WHO AM I THINK WE'LL HEAR ABOUT
THIS IN THE NEXT ITEM BUT REALLY
WANTED TO? BRING UP SIMILAR TO
IN MEDICINE THERE ARE CERTAIN
PART OF OUR STATE WHERE WE LACK
THE APPROPRIATE INFRASTRUCTURE
TO DEAL WITH OUR CURRENT
CHALLENGES.
AND.
ARE REALLY STRUGGLING WITH HOW
WE BUILD THAT CAPACITY LONG TERM
AND. I AM LOOKING FORWARD TO
THAT NEXT PROPOSAL AS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO. SEE A
COMPLIMENTARY PACKAGE TO WHAT IS
INCLUDED HERE WITHIN ONE
CALIFORNIA.
SO WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
FIFTEEN OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE SEVENTY
.
GOOD AFTERNOON WITH THE GOODNESS
OF MY* ON THE CHAIR OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY DIFFERENT PERSON
COLLABORATIVE. AND I'M ALSO HERE
STEERING COMMITTEE MEMBER OF THE
FRESNO COUNTY LEGAL DEFENSE
FUND.
I THINK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO.
.
SPEAK HERE AT THIS HEARING ON
BEHALF OF THESE TWO
ORGANIZATIONS THAT REPRESENT THE
TODAY. MY COLLEAGUES WHO ARE
HERE TODAY. AND THOSE WHO ARE
ABLE TO MAKE THE TRIP
SACRAMENTO.
HAVE PRESENTED TO YOU AND TO
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE A FOUR
POINT PROPOSAL BUT IS A CALL FOR
HELP.
YES LIVE MAY BE CLEAR FROM THE
START WE NEED YOUR HELP.
IN PARTICULAR WE NEED YOUR HELP
TO ADDRESS TWO PROBLEMS ONE THE
HISTORICAL NEGLECT OF IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND TO THE THREATS THAT OPPOSED
TO THIS IMMIGRANT FAMILIES BY
THE INCREASED ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS OF IMMIGRATION ACOSTA
CUSTOMS ENFORCEMENT. BETTER
NOTIFIES.
AND WHICH ARE CURRENTLY TAKING
PLACE IN THE REGION.
AS THE RESULT OF THESE PARALLEL
PROPHECIES.
WE ARE WITNESSING THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WHAT CAN BEST BE
DESCRIBED AS A CRISIS SITUATION.
IT IS A CRISIS SITUATION BECAUSE
OF THE FOLLOWING ONE.
WE HAVE A SIZEABLE IMMIGRANT
POPULATION THE TOTALS ABOUT NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND.
PEOPLE IN THE REGION.
THAT IS ENCOMPASSED BY
STANISLAUS CONCURRENT COUNTIES.
IT IS THE REGION WHERE THEY'RE
ABOUT HALF A MILLION CHILDREN
WITH AT LEAST ONE IMMIGRANT
PARENTS.
IT IS A CRISIS OF A FUTURE IT IS
A SITUATION ARE BUT CAN BE THE
SCRIBE IS A CRISIS SITUATION
BECAUSE.
I THE PENSIONS HAVE DOUBLED IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN IN COMPARISON
TO TWENTY SIXTEEN.
ALSO BECAUSE THE PENSIONS IN THE
MONTH OF FEBRUARY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHERE THE HIGHEST OF
ANY MONTHS IN MANY YEARS.
ALSO BECAUSE THE MAJORITY OF THE
TRAINEES DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
LEGAL COUNSEL. AND ARE EASY
TARGETS FOR THE PETITION AND THE
ENSUING BREAKUP OF IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES.
IT IS A CRISIS SITUATION ALSO
BECAUSE THE MAJORITY OF THE
NONPROFIT LEGAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS IN THE REGION. DO NOT
HAVE ATTORNEYS SPECIALIZING
REMOVAL DEFENSE.
ALSO IT IS A SITUATION WHICH
MOST OF THE OF THESE NONPROFIT
LEGAL SERVICE PROVIDERS DO NOT
RECEIVE FUNDING FROM THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FOR REMOVAL
DEFENSE.
THE RECENTLY RELEASED DIRECTORY
OF AGENCIES CONTRACTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES FOR EXAMPLE.
LIST SIXTY TO CONTRACTED
TO. OUT OF SIXTY TWO.
ARE BASED IN THE.
CENTRAL VALLEY.
ONE BASED IN SACRAMENTO ONE AT
BAKERSFIELD.
THE FRESNO COUNTY LEGAL DEFENSE
FUND IS A COMMUNITY DRIVEN
EFFORT THAT HAS BROUGHT
TOGETHER.
LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS AND
COMMUNITY LEADERS CONCERNED WITH
THE INADEQUATE LEGAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT EXIST IN THE
REGION. TO PROTECT IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES BE BROKEN UP BY ICE
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS.
WE HAVE COME TOGETHER BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT IT IS IMMORAL ANY
RATIONAL.
TO REMAIN PASSIVE WHILE
IMMIGRANTS ARE DENIED DUE
PROCESS.
THEREBY DISRUPTING FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITY STABILITY.
CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN IMPORTANT
STEPS TO ASSIST AND PROTECT
IMMIGRANTS.
WE WISH TO EXPAND THESE
PROTECTIONS AND BENEFITS TO
IMMIGRANTS RECITING IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. A REGION THAT
OVER THE YEAR.
OVER THE YEARS HAS BEEN
SUBJECTED TO NEGLECT AND
RECEIVED INADEQUATE INVESTMENT
FROM FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU IS THAT CALL
FOR HELP.
BUT ALSO A DOCUMENT WITH IDEAS
AND POSSIBLE SOLUTIONS
TO BE ONGOING NEGLECT OF THE
INTEREST RIGHTS AND CONCERNS OF
IMMIGRANTS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
IT IS AN INITIAL EFFORT ON OUR
PART.
THAT REQUIRES YOUR LEGISLATIVE
SUPPORT AND THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE OF YOUR STAFF TO MAKE
IT ACTIONABLE.
WE'RE PROPOSING ONE.
SUPPORT FOR THE PARTITION
DEFENSE FUND THEY WILL PROVIDE
REMOVAL DEFENSE TO ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY TO TWO HUNDRED IMMIGRANTS.
THE ASSISTANCE WILL BE PROVIDED
THREE PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
NONPROFIT LEGAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
WITH BE A A CREDIT THE
REPRESENTATIVES OR.
AND ALSO MAY HAVE ATTORNEYS AND
ALSO REPUTABLE PRIVATE
IMMIGRATION ATTORNEYS.
THIS PROJECT WOULD HAVE THE
ADDED BENEFIT OF PROVIDING
NONPROFIT AGENCIES EXPERIENCE
THE REMOVAL DEFENSE. AND
CONTRIBUTE TO OVERALL REGIONAL
CAPACITY BUILDING.
TO.
A RURAL JUSTICE FELLOWS PROGRAM.
THAT WOULD RECRUIT TRAIN AND
DEPLOY A COHORT OF RECENT LAW
SCHOOL GRADUATES.
THE FELLOWS WOULD BE ASSIGNED TO
NONPROFIT LEGAL SERVICES
AGENCIES IN THE REGION. AND BE
SUPERVISED BY COORDINATING
ATTORNEY.
A SIMILAR AND VERY SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM HAS BEEN CREATED NEW
YORK AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE
CONDITIONS SUCCESS TO ESTABLISH
ONE. ESTABLISHED ONE OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND THEREBY BRING
ABOUT A SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT
INTO LEGAL CAPACITY IN OUR
REGION.
THREE.
A COLLEGE TO LAW SCHOOL PIPELINE
PROJECT.
THE PROJECT WOULD RECRUIT A
COHORT OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
COMPLETED THEIR UNDERGRADUATE
DEGREE. AND ARE INTERESTED IN
ATTENDING LAW SCHOOL.
THEY WILL BE PLACED WITH
NONPROFIT AGENCIES FOR TWO YEAR
PERIOD TRAINED TO OBTAIN BE A
ACCREDITATION AND ASSIST IN THE
DELIVERY OF SERVICES.
THERE WILL BE PROVIDED WITH
SUPPORT TO STUDY FOR THE LSAT
ABBY SUPERVISED BY COORDINATING
ATTORNEY.
AND FOR.
THE CREATION OF A SAMPLE CAN
RALLY IMMIGRATION CAREER
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
THE SIGN TO ATTRACT AND RETAIN
IMMIGRATION ATTORNEYS.
BY OFFERING A LOAN FORGIVENESS
PROGRAM.
SIMILAR TO THAT OFFERED IN SOME
LOCATIONS TO ATTRACT DOCTORS.
THIS PROJECT WOULD HELP ATTRACT
AND RETAIN IMMIGRATION ATTORNEYS
IN A REGION. THAT REQUIRES THE
PRESENCE AND THEIR SERVICES.
HELP US FARM SOLUTIONS TO THE
CRISIS.
SITUATION THAT WE'RE FACING IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
HELP US BUILD THE LEGAL AND
ORGANIZATIONAL CAPACITY.
SERVED ON NINE A THOUSAND
IMMIGRANTS AND HALF A MILLION
CHILDREN.
WITH AN IMMIGRANT PARENT.
HELP US MAKE TO PROCESS THAT
REALITY FOR IMMIGRANTS WERE NOW
BEING DETAINED AND DEPORTED
WITHOUT ACCESS TO COUNSEL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON OF LITTLE
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE OUT
CHAIR SOMETHING MEMORABLE THING
THAT I'M WE'RE NOT.
STATE OFFICIALS ON WILL GET A
COMMUNITY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
HAVE IT ALASKA SOME THE DIRECTOR
OF WINTERS AND SERVICES FOR THE
EDUCATIONAL FOUNDATION.
I'M FRESNO CALIFORNIA ALSO THAT
THE RECIPIENT.
.
TYPES IN THE OFFICIALS
FOUNDATION WOULD COMMUNITIES
ORGANIZATION THAT BEGAN AT TEN
YEARS AGO.
UNITY UP ON DOCUMENTS TO THE
STUDENTS.
DETAINEE CULTURE KEYS EDUCATION
INTO DOESN'T TWELVE WE WITH THE
ENACTMENT OF THE FOR ACTUAL FOR
A CHILD TROUBLE ARRIVES PROGRAM.
WE BEGIN OUR IMMIGRATION CENTER
AND WILL RECEIVE RECOGNITION IN
A GREAT POSITION TO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN.
I WE HAVE HOPE OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND DUCK RECIPIENTS
ATTENDED PARTITION PROTECTION.
WE HAVE REPRESENTING ASSISTED
OVER ONE THOUSAND LEGAL PRIMER
RESIDENTS WITH NATURALIZATION
PROCESS THROTTLE SINCE IT DOES A
FIFTEEN.
FINALLY FROM MY CALIFORNIA HAS
TRICKLE.
TO THIS FAMILIES MANY OF THEM
ARE HERE.
TO THEIR WE HERE SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF MANY UNDOCUMENTED MIX
THAT IS FAMILIES LIVING IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. THESE FAMILIES
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY THE LACK
OF TRAINING GREATER RIPS ITEMS
LACK OF TRUST ENTRANCE.
THE REASON.
ROSSER PUBLISHED BY THE FINAL
JUSTICE TO THEY SINGLEREPORTED
THAT THERE ARE CLEARLY.
NINE HUNDRED TWELVE REDNECKS
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE US.
IN THE VALLEY ITSELF HOWEVER
THEY'RE ONLY LEVEL RECKLESS
ORGANIZATIONS PRIMARILY BECAUSE
TRAIN THE FRESNO COUNTY.
THESE ARE SOME OF THESE AGENCIES
HAVE OXYGEN OFFICER RURAL AREAS
BUT SIR IMMIGRANTS IN A MINIMAL
CAPACITY.
SO MAJOR SEES PLAYED ONE OF
REPRESENTED A TROUBLE TWICE A
MONTH WITH FOUR REPRESENT US ALL
OVER ALL OVER THE A CAMPUS
BURBANK HOSTAGE THE FAMILIES.
SOME OF THESE FAMILIES TROUBLE
TWO TO THREE HOURS TO GET
IMMIGRATION ASSISTANCE SOME OF
THESE FAMILIES MAY HAVE TO LOSE
A DAY OUT OF THE WAR. TO RECEIVE
ASSISTANCE.
WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
VALLEY LACKS LEGAL CAPACITY TO
COVER THIS BIG GRAPHICAL AREA.
SHE'S INDIAN OF THE YEAR WITH
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF CALIFORNIA
THE RECENT WEEKS ON THEIR WAY
TO WORK. TO IMMIGRANT PARENTS ON
THE LAND.
PLUS OUR LIVES WHILE SKIPPING UP
FROM.
ICE AGENTS TO TO FEAR LIVING
SIX ORPHAN AND HOMELESS
CHILDREN.
THE FUNERALS WERE JUST TWO DAYS
AGO.
EARLY FAVORING AT LEAST FORTY
WORKERS FROM BC TEACHERS SINFUL
AND FATHER CALIFORNIA. LAZAR
JOBS AFTER FAILED FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION AGENTS BEGAN I NINE
OUT ITS BY CHECKING EMPLOYEE
RECORDS.
SEARCHING FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
LEGALLY ALLOWED TO WORK IN THE
UNITED STATES AND STONE PANIC.
THAT RESONATED THROUGHOUT THE
BALLOT.
OVER THE PAST FEW DAYS WE HAVE
MADE WITH MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE ADVOCATING FOR MORE
RESOURCE TO THE VALLEY. WE NEED
YOUR WITH DESPERATE HELP TO
WREAK MEDIA THE PETITION THE OF
THE FANS RESOURCES TO THE
VALLEY.
WE NEED STRONG LEGAL STRUCTURE
AND CAPACITY BILLION TO THE
EXISTING COMMITMENT TO EXISTING.
PRERACE TRANSITION THAT WE HAVE
BEGUN WITH WITH
ALVIN AND CIVIC ABOUT HOW WE CAN
BUILD THE CAPACITY TO PROVIDE.
TO PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES TO
STOP A COUPLE OF THINGS A COUPLE
OF THINGS TO NOTE SO THAT. MANY
OF THE SERVICE PROVIDERS FROM
THE CENTRAL VALLEY HAVE A NUMBER
OF SUBCONTRACTORS THAT DON'T
APPEAR ON THE LIST SO THAT THAT
LIST IS IS.
DOESN'T IDENTIFY ALL THE
SERVICE PROVIDERS IN MANY OF THE
SERVICE PROVIDERS WHO ARE
SUBCONTRACTORS TO PRIMARY OUR
SUBCONTRACTORS BECAUSE THEY
DON'T YET MEET THE ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA FOR. THE STATUTORY
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA WHICH IS
ONE FACTOR THAT HAS.
PREVENTED SOME ORGANIZATIONS
FROM FROM.
FROM OF RECEIVING A FUNDING
DIRECTLY FROM THAT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT BUT IN ALL INSTANCES
WHEN THE DEPARTMENT IS
REVIEWING.
APPLICATIONS THROUGH THE
COMPETITIVE PROCESS WE'RE VERY
MINDFUL OF THE AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE THEIR.
WHERE WHERE THERE ARE LIMITED
SERVICES AND AND REALLY TRY TO
PRIORITIZE THOSE AREAS FOR
FUNDING?
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
LA A.
WE ARE ALSO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE'RE STILL REVIEWING
AND CONSIDERING THIS PROPOSAL WE
APPRECIATE THE PROPONENTS
MEANING WITH US THAT TO.
GIVE US SOME MORE FEEDBACK AND
INFORMATION ABOUT THE PROPOSAL
TO THE EXTENT OF THEIR TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE ON THIS WE WOULD.
SIMILAR TO OTHER ADVOCATE
PROPOSAL SUGGESTS THAT THEY
WOULD BE OF SOME FUNDING FOR
STATE RESOURCES TO MASTER THE
PROGRAM AND POTENTIALLY SOME
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR THOSE
FUNDS.
THANK YOU.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
SEVENTEEN.
GOOD EVENING AGAIN I'M SALLY
KENOSHA FROM IMMIGRANT LEGAL
RESOURCE CENTER.
IN THE PAST FEW YEARS WITH
SUPPORT FROM CDSS AND
IMMIGRATION SERVICES FUNDING
PROGRAM WE'VE REALLY BEEN ABLE
TO OBSERVE INSPIRING GROWTH IN
CAPACITY IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
HOWEVER THE GROWTH AS INSPIRING
AS IT HAS BEEN IS TINY COMPARED
TO THE CAPACITY IN MORE URBAN
AREAS.
AND AS WELL AS
TINY COMPARED TO THE CRITICAL
NEED IN THE GREAT NEED IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SO WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF ON CONSIDERATION OF
ANY PROPOSAL THAT COULD.
ADD FUNDING AND SUPPORT TO
IMMIGRATION SERVICES FUNDING AS
WELL AS CONSIDER CREATIVE
OPTIONS AND SOLUTIONS FOR THE
UNIQUE CHALLENGES OF THE REGION
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ONE.
I'M HERE REPRESENTING OUR
DREAMERS AND DHAKA. RECIPIENTS
LIES JUST LIKE MYSELF THINGS TO
DHAKA AYE AND I NOW HAVE A JOB
WHICH WILL HELP ME TO OBTAIN
INCLUDED DICTATION. I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT TO ALLOCATE MORE FUNDING
FOR THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHICH
WILL GIVE US ACCESS. TO MORE
RESOURCES LAWYERS AND OTHER
PROGRAMS FOR ALL CHAMBERS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY CLUB ISSUE BASED
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME THE APART A GREAT LOS
I'M ACOSTA NUMBER SUCH COLLEGE
STUDYING CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
I'M CURRENTLY IN THE POLICE
ACADEMY.
ON FEBRUARY TWENTY A MY FATHER
WAS TAKEN BY ICE AROUND EIGHT AM
BALL MY TWELVE YEAR OLD LITTLE
BROTHER FLUSHED EVERYTHING.
MY LITTLE BROTHER WAS SCARED AND
SAD THAT THEY WERE TAKING HIM.
I WAY.
AND HE WOULD AND THEN HE WOKE ME
UP AND WENT TO HIS ROOM TO HIDE
I HAD JUST GOTTEN HOME FROM WORK
SO I WAS SLEEPING WHEN IT ALL
STARTED FOR.
WE ALL COOPERATE WITH OFFICERS
AND IT TOOK HIM AWAY FROM US.
MY DAD IS A HARD WORKING MAN
EVERYTHING WE HAVE IS THINGS TO
HIM AND HAS AND HE'S ALWAYS BEEN
THERE FOR US. WHEN WE NEEDED
HIM.
US EMOTIONALLY AND FINANCIALLY
BECAUSE WE ARE A LOW INCOME
FAMILY AND THAT'S WHY WE ARE
HERE TO THE ASKING FOR LEGAL
DEFENSE FUNDS BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO PAY FOR LEGAL
REPRESENTATION ON OUR OWN. THANK
YOU.
I.
GO THEM THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY
NAME AS ONE.
THAT PERSON THEN THE LESS
FAMILIAR AS ADVICE IN PLAN.
CAMPESINOS CANNELLA DOES.
I'M AS A KASA.
WAS THE ONLY THEM AS ONE AND ONE
THAT I REALLY.
IT'S I WAS IMMIGRANT AS INNOCENT
MOMENTS.
I REPRESENTING OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. REPRESENTING
FARMWORKERS.
STAY AT HOME MOMS AND SOME OF
THEM MOST HARDWORKING
INDIVIDUALS BUT SOME OF THEM
MOST VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS AS
WELL. WHICH IS THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY.
LUCK WITH THEM AND THEY. VIVID
YEAH.
THE UPLAND VIA LOGICAL MUCH A.
OR AT THE MEZZALUNA.
MEAN THAT THE PRESS MINUTO.
WHEN THAT THE MORTARS EN EL
ESCUELA.
ONE OF THEM WOULD LEAVE OUT OF
OUR HOME.
I DON'T TOLD. PURSUE COMMUTER.
ROLANDO RIOS YES OF GAZA.
IT DOES HAVE THE DETAILS PUT
ICE.
SERVE THE PURPOSE.
IMMIGRANTS LIVE DAY BY DAY.
NIGHT BY NIGHT HOUR BY HOUR AND
MINUTE BY MINUTE.
WITH THE FEAR.
NOT BEING ABLE TO GO TO SCHOOL.
NOT BEING ABLE GROW THEIR JOB.
TWO DOCTORS ASSEMBLY. MEMBERS.
NEXT ALMOST ONE THOSE. BUT I DO
THAT.
WHEN THIS IS A REALLY GOT.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT THE PURPOSE
UNITS.
AND THEN WHY ISN'T THAT I WILL
ARGUE THAT IT ON CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE ANY OF THESE FUNDS.
TO HELP OUR FAMILIES.
TO FIGHT DEPORTATIONS.
FOR ALL FAMILIES ACROSS THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WITH THE HELP OF
ONE CALIFORNIA.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S.
THE LOS.
NO SECURE WILL GO CONCURRENT OF
THE STATUS.
BUT I I YOU THAT.
APPLE YET.
I WAS LIKE WE THAT.
SO COULD WE THAT.
MOST LOCAL MONEY THAT.
MY IS ONE THAT I REALLY.
INITIAL MOMENTOUS.
THAT'S YES.
IS DONE IN A SURPLUS EUNICE.
GOD DID NOT MISS MAKE A MISTAKE
BY PLACING EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU IN THIS POSITION.
STAND WITH US.
TO PROTECT OUR COMMUNITY TO
PROTECT YOUR COMMUNITY.
WE'RE PRAYING FOR YOU AND WE
THANK YOU FOR THE SERVICES THAT
YOU'VE DONE.
GOOD EVENING I'M FATHER R.
GRANDMA HAY I'M THE PASTOR AT
SAINT ANTHONY CLEAR AT CHURCH.
AND I MEANT ONE OF THE STEERING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT THE.
PRESIDENT COUNTY.
LEGAL DEFENSE FUND.
AND THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK. HAVE I SPEAK PRIMARILY AS
A PASTOR.
PART OF IT IS.
YOU KNOW HOW TO HOW TO HELP
PEOPLE LOVE AND MAKE THIS WORLD
A BETTER PLACE.
.
PART OF THAT IS IS.
KEEPING FAMILIES TOGETHER.
AND MAYBE IF SEVERAL WEEKS AGO
MAYBE JANUARY.
DURING THE HOMILY AYE I JUST
ASK OUR TEN O'CLOCK MASS BECAUSE
IT'S FULL OF THOSE RALLY SIX
HUNDRED PEOPLE.
AT THAT MASS I JUST SAID HOW
MANY OF YOU. KNOW.
OF.
SOMEONE WHO IS FEARFUL THAT A
FAMILY MEMBER WILL BE DEPORTED.
AND NINE OUT OF TEN.
NINE OUT OF TEN IT YOU KNOW
WHERE IT WHICH.
A.
I DO KNOW IS GONNA BE THAT HIGH.
AND SO THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS WERE
FEARFUL OF GOING TO THE GROCERY
STORE THEY GO SEPARATELY.
YOU KNOW IN CASE ONE OF THEM
GETS CAUGHT A THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS TO. A MOTHERS AND
FATHERS WHO.
HERE WELL WHAT WILL HAPPEN IF
IF I GET.
IF I GET DEPORTED WHAT WHO'LL
TAKE CARE MY KIDS.
HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO.
.
ARE.
AFRAID OF YOU KNOW LOSING THE
BREADWINNER.
YOU HAVE FAMILIES.
IT'S PROBABLY A MATT AND
IMAGINAL THAT YOU KNOW YOU'RE
SEPARATED FROM. YOUR CHILDREN.
.
SO THAT'S
MY CONGREGATION.
AND NINETY NINETY FIVE NINETY
FIVE PERCENT MEXICAN MEXICAN
AMERICAN.
I I REALLY I'M PART OF THE
STEERING COMMITTEE BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT BY.
INCREASING THIS CAPACITY BY
GIVING PEOPLE LEGAL DEFENSE.
THAT IT WILL HELP KEEP FAMILIES
TOGETHER.
I THINK THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
AND I'D I HOPE YOU DO THE RIGHT
THING.
AND HELP US.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME SIAM.
EXPERIENCING OF FIRSTHAND FROM
THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHAT'S GOING
ON.
IT'S JUST.
IT THE FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE NOT
GOING BASED OFFICES STATISTICS
NOT GOING BASED OFF WHAT YOU
HEAR IN THE MEDIA AND ONGOING
BASED OFF ANYTHING ELSE IT'S
FIRSTHAND EXPERIENCE.
THAT THIS IS WHAT WE NEED.
WE'RE TRYING TO DO THINGS THE
RIGHT WAY.
SO THIS JUST IS A BIG STEP
TOWARDS THOUGHT.
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY THINK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS I AM A
MARTINEZ LOT I WORK WITH A FAITH
IN THE VALLEY. AND.
I WAS ABLE TO.
SPEAK TO INDIVIDUALS.
THAT HAD BEEN AFFECTED BY
SOMEONE BEING DETAINED IN THEIR
HOME.
EVERYTHING FROM AN EIGHT MONTH
OLD AND SHE WAS PREGNANT EIGHT
MONTHS.
SHE HAD A GUN POINTED TO HER
FACE.
ATTIRE OF THE FATHER OF A CHILD
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS.
A INDIVIDUAL WITH DHAKA WHO WAS
PROMISED TO BE PROTECTED.
CALLISON A. ARE NOW IN
DETENTION.
LEAVING THE FAMILY TO COME UP
WITH FOUR TO SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS CSH FOR BOND.
IT'S NOT FOR LEGAL DEFENSE
THAT'S TO COME UP WITH BOND TO
RELEASE THE INDIVIDUALS.
SO NOW THEY ARE FACED WITH HOW
DO WE COME UP WITH THE MONEY FOR
LEGAL REPRESENTATION.
I WON'T TELL YOU GUYS THE
STORIES OF EVERY SINGLE ONE
INDIVIDUAL THAT IS NOW
STRUGGLING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO. FIGHT THEIR
LOVED ONES CASE BECAUSE REALLY
IF THEY WERE HERE THE LINE
REALLY WOULD GO OUT THE DOOR.
THAT'S HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS I'VE
TALKED TO FIRSTHAND THAT ARE
STRUGGLING TO FIGURE THIS OUT.
SO WHEREIN CRISIS MODE RIGHT
NOW.
BUT WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO FIGURE OUT HOW THE.
DO THIS LONG TERM.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT ONLY
TAKING CARE OF OUR FAMILIES WERE
TAKING CARE OF THE GENERATIONS
TO COME. SO THINK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
I'M IN A BRING IT BACK UP TO THE
DYESS AND.
.
I WAS REMEMBERING A STORY WHEN
THE FATHER WAS SPEAKING.
ACTUALLY REMINDED ME OF MY
FATHER WHO IS WATCHING MY KIDS
AT THE TIME AND WHEN I CAME HOME
HE WAS. SHARING WITH THEM AND
RECOUNTING WHAT HAPPENED IN
DILLON.
AND IN I WAS BORN IN THAT CITY
MY. FATHER WAS A LAWYER FOR CRLA
IN THAT CITY FIGHTING FOR.
IMMIGRANTS RIGHTS A GENERATION
AGO.
AND.
YOUR PROPOSAL HERE TODAY WILL
HELP US TO DEAL WITH MUCH OF THE
FEAR THAT OUR COMMUNITY IS
FACING.
AND I AM PROUD OF YOUR ABILITY
TO COME AND BRING A VOICE TO IT.
AND THAT.
WE WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN FOR
NOW BUT LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU AS
THIS PROGRESSES.
WITH THAT WE WILL MOVE TO ISSUE
A TICKET
.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH BENITO
JANE IF THAT'S OKAY AND THEN
CRISTINA MANSFIELD.
GREAT THANK YOU AND SO YES MY
NAME'S BENITO JAN I'M WITH THE
IMMIGRANT FAMILY DEFENSE FUND.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK
TO YOU TODAY.
WE LAUNCHED A LITTLE OVER A
YEAR AGO TO SUPPORT OAKLAND AND
NOW ALL OF ALAMEDA COUNTY.
FAMILIES THAT ON IMMIGRATION
CRISIS AND SPECIFICALLY I HAVE
FAMILIES WHO HAD A LOVED ONE WHO
IS IN IMMIGRATION DETENTION. AND
TODAY WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA HAS
REQUEST FOR A FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET APPROPRIATION FOR
AN IMMIGRATION BOND FUNDS.
THIS BOND FUND WOULD OFFER
RECOVERABLE GRANTS TO NONPROFITS
TO ENABLE THEM TO POST
IMMIGRATION BOND FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND PEOPLE. AYE WHO
ARE DETAINED IN ICE FACILITIES
WERE DETAINED IMMIGRATION AT AN
IMMIGRATION DETENTION IN
CALIFORNIA.
QUITE ABLE TO GET OUT BECAUSE I
THEY CAN'T AFFORD THE BOND
AMOUNTS THAT HAVE BEEN SET BY
ICE OR HAVE BEEN SET BY AN
IMMIGRATION JUDGE YOU JUST HEARD
JUST TWO MINUTES AGO THAT YOU
KNOW THAT WE'RE SEEING. BOND
AMOUNTS THAT ARE FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS OR MORE AND
PEOPLE OFTEN HAVE TO MAKE A
CHOICE BETWEEN. PAYING THIS IF
SURPLUS SOMEHOW FINDING MONEY
AND TO GET THEIR LOVED ONE OUT
OF DETENTION OR HIGHER
IMMIGRATION LAWYER OR PAY THEIR
RENT OR SOME BECAUSE YOU KNOW
ANY COMPETITION CAN IMAGINE.
IN OUR CASE OLIVER FAMILIES
HAVE SCHOOL AGE KIDS AND ALAMEDA
COUNTY MOST AND THERE WERE
TALKING ABOUT
YOU KNOW MOSTLY PEOPLE FROM MICK
STATUS FAMILIES MEANING PEOPLE.
UP WHO HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
MIGHT BE LAWFUL PERMANENT
RESIDENTS OR CITIZENS
UNDOCUMENTED A COMBINATION.
FORTY TWO PERCENT HAVE U. S.
CITIZEN KIDS WERE TALKING ABOUT
LAWFUL PERMANENT RESIDENTS WERE
FACING DEPORTATION VETERANS
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS THAT OF
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR SOME KIND OF
STATUS HERE. PEOPLE FLEEING
PERSECUTION APPLYING FOR ASYLUM
WHILE WE'RE FACING DETENTION
FROM OUR ON SITE FACING
DEPORTATION FROM BEHIND BARS.
AND YOU KNOW GETTING BOND
SUPPORT BUT WE'VE SEEN THAT OUR
FAMILIES AND OTHERS.
IS GETTING BOND SUPPORT HAS
BEEN CRITICAL TO PUTTING PEOPLE
IN THE BEST POSSIBLE WAY TO
FIGHT. THEIR CASES FROM FREEDOM
SO I HAVE NO I'M JUST THINKING
OF OUR FAMILIES WILL WORK WITH
RECENTLY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
A DAD WHO'S BEEN ABLE TO BE
PRESENT FOR HIS DOCUMENTED
DAUGHTER'S WEDDING A DAD WHO WAS
ABLE TO REUNITE WITH HIS KIDS
AFTER MONTHS OF BEING SEPARATED.
OTHER WAS ASSEMBLING UP IN
OAKLAND STUDENTS WHO WAS
BASICALLY A FATHER FIGURE IN HIS
HOUSEHOLD BEING ABLE TO BE
RELEASED AND.
AND.
HOPING HIS MOM NOW TAKE CARE OF
HIS YOUNGER SIBLINGS GOTTEN. YOU
GUYS HAVE BEEN HERE ALL DAY SO
WE KNOW WHEN I HAD TO THE
EVENING.
TOO MUCH BUT JUST TO SAY THAT
THE ABILITY TO FIGHT DEPORTATION
FROM FREEDOM MAKES SUCH A BIG
DIFFERENCE IN PEOPLE'S ABILITY
TO WHEN. PEOPLE ARE MORE LIKELY
TO GET BECAUSE EVEN IF YOU HAVE
COUNSEL IF
YOU'RE IN DETENTION IT'S HARDER
TO WIN YOUR CASE.
THERE WAS A STUDY THAT STANFORD
DEAD A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO WHERE
IT LOOKED AT OUT DEPORTATION
CASES IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND FOUND THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE
DETAINED AND HAVE COUNSEL THIRTY
THREE PERCENT ARE AYE AND OF
WINNING THEIR DEPORTATION CASES.
PEOPLE WHO WERE DETAINED THEN
WERE RELEASED TO HAVE COUNSEL. I
EIGHTY SEVEN PERCENT OF PEOPLE
WONDER HE SAYS YOU KNOW THIRTY
THREE PERCENT EIGHTY SEVEN
PERCENT IT'S SUCH. A BIG
DIFFERENCE.
SO YOU KNOW I GUESS
JUST TO WRAP BROUGHT IT UP TO
CRISTINA CAN ALSO TALK.
.
I THINK THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA AS
BUDGET REQUEST HERE IS
INCREDIBLY TIMELY. AGAIN SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE DETAINED IN
CALIFORNIA EVERY YEAR. AND WE
EXPECT THESE NUMBERS TO SPIKE
GIVEN THE. DRASTIC INCREASE AND
PEOPLE WERE BEING DETAINED BY
ICE AND GIVEN.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
REQUEST FOR INCREASED MONEY FOR
DETENTION POT. INSTANT THAT WERE
HOPING YOU'LL CONSIDER AND BE
SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
AND GOOD EVENING ESTEEMED
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND I'M
CRISTINA MANSFIELD ON THE CO
FOUNDER AND CO EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF FREEDOM FOR
IMMIGRANTS. FORMERLY KNOWN AS
CIVIC WHERE NATIONAL NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION DEVOTED TO ENDING
ARE PROFIT DRIVEN IMMIGRATION
DETENTION SYSTEM.
WHILE ALLEVIATING THE SUFFERING
OF PEOPLE CURRENTLY SUFFERING IN
THE SYSTEM AND WE DO THIS
THROUGH A VISITATION INDEPENDENT
MONITORING STORYTELLING AND
ADVOCACY.
WE'VE BEEN RUNNING A REVOLVING
IMMIGRATION DETENTION AND BOND
FUNDS SINCE TWO THOUSAND TEN
WHICH ALLOWS US TO FREE PEOPLE
FROM IMMIGRATION DETENTION AND
REUNITE THEM WITH THEIR FAMILIES
WHILE THEY SEEK LEGAL RELIEF IN
THEIR IMMIGRATION CASES.
IN TOTAL WE'VE REYES CLOSE TO A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS TO FREE
TWENTY NINE PEOPLE FROM
IMMIGRATION DETENTION. AND WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT ALL OF THE LOVED
ONES OF THESE PEOPLE THE EFFECT
OF PAYING IMMIGRATION BOND IS
EXPONENTIAL AND PROTECTING.
OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES FROM
UNNECESSARY HARM. UP ALL OF THE
PEOPLE WE'VE HELPED TO TO
RELEASE ARE PEOPLE WHO AN
IMMIGRATION JUDGE HAS DECIDED
ARE NEITHER DANGER.
NOR A FLIGHT RISK.
AND ALL THE PEOPLE WE'VE HELPED
TO RELEASED FROM DETENTION WOULD
HAVE.
REMAINS IN PRISON FOR MONTHS OR
YEARS.
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY'RE POOR.
THIS GOES AGAINST OUR VALUES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SINCE DONALD TRUMP WAS ELECTED
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS ROLLED
BACK MANY THE STEVE SAFEGUARDS
PROTECTIONS AND AVENUES FOR
RELEASE OF PEOPLE IN DETENTION.
AS A RESULTS AND PEOPLE ARE
EITHER LANGUISHING IN PRISON FOR
YEARS OR OTHER FOR FORCED TO
WORK WITH EXTREMELY EXPLOITIVE
COMPANIES LIKELY BREAK BY THE
ACCESS.
WHICH CHARGE.
UNBELIEVABLE RATES FOR THEIR
SERVICES OF ACTING AS.
BAIL BONDSMAN IN IMMIGRATION
DETENTION SPACE.
SO NO MATTER WHAT SIDE OF THE
POLITICAL AISLE YOU SIT ON WE
CAN PROBABLY ALL AGREE THAT THE
SYSTEM IS A OWES A WASTE OF OUR
FEDERAL TAXPAYER DOLLARS. OUR
SPENDING APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED
SIXTY FOUR DOLLARS A DAY TO
IMPRISON PEOPLE IN DETENTION. M.
ALTERNATIVES COST A FRACTION OF
THIS IN APPROVED HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE IN MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE COMPLY WITH THEIR
PROCEEDINGS.
SO BY SPONSORING A STATE FUNDED.
.
REVOLVING IMMIGRATION BOND FROM
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WILL BE
LEADING THE WAY AND
DEMONSTRATING THAT IMMIGRATION
DETENTION ISN'T NECESSARY TO
INSURE COMPLIANCE WITH ANNA
IMMIGRATION LEGAL PROCEEDINGS.
AND PROVIDING A MODEL AND DATA
FOR HOW WE CAN CREATIVELY REFORM
THE SYSTEM FEDERALLY.
I THINK GIL.
WORKLIGHT BORN MERCIFUL RELEASE
AND COME TO.
HERE TO THE DEPARTMENT
RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
ISSUE AND AS A MATTER OF FACT.
IS PART OF THE FUNDING CYCLE
THIS YEAR A PRIORITIZE BOND
HEARINGS BY MAKING IT A
STANDALONE SERVICE THAT COULD
BE.
COULD BE OFFERED IN RECOGNITION
OF THE MUCH IMPROVED OUTCOMES
THAT IMMIGRANTS FACE IF THEY ARE
RELEASED RELEASED FROM BOND AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING FOR
THE CONVERSATION ABOUT THE.
THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA A.
PAINTINGS OF STILL REVIEWING THE
PROPOSAL LOOKS FORWARD TO
REVIEWING THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THANK YOU ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE EIGHTEEN.
GOOD EVENING AGAIN I'M SALLY CAN
NATIONAL FROM THE IMMIGRANT
LEGAL RESOURCE CENTER.
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BOND BUDGET REQUEST AS WRITTEN
AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN ALL TOO
FREQUENTLY MOTHERS FATHERS SIT
AND SIBLINGS REMAIN DETAINED FOR
MONTHS OR EVEN YEARS AS THEY.
FIGHTER DEPORTATION CASE BEHIND
BARS UP BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
ABLE TO POST BOND.
THIS TAKES A SEVERE MENTAL TOLL
AND MANY PEOPLE EVEN GIVE UP
MERITORIOUS CASES SO THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE TO REMAIN
INCARCERATED AND SEPARATED FROM
THEIR FAMILIES.
IMPORTANTLY PEOPLE ONLY
RECEIVED BOND AFTER ICE OR AN
IMMIGRATION JUDGE HAS DETERMINED
THAT THE INDIVIDUAL SHOULD AND
CAN BE RELEASED AND THERE AND AT
THAT POINT THERE ONLY PENDING
PAYMENT OF THE BOND TO BE
RELEASED FROM DETENTION.
AS THIS BUDGET REQUEST PROCEEDS
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
ENSURE THAT OUR REMAINS AS
INCLUSIVE AS POSSIBLE WITHOUT
ANY EXCEPTIONS DICTATING WHO IS
DESERVING AND WHO HAS NOT. OUR
BELIEF IS THAT EVERYONE DESERVES
A CHANCE TO BE BONDED OUT OF
DETENTION.
THE GAME.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
AND WANTED TO THANK THE
ADVOCATES AS WELL AS A SOMEONE
BONTA FOR BRINGING THIS ISSUE IT
IS QUITE TIME.
I WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
EIGHTEEN OPEN FOR NOW AND
CONCLUDE TODAY SOMEONE HERE
THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING OKAY